GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I WANT TO
WELCOME YOU ALL HERE TO THIS
VERY IMPORTANT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND FIRE --
ON ON OUR STATES WATERSHED AND
WATER SUPPLY.
THE DEVASTATING WILDFIRES IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS HAVE WIDESPREAD
IMPACTS RANGING FROM HEALTH TO
INSURANCE TO LOCAL PLANNING.
WE WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS BOTH IN BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE AND
THEN POLICY COMMITTEES ABOUT
WHAT ELSE THE STATE CAN DO TO
REDUCE.
THE IMPACT OF FIRE IN THE FUTURE
BUT TODAY WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT THE NATURAL
SOURCE IMPACTS.
IN THIS HEARING I HOPE TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WILDFIRE ARE
IMPACTING OUR NATURAL SOURCES.
HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT MAKE GRANTS FOR
THE CONSERVATION AND RESTORATION
OF FORESTS AND WATERSHEDS.
AND EXAMINE HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
THE EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS
OF THESE PROGRAMS SO THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS THIS CHALLENGE IN A
TIMELY WAY.
GIVEN THE POLICY OVER LATER THIS
TOPIC I AM.
VERY PLEASED AND WE'RE HONORED
TO HAVE --
OF THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING
JOINTLY WITH OUR ASSEMBLY
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE --
CHAIR FRIEDMAN FROM THAT
COMMITTEE IS HERE NOW AND TO TO
TO ONE OF OF SAFE YOU
INTRODUCTORY WORDS I JUST SAID
I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY I'M HAPPY THAT
ARE TOO COMMITTEES ARE --
JOINING TOGETHER TO HOLD A
HEARING ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
A WE LOVE OUR FARCE IN
CALIFORNIA --
AND I THINK EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN VERY
DISMAYED BY THE INCREASING
AMOUNT OF FOREST FIRES THAT WE
HAVE BEEN HAVING.
A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND THE
LARGEST FIRES IN CALIFORNIA'S
RECORDED HISTORY I'M CAL FIRE
KEEPS RECORDS ABOUT FIRES IN
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
THE AMOUNT OF FIRE THAT WE'RE
HAVING IS INCREASING AS WELL AS
THE FEROCITY OF THOSE FIRES.
AND WHAT SOME PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE.
IS THAT OUR WATERSHEDS WHICH ARE
IN THE FAR AS THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY FIRE OR THE MAJOR
SOURCE OF WATER RESOURCES FOR
CALIFORNIA SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF THE FIRES HAVING ON
OUR WATER RESOURCES --
BUT ALSO TO DISCUSS HOW CLIMATE
CHANGE WHICH IS BEEN FUELING
THESE FIRES IS EXPECTED TO
INCREASE THESE CHALLENGES IN THE
YEARS TO COME.
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK AGAIN
MISTER BLOOM --
FOR CONVENING THESE HEARINGS THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT HAVE
JOINED US THREE OF US AND MARK
STONE.
AND ALSO TO JUST REMIND EVERYONE
THAT IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS AN ACCIDENT
SEVERAL NEW LAWS. TO DEAL WITH
FORESTRY AND WITH WATER SHEDS
AND ALL OF THESE RESOURCES BUT
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO SO
I'M REALLY.
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO BE HERE TO
ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES AND START
THAT WORK THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE OR
MISERY THIS --
ANY ANY COMMENTS YOU THE TWO
WELL ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAYS ONE OF
OUR NEW MEMBERS OF BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE THIS IS HER
FIRST OFFICIAL MEETING AND I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO FIND --
TO OF BEING A PART OF THIS
COMMITTEE VERY --
EDUCATIONAL INTERESTING AND
PLACE WHERE --
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO ADD --
TO IMPORTANT WORK TO WELCOME
ABOARD.
AND WE'RE ALSO WELCOMING TODAY --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AS ONE OF
THE MEMBERS OF BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE --
THREE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ANY INTRODUCTORY REMARKS BUT WE
DO WANT --
TO WELCOME YOU AS YOU'RE SITTING
DOWN -- A TO
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE DID YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE.
TO LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT WAS DONE.
DURING SB NINE A ONE HEARINGS
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO SPECIALLY
TODAY'S.
THANK YOU THANK YOU--
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
OUR FIRST PANEL --
WE HAVE --
TO TO INDIVIDUALS TOM PORTER
WHO'S THE DIRECTORY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME APPOINTED CHIEF
PORTER AS DIRECTOR JUST COUPLE
WEEKS AGO --
JANUARY EIGHTH BEFORE THAT HE
WAS CHIEF OF STRATEGIC PLANNING
AT CALIFORNIA HEADQUARTERS.
SOUTHERN REGION CHIEF ASSISTANT
RE.
AND I USE ASSISTANT REGENCY FOR
THE SOUTHERN REGION.
MAYBE --
CORRECT ME ON THAT THAT'S THAT'S
A MOUTHFUL --
BUT YOU ARE ALSO --
SAN DIEGO UNIT FIRE CHIEF CHIEF
PORTERS DEPTH OF FIRE DEPARTMENT
MANAGEMENT EXPERTISE IS BALANCED
BY HIS FORESTRY BACKGROUND HE
REALLY HAS A A BROAD BACKGROUND
THAT'S APPLICABLE HERE.
OF HIS A RESERVATION REGISTERED
PROFESSIONAL FORESTER IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE FORESTRY
DEGREE FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY GO BEARS --
AND WE HAVE ALSO WITH US DR JIM
THORNE WHO IS A CLIMATE CHANGE
RESEARCHER AND MODELER AT UC
DAVIS -- AND
WHO HELPED NUMEROUS CALIFORNIA
STATE AGENCIES COLLECT AND
ANALYZE DATA TO DEVELOP
FRAMEWORKS FOR ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS INCLUDES DEVELOPING MAPS TO
HELP THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE ASSESS CLIMATE REST TO
NATURAL LANDS HELPING CAL FIRE
PROJECT WERE TREE SPECIES WILL
MOVE.
UNDER CLIMATE CHANGE AND DEVELOP
FOR CALTRANS HE WAS THE AUTHOR
AND EDITOR OF CALLIE PA'S
CLIMATE INDICATORS REPORT.
AND THE LEAD AUTHOR FOR THE
SUMMARY OF THE RECENT FOURTH
CLIMATE VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT
AND I WANT TO WELCOME YOU BOTH
BEFORE YOU BEGIN --
I JUST WANT TO SAY AT THE OUTSET
THAT -- I
HAVE A UNFORTUNATELY FAMILY
EMERGENCY THAT I HAVE TO ATTEND
TO TODAY AND I'LL BE LEAVING.
AT APPROXIMATELY --
TEN TWENTY FIVE BUT IS FRIEDMAN
WILL CARRY ON A MORE THAN
CAPABLE THE IN MY ABSENCE
[inaudible]
PLEASE CHIEF.
WELL THANK YOU AGAIN --
TOM PORTER A CAL FIRE DIRECTOR
AND FIRE CHIEF --
CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND CHAIR
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU FOR A FOR
HAVING ME HERE AND AND US HERE
FOR THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC --
AND REALLY LOOKING TOWARD TOWARD
THE FUTURE A AND UNDERSTANDING
WHERE --
WE'RE HAVING SOME DIFFICULTIES
OF CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED AND
OTHER -- IN
WATERSHED HEALTH AND WITH
[inaudible]
SO.
I THINK YOU I WANTED TO START
WITH -- A
KIND OF I LAY OUT OF OF WILD
FIRE IS A UBIQUITOUS PART OF
CALIFORNIA --
EVERY ACRE IN CALIFORNIA CANNON
WILL BURN AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE.
AND WE ARE UNFORTUNATELY JUST
SEEING THAT THAT RATE AND THAT
RETURN INTERVAL IS IS INCREASING
DRAMATICALLY IN THE IN THE
RECENT YEARS [inaudible]
WE'VE SEEN.
I DO TOO CLIMATE --
WILD SWINGS IN WEATHER PATTERNS
LESS SNOW IN THE HIGHER
ELEVATIONS --
LONGER --
AND MORE PERSISTENT DROUGHTS.
MORE -- WIND
EVENTS THAT ARE VERY DIFFICULT
TO CONTROL FIRE UNDER SANTANA'S.
NORTHERN WINDS UP HERE IN THIS
PART OF THE STATE AND SUNDOWNERS
AND THE CENTRAL COAST.
MORE OF THOSE DAYS ARE COMING ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS THAN WE ARE ARE
USED TO SEEING --
AND THEN THE BONE DRY FUELS.
AND WE'VE THE PERSISTENT DROUGHT
REALLY DRIED EVERYTHING TO BONE
DRY.
OF THE LARGE LOGS THAT ARE OUT
IN THE FOREST THE TREES THE THE
HUNDRED AND NOW FORTY SEVEN
MILLION TREES THAT ARE DEAD IN
THE FORESTS OF THE OF THE
CENTRAL SIERRA.
IT TAKES FOR THEM TO DRY OUT AND
IT TAKES MORE YEARS FROM THE FOR
THEM TO INCREASE IN MOISTURE
AGAIN.
SO THAT BONE DRY FUEL IS IS
BECOMING VERY AVAILABLE AND
MAKING A FIRE IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO CONTAIN.
A CLIMATE CHANGE HAS EXTENDED
OUR FIRE SEASON.
WE HAVE AN EARLIER START TO FIRE
SEASON AND AT A LATER AND AND
THAT'S THE PEAK SEASON AND WE'RE
FINDING THAT WE HAVE WILDFIRE
AND FIRE SEASON THAT'S CARRYING
THROUGHOUT THE SEIZE THAT
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
WE HAD A HUMBLE A FIRE IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY THIRTY ACRES --
OVER THE THE A CHRISTMAS AND NEW
YEAR'S HOLIDAY PERIOD --
THAT'S UNHEARD OF IN THE WETTEST
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HAPPENED IN THE MIDDLE OF WINTER
[inaudible]
SO.
WITH ALL OF THIS --
OF COURSE THE STATISTICS FROM
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS SHOW
THAT TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WAS.
AT THE TIME THE WORST FIRE.
SEASON IN HISTORY FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S OF COURSE ARE ARE
WRITTEN HISTORY --
WHEN WE'VE BEEN STE --
WORKING TO SUPPRESS FIRES AND
AND SUCH.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CAME
AROUND AND DWARFED.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BROKE ALL
RECORDS IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND WOULD
COME TO A POINT WHERE --
FIREFIGHTERS THAT HAD THIRTY
PLUS.
YEAR LONG CAREERS --
AND RENDON THOSE CAREERS SOME
TEN TWENTY YEARS AGO THEY TALKED
ABOUT CAREER FIRES.
WHEN I STARTED THE FIRE SERVICE
IT WAS ALWAYS THIS CAREER FIRE
CONCEPT CAREER FIRE THIS THE THE
BIG?
ONE YOU SEE EVERYBODY ON THAT
WAS A FIRE THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
FIFTY SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
ACRES AND BURNED.
MAYBE --
ANYWHERE FROM FIFTY TO A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY STRUCTURES THAT WAS A
CAREER FIRE.
NOW WE'RE HAVING MULTIPLE CAREER
FIRES EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND I
CANNOT REMEMBER THE LAST TIME.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS THAT I'VE
HEARD ANYBODY SAY.
THAT'S A CAREER FIRE.
WE DON'T EVEN USE IT IN THE FIRE
SERVICE ANYMORE IT IS IT'S A
RELIC.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY CONCERNING TO ME
[inaudible]
THE WATERSHED IMPACTS.
SO ALL OF THIS COMES WITH GREAT
IMPACTS.
TO WATERSHED.
AND WE STARTED OFF --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WITH THE
TRAGIC EVENTS IN MINAS SETO --
THAT WERE ON THE HEELS OF THE OF
THE THOMAS FIRE AT THE TIME THE
LARGEST FIRE IN HISTORY --
AND THEN THEN THEN THE DEBRIS
FLOWS. TO KILL PEOPLE DESTROYED
HOMES AND BECAUSE A LOT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE AS WELL.
WEARE SEEING ARE AND AND AND TO
BE CLEAR WHAT THE STATE HAS
RESPONDED TO THE LARGE FIRES IN
THE LAST --
FIVE OR SO YEARS WITH --
WIRED WATER WATERSHED EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TEAMS THAT GO AND IT'S
CAL FIRE AND ON THE CALIFORNIA --
GEOLOGIC SURVEY SURVEY WORKING
TOGETHER --
AND OTHER AGENCIES TO DETERMINE
WHAT CRITICAL AREAS ARE THAT
THAT COULD SEE THE DAMAGE OR
HIGH HIGH FLOW OF WATER DEBRIS
FLOWS THOSE KIND OF THINGS AND
OTHER DAMAGES THAT MIGHT HAVE
OCCURRED FROM.
THE FIRE ITSELF AND THEN AND
THEN --
IDENTIFY THOSE AND IDENTIFY
MITIGATION MEASURES WHERE WHERE
POSSIBLE AND AND A FEASIBLE.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT AND
AND THOSE TEAMS HAVE THEY HAVE
BECOME VERY CRITICAL TO OUR FIRE
RESPONSE AND ARE WATERSHED
EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS UTILIZE
THOSE SAME TYPES OF TEAMS TO
DETERMINE AHEAD OF AHEAD OF WILD
FIRES WHERE THOSE AREAS ARE WE
CAN DO THAT?
WE CAN AND ARE DOING THAT IN
SOME AREAS OF THE STATE --
PROACTIVELY TO DETERMINE WHAT
THE THE ISSUES MIGHT BE SHOULD
WE HAVE WATER A FIRE IN THOSE
AREAS.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING.
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO CONSIDER
MORE OF MOVING DOWN THE DOWN THE
ROAD.
IF YOU HAVEN'T.
READ JOHN MAKE FEES SHORT STORY
ON ON ON KIND OF WATER FLOW.
AND THE SENATE SAN GABRIEL
MOUNTAINS.
IN IN THE BOOK OR HIS BOOK.
THE CONTROL OF NATURE.
I WOULD ITS A SHORT PASSAGE IT'S
AT THE BACK END OF THE BOOK AND
IT'S WORTH THE READ BECAUSE
IT'LL GIVE YOU A VERY VERY VIVID.
PICTURE OF WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
FIRE WHEN WE HAVE THESE THESE --
COULD KIND OF RAIN ABOUTS THESE
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS.
SOMETHING JUST TO TO THINK ABOUT --
SO I THINK THE WITH THE
WATERSHED A PIECE OF THIS --
KIND OF ADDING TO THE THE
LONGEVITY OF OF THE DAMAGE THAT
WILD FIRES ARE CAUSING --
ON THE LANDSCAPE.
THE FINAL THING IT KIND OF COMES
BACK TO THAT CAREER FIRE COMMENT
THAT I MADE.
WHILE THE WHILE THE WATERSHED
AND THE LANDSCAPE IS IS BEING.
DAMAGED BY THESE THESE FIRES.
A AND THIS ACTIVITY.
SO TO OUR OUR FIREFIGHTING
RESOURCES ARE OUR HUMAN CAPITAL
THAT GOES.
TO RESPOND TO THESE EMERGENCIES
ARE ARE REALLY SEEING.
A DETRIMENTAL EFFECT TO THE THE
NUMBER AND THE LONGEVITY THAT
THEY'RE SPENDING ON INCIDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AGAIN.
NO LONGER IS THERE A CAREER FIRE.
THERE IS JUST CAREER SEASONS AND
IT JUST NEVER ENDS AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT --
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON GOING
FORWARD IS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OF OUR OF OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS ACROSS THE BOARD AS
LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRE --
FLOOD EVERYTHING.
INCLUDED.
AND WITH THAT --
I WILL CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DIRECTOR.
WELCOME.
ARE THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRESENT TO THE GROUP HERE.
AND I'LL TRY AND ADD A FEW
IMAGES.
TO OF WHAT TOM JUST SO
ELOQUENTLY.
OF REPRESENTED AND I'M GONNA TRY
AND FOCUS A LITTLE MORE ON THE
WATER SIDE OF OUR WATER SHEDS
AND THE WILDLIFE AND HABITAT
COMPONENT.
BUT THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL
TO JUST.
DO A LITTLE REVIEW.
IF I CAN GET THESE THIS QUICKER
TO WORK.
SO THIS IS A SLIDE THAT'S ABOUT
TWO YEARS OLD NOW BUT IT SHOWS
TEMPERATURE AND PRECIPITATION.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT ON THE RED
LINE THE TEMPERATURE IN
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN GOING UP AND
PRESET BOUNCES AROUND A LOT BUT
WE HAD THE FOUR YEAR DROUGHT.
THAT WAS FOLLOWED BY A TWO YEAR --
A DOUBLE NORMAL RAINFALL YEAR
LAST YEAR OF WHICH I THINK
PROBABLY GREW THE THATCH WHICH
HELPED TO INMATE IGNITE MANY OF
THE FIRES THAT ARE.
YOU WERE JUST DESCRIBING.
AND THEN I HAVE I HAVE A SERIES
OF MAPS YOU'RE THE TO JUST KIND
OF WALK THROUGH WHAT.
ARE SOME OF THE PROJECTED
FUTURES ARE AND I LIKE LOOKING
TOWARDS THE END OF CENTURY
BECAUSE THE THAT'S THE MOMENTUM.
EVEN IF WE MANAGED TO REDUCE OUR
EMISSIONS WE ARE STILL ON A
TRACK WHERE THERE'S GOING TO BE
A LOT OF CHANGE OVER THE THE
NEXT EIGHTY YEARS OR SO.
AND SO ON THE LEFT YOU SEE A
ANNUAL MEAN MINIMUM TURNED OUT
TO BE CRITICAL FOR MANY
ECOSYSTEMS --
AND MANY THINGS IN AGRICULTURE
AS WELL --
AND THEN IN THE CENTRAL PANEL
THAT'S THE CHANGE INTO --
AND CENTURY UNDER A WETTER
FUTURE AND ON THE RIGHT HAND
SIDE OF THE CHANGE. TO THE END
OF CENTURY UNDER A HOTTER FUTURE
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT SOME PLACES
ARE GOING TO BE.
UNDER A PARTICULAR HAVE IF WE
STAY ON THE HOTTER TRACK.
OF LARGE PARTS OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WILL BE NINE AND DEGREE
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT WARMER ON
NIGHT ON AVERAGE AT NIGHT SO
THAT'S THAT'S A PROJECTION THAT
THE THAT'S ON THE BOOKS NOW
RELATIVE --
TO THAT'S HOW MUCH WARMING WE
COULD SEE IN SOME PARTS OF WHAT
NINE DEGREES FAHRENHEIT.
I TRY TO PUT EVERYTHING INTO
FAHRENHEIT AND MILES HERE. TO
PRECIPITATION THERE'S ON THE
LEFT THERE'S CALIFORNIA'S
PRECEPT AND WE KNOW ALMOST NEVER
HAVE AN AVERAGE YEAR RIGHT.
BUT THAT'S SORT OF WHERE YOU SEE
MORE OR LESS AND THEN UNDER A
WETTER FUTURE IN THE CENTER YOU
SEE A A A LITTLE BIT OF BLUE IN
THERE THAT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
RAIN -- AND
UNDER A DRYER FUTURE BY THE
TRYING DOWN AND ONE OF THE
THINGS TO NOTICE THAT IN OUR
WETTEST PART AS YOU.
MENTIONED UP AROUND HUMBLE I WE
SEE A LOT OF DRY DOWN UNDER
UNDER ONE OF THESE.
CIRCULATION MODELS THAT HAS RAIN
NOT HITTING NORTHWESTERN
CALIFORNIA AS DEEPLY.
OKAY HERE'S RUNOFF OKAY WILL RUN
OFF A IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT'S
WHERE WE COLLECT THE WATER INTO
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEM THAT --
FUELS THE AGRICULTURE AND THE
THE CITIES IN THE NURSES THE
PEOPLE UP WATERS THE PEOPLE
SHALL WE SAY.
AND UNDER WHETHER FUTURE THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT MORE NOT
SURPRISINGLY UNDER DRYER FUTURE.
RUNOFF DECREASES OKAY WE EXPECT
THAT RIGHT [inaudible]
WELL OKAY.
AS WE GO ALONG WE'RE GOING SEE
MORE ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS AND MORE
DROUGHTS BECAUSE THINGS ARE
GETTING FLASHIER AND NOT ONLY
THAT BUT THE PULSE OF WATER MAY
BE MUCH MORE INTENSE SO NOT ONLY
WILL IT COME IN A SHORTER PERIOD
AND OUR FIRE SEASON BE LONGER.
BUT WE MAY SEE FLASH FLOODS OR
WE MAY SEE PULSES IN WHICH THE
OF RAINFALL THIS COMING IS
COMING MORE INTENSELY ON TO THE
LANDSCAPE.
AND SO WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
HOW DO WE WATER HOW DO WE MANAGE
OUR WATER SHEDS.
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE
FLEXIBILITY THE RESILIENCE TO
HANDLE BOTH PULSE ADVANCE AND
LONGER SEQUENCES OF DROUGHT.
OKAY SNOW PACK WILL SNOW PACK
WHETHER IT GETS WETTER OR DRYER
OUR SNOW PACK IS EXPECTED TO
DECREASE --
THIS CURRENT STORM NONE YOU KNOW
REGRET IT REGARDLESS OF THIS
CURRENT STORM --
AND SO YOU SEE HERE THAT BECAUSE
TEMPERATURES ARE WARMING AND ONE
OF THE NICKNAMES OF THIS YEAR'S
IS THE MOTHER RANGE BECAUSE IT'S
A RELATIVELY WARM MOUNTAIN RANGE
IN.
NORTH AMERICA --
THAT -- WILL
SEE A DECREASE SO THERE'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
WETTER DRIER FUTURE AND WHAT OUR
STORAGE OUR THIRD THIRD 30% OR
SO OF OUR WATER BUDGET THE COMES
AS SNOW.
WILL BE.
AND THEN HERE'S A A MEASURE OF
PLANT STRESS SO THE CLIMATIC
WATER DEFICIT AND IT'S
ESSENTIALLY HOW MUCH MORE WOULD
PLANTS LIKE --
TO EVAPORATE TRANSFEREE IF THEY
COULD -- IF
THE WATER WAS AVAILABLE IN THE
SOIL AND SO YOU CAN SEE ON THE
LEFT HAND SIDE.
YOU KNOW THE DESERT'S ARE REDDER
AND THE THE NORTH WEST CORNER IS
THE HAS THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
CLIMATIC WATER DEFICIT.
AND AGAIN IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHETHER WE SEE MORE OR LESS RAIN
OF PRECIPITATION.
PLANTS ARE GOING TO BE UNDER
HIGHER STRESS THAN THEY ARE NOW.
FOR OUR FORESTS GRASSLANDS
SCRUBLANDS THEY'RE ALL GOING TO
EXPERIENCE HIGHER STRESS AND
THAT'S BECAUSE TEMPERATURE IS
RAMPING UP FASTER THAN A
INCREASE IN WATER WOULD WOULD --
ALLOW FOR THEM TO KEEP UP WITH
THIRTY VAPID TRANSPIRATION SO WE
EXPECT TO SEE STRESS COMING INTO.
OUR FORESTS MORE AND MORE AND
TRIGGERING EVENTS LIKE DROUGHT
COULD OCCUR.
THEY MIGHT NOT THEY MIGHT NOT
NEED THE SAME INTENSITY OF
DROUGHT TO HAVE THE SAME LEVEL
OF A FACT IN TERMS OF MORTALITY
ON TREES AND STRESS ON TREES
THAT OPENS THE TREES UP.
FOUR BEATLES AND OTHER --
PATHOGENS RIGHT.
OKAY SO HERE'S SOME AN EXAMPLE
THAT SOME FORCE CHANGES ALREADY
HAPPENING THESE ARE --
BASED OFF OF NINETEEN THIRTY
SURVEY THAT WAS DONE --
IN CALIFORNIA AND COMPARING THE
MAP TO A CONTEMPORARY OF ABOUT.
TWO THOUSAND AND WHAT YOU SEE IS
THERE'S ABOUT ABOUT A THREE
HUNDRED FOOT TO TWO DEGREES.
OF NIGHT TIME WANTING TO DATE
THEIR RESPONSE TO THAT BUT IF
YOU HAVE A FIRE.
MAYBE THOSE FEELINGS ARE NOT
COMING BACK AND SO THIS STARTS
TO LEAD US INTO WE CAN EXPECT TO
SEE CHANGES IN COMPOSITION IN
OUR OUR FORESTS AND SPECIES MAY
BE A OF FORCE TREES MAY MOVE
AROUND.
AND THE MIX OF HARDWOODS TO CON
OFFERS IN THIS YEAR'S OR THE
LOCATIONS OF OUR BIG OAK
SAVANNAS THE BLUE OAK WOODLANDS
THAT RING THE CENTRAL VALLEY --
THOSE TYPES OF HABITATS MAY
BEGIN -- TO
CHANGE AND SO THEN THE QUESTION
ARISES OF WHERE DO WE WHERE
COULD WE RETAIN THEM.
AND WHERE ARE EVER PLACES THAT.
EVEN IF WE PUT ENORMOUS
RESOURCES IT MIGHT NOT LOOK THE
SAME FIFTY YEARS FROM NOW THAT
IT LOOKS TODAY.
AND HOW DO WE FIGURE THAT OUT
AND THEN HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT
FROM A WATERSHED PERSPECTIVE.
AND I THINK YOU'LL HEAR SOME
VERY COMPELLING STORIES LATER IN
THE DAY WITH REGARDS --
TO A DOCTOR NORSE AYE IDEAS OF
MANAGING FORESTS AND MANAGING
THE BLACK IN THE GREEN THAT WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE
REDUCE DEEP DEBRIS FLOWS AND GET
IN THERE AFTER FIRES WE ALSO
NEED TO MANAGE THE GREEN.
AND WE NEED TO DO THOSE THINGS
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS SO I
HAVE TO TOP SLIDE WITH SOME TEXT
I APOLOGIZE WALK US THROUGH --
* SO WHERE EACH OF THESE SNOW
PACK WE LOSE OUR SNOW PACK
MEADOWS ARE GOING TO BE THE LET
THE NEXT SPONGES THAT COLD WATER
ON THE LANDSCAPE WE WANNA HOLD
WATER ON THE LANDSCAPE AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. TO PREVENT IT THE
THE INCREASED SPEED OF OF
VELOCITY OF WATER MOVING THROUGH
OUR SYSTEMS NOT BEING ABLE TO
RETAIN IT FOR GROUND WATER
RECHARGE OR FOR ECOSYSTEM HEALTH.
FOR HUMAN USES SO MEADOWS BECOME
META RESTORATION BECOMES AN
INTERESTING.
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT CARRY IN AREAS
OF GETTING INTO THE RIGHT PARIAN
AREAS AND MAKING THEM MORE
RESILIENT --
TO WITHSTAND DEBRIS FLOWS AND TO
TO REDUCE EROSION BECAUSE
EROSION COMING INTO OUR DAM
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE A LARGE
PROBLEM SO HOW DO YOU --
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT OUR
WATERSHEDS HOLISTICALLY BECAUSE
OF ALL OF THESE PIECES
CONTRIBUTE AND THEY RELATE TO
EACH OTHER WHILE THE HELL SLIPS
THAT'S WHERE YOU MIGHT BE
THINKING ABOUT --
MANAGING OUR WOODLANDS WELCOME
OTHER PLACES WE CAN PUT IN
SHADED FUEL BREAKS OTHER PLACES --
WHEN WE LOOK AT RECOVERING OF
FROM A YOUR TOWN RECOVERING LIKE
LIKE A PARADISE?
WHAT COULD WE DO ON THE
LANDSCAPE THAT THAT BUILDS
RESILIENCE INTO THAT WHOLE
LANDSCAPE AND AND MAKES IT A
LITTLE BIT LESS SUSCEPTIBLE AND
ONE OF THE PLACES THAT YOU WANT
TO GO FIRST TO DO THAT?
IF YOU HAD HE GAVE ME A MILLION
BUCKS AND SIT AND SAID OKAY GO
OUT AND DO IT NOW WHAT PLACES
WHEN I PICKED BECAUSE I'M ONLY
GONNA GET A LITTLE TINY PART OF
THE FORCE THAT FIRST YEAR ON
THAT PERSONALLY.
RIGHT OKAY SO WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT MANAGING OUR WATER SHEDS.
LOOKING AT THEM HOLISTICALLY --
IMPROVE THE WATER RETENTION ON
THESE LANDSCAPES BECAUSE OF THE
THE CLIMATE --
PRESSURES THAT ARE COMING.
SO I THINK THAT'S MORE OR LESS
WHAT'S ON THAT SLIDE.
AND LET'S JUMP TO THE LATTER THE
SECOND TO LAST.
SO.
HOW DOES THIS RELATE TO
VEGETATION AND TWO SPECIES WELL
CHANGES IN THE SPECIES MIX ARE
COMING WILL WE'RE LIKELY TO SEE
THAT IN DIFFERENT PLACES?
ARE AND SPECIES ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO TRY TO TRACK THEIR
SUITABLE CLIMATES.
THERE ARE THERE HOWEVER THERE
ARE PLACES WHICH APPEAR TO BE
MORE STABLE BY THE END OF
CENTURY AND THAT AT THOSE MAY BE
THE PLACES WHERE.
IF YOU HAVE A DOG FOR FORCE NOW
IT COULD STILL BE A DOG FOR FOR
US BECAUSE THE GENERAL
CONDITIONS ARE WITHIN THE RANGE
THAT DOG.
FOR OUR EXPERIENCE IS NOW AND
OTHER PLACES WERE DUG FOR CURSES
IT PROBABLY IS.
GOING TO BE OUTSIDE OF THAT
CLIMATE CONDITIONS.
I AND THEN AND THOSE WOULD BE
THE ZONES OF TRANSITION AND SO
THE IF WE THINK OF THE LANDSCAPE
IN TERMS OF WHERE THE REFUGIO
WHERE THE PLACES WE WANT TO
RETAIN.
WHERE THE PLACES THAT WE EXPECT
TO CHANGE AND MAYBE IT'S GOING
TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE --
TO TO SEE THAT CHANGE TO TRY.
TO THAT THE THOSE ARE --
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS --
AND AND THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT
FOR COMMUNITIES.
A AND THEN WITH REGARDS TO
WILDLIFE SIMILARLY THERE ARE
PLACES WHERE THE HABITATS THAT
ARE [inaudible]
ANIMALS.
OCCUPY OUR WILD ARE WILDLIFE
OCCUPIES OUR LOOK APPEAR TO BE
CLIMATICALLY STABLE OVER THE
NEXT EIGHTY YEARS AND THERE'S
OTHER PLACES WHERE --
THOSE SIMILARLY I MEANS THE
VEGETATION IS THE HABITAT OF WE
EXPECT THOSE PLACES TO CHANGE
AND SO THEY MIGHT NOT BE
SUITABLE FOR SOME SPECIES.
AND SO CORRIDORS AND
CONNECTIVITY LOOKING AT THE
LANDSCAPE FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF OUR WHAT ARE THE PLACES THAT
YOU WANTED RETAIN IN SOME KIND
OF NATURAL CONDITION.
SO THAT SPECIES CAN MOVE FROM
WHERE THEY CURRENTLY CAN PERSIST.
TO OTHER PLACES WHERE THEY MAY
BE ABLE TO PERSIST IN THE FUTURE.
THESE ARE A VERY ACTIVE RESEARCH
TOPICS AND THEY WERE ADDRESSED
IN THE FOURTH CLIMATE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT TO SOME
DEGREE THEY ARE CAL FIRE HAS HAD
AN ACTIVE INTEREST IN THESE
TYPES OF RESOURCE MANAGEMENT.
CALIFORNIA FISH AND WILDLIFE HAS
SIMILARLY SO I THINK THE
AGENCIES ARE ALREADY ENGAGED
WITH MANY OF THESE CHALLENGES.
AND I'VE I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY --
TO TRY TO PRESENT THOSE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I WONDER IF YOU COULD GO INTO A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL ABOUT --
HOW AND PERHAPS BOTH OF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A CRACK AT
THIS QUESTION HOW WORK CURRENTLY
PRIORITIZING THAT TED?
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE HAVE --
GIVEN THE FACT THAT EVEN WITH
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES --
OF THAT HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS THERE STILL.
ARE LIMITATIONS.
AS DOES THE QUESTION --
IS RELATED TO MANAGEMENT I'LL
TAKE THAT FIRST.
FLEAS AND SO --
WHAT WHAT CAL FIRE IS DOING IS
IS --
THROUGH THE FUNDING THAT THAT
HAS COME THROUGH --
GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDING.
AND OTHER --
MECHANISMS --
WE HAVE BEEN PUTTING A LOT OF
THAT TO WORKING DIRECTLY INTO --
WATERSHED BASS LANDSCAPE LEVEL
RESILIENCE WORK --
SO -- I'LL
AND I'LL COME BACK TO IT BUT
THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
EXPENDED IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS --
COMING GOING FORWARD WE HAVE --
TWO HUNDRED MILLION --
FOR EACH OF THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
TO TOTAL OF AN ADDITIONAL
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
INVESTMENT IN THIS TYPE OF OF
LANDSCAPE LEVEL.
OF FOREST WORK.
AND BECAUSE SOME OF THAT WILL BE
FOCUSED IN IN IN AND AROUND
COMMUNITIES BUT BY AND LARGE THE
THE LARGE SCALE PROJECTS ARE
GOING TO BE OUT IN THE IN THE
BROADER LANDSCAPE WATERSHED
RELATED.
AND LOOKING TO ESTABLISH --
PRIORITIES --
THAT THAT.
ACT AS ANCHOR POINTS AND THEN
MORE WORK --
EXPANDS FROM.
ALL OF OUR EFFORTS IN --
IT DEVELOPING OUR GRANT PROGRAMS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS --
AND HAVE HAVE BEEN TO THAT AND
WE HAVE BEEN DOING COMPETITIVE
GRANTS WE ALSO HAVE DONE BEEN
DOING DIRECT FUNDING --
WE WILL CONTINUE AND DO MORE
CORRECT SURE --
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOW IDENTIFIED
WHERE THOSE ANCHOR POINTS ARE WE
KNOW WE NEED TO PUT --
PROJECT WORK AND AND MONEY INTO
THOSE AREAS TO ESTABLISH A
REALLY GOOD FOOTHOLD TO THEN
SPREAD FROM.
ALL OF THESE EFFORTS ARE
COORDINATED WITH OUR FOR SERVICE --
COUNTERPARTS REGION FIVE FOR
SERVICE --
SO THEY HAVE THEIR OWN PROJECTS --
WE HAVE ARE PROJECTS WE PUT OUR
MAPS TOGETHER WE WE INVITE IN
THIS YEAR PROJECT PACIFIC
INDUSTRIES AND OTHER TIMBER
COMPANIES ALSO WHO SHOW US WHAT
THEY'RE DOING --
BOTH IN THEIR TIMBER HARVESTING
PLANNING --
THEIR THINNING AND THEIR FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECTS AND THAT'S
HOW WE'RE COMING TO THE TO
IDENTIFY THOSE AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE ANCHOR POINTS THAT WE CAN
THEN STE.
SPREAD THAT WORK OUT FROM AND
REALLY HAVE.
BROAD LANDSCAPE LEVEL WATERSHED.
AND FORCED RESILIENCE --
AFFECT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD HOW ABOUT YOU I THINK YOU
COVERED IT REALLY WELL.
GREAT -- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS MISS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
AND THOSE WERE BOTH REALLY
EXCELLENT PRESENTATIONS VERY
HELPFUL THANK YOU --
I WAS PARTICULARLY INTRIGUED
WITH THE NOTION OF TRYING TO PUT
OUR RESOURCES INTO.
THE AREAS THAT WE THINK ARE
GOING -- TO
CHANGE THE LEASE --
THAT'S A GREAT WAY TO TO THINK
ABOUT --
FOCUSING AND PRIORITIZING I HAVE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR THE CHIEF
OF FIRST OF ALL HOW DOES CALL
FIRE DECIDE --
TO A PORTION THE G. G. R. F..
APPROPRIATIONS BETWEEN THE LOCAL
FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS AND
FOREST HEALTH GRANTS DO YOU HAVE
SOME SORT OF FORMULA THAT YOU
USE OR HOW DO YOU MAKE THOSE
SORTS OF DECISIONS THAT THAT IS
A GREAT QUESTION --
AND WILL WE WE DON'T PRE
DETERMINED HOW MUCH IS GOING TO
GO -- TO THE
LOCAL --
VERSUS THE LANDSCAPE LEVEL --
WE BRING IN APPLICATIONS --
FROM BOTH A AND THIS IS IN THE
COMPETITIVE ROUND.
SO -- WHEN
WE'RE DOING THE COMPETITIVE
GRANTS WE WE WE BRING IN FRONT
THROUGH TWO DIFFERENT TWO
SEPARATE PROCESSES LANDSCAPE
LEVEL AND THEN MORE OF THE
COMMUNITY BASED?
AND THEN WE WE PRIORITIZE THOSE --
FROM TOP TO BOTTOM --
IT AND THEN WE DETERMINE BASED
ON THE QUALITY OF APPLICATION
AND THE QUALITY OF OF PROJECT --
AS DETERMINED BY SCREENING AT
THE LEVEL.
THE REGIONAL LEVEL AND THEN ALSO
THE SACRAMENTO LEVEL.
WE DETERMINE WHICH WHICH WHICH
ONES WHERE THE KIND OF THE BREAK
OFF POINT IS IN IN THE THE BEST
OF THE BEST.
AND IN BOTH CATEGORIES AND THEN
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS IT'S IT'S
BROKEN ALMOST EVENLY --
THEIR SPEND ABOUT FIFTY TO ADD A
LITTLE BIT LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
50% -- IN
THE THE LANDSCAPE LEVEL AND THEN
THE OTHER IN IN THE KIND OF
AROUND COMMUNITIES BUT IT'S
STILL A FOREST'S TREATMENT IT'S
NOT IT JUST HAPPENS TO BE CLOSER --
TO TO WHERE PEOPLE ARE LIVING.
IN THOSE --
PREVENTION TYPE OF OF GRANTS --
IT SHOULD ALSO BE NOTED THAT --
NOT A FORTY THAT HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE
EXPANDED SUSS THUS FAR OR IS
OBLIGATED THUS FAR --
IT HAS GONE ON TO FEDERAL LANDS
IN THOSE FEDERAL LANDS WHILE
THEY ARE NEAR COMMUNITIES THEY
ARE THEY ARE MORE OF THAT
LANDSCAPE LEVEL --
PROJECT WORK.
GREAT THANK YOU AND WONDERED IF
YOU COULD JUST TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW ANY OF YOUR FOREST
HEALTH PROJECTS AND IF YOU'VE
SEEN ANY TANGIBLE BENEFITS AT
THIS POINT AND WHAT THOSE WOULD
BE.
ABSOLUTELY --
UP THE HIGHWAY FIFTY CORRIDOR --
WE HAVE HAD BEEN PUTTING A LOT
OF EFFORT --
BOTH OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND AND CAL FIRE --
AND OTHER LOCAL --
LOCALS HAVE ALSO BEEN PUTTING
MONEY INTO PROJECTS.
TO PROTECT THE COMMUNITIES AND
THE CORRIDOR ALONG A HIGHWAY
FIFTY IT'S THAT'S ONE OF THOSE
ANCHOR POINTS HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT.
AND WHILE THERE'S THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT --
POPULATION THAT'S THAT'S IN THE
THE LITTLE COMMUNITIES ALONG
HIGHWAY --
FIFTY A LOT OF THAT IS
COMBINATION --
FIRE PREVENTION AND LANDSCAPE
LEVEL TREATMENT WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING SO THAT'S THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE A DINKY CREEK WHICH IS A
COLLABORATIVE DOWN AND YOUR
SHAVER LAKE IN FRESNO COUNTY --
THAT IS A COLLABORATIVE WITH THE
FOR SERVICE THAT WE'RE DOING
UNDER A GOOD NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY --
AND THEN THERE ARE OTHERS AS
WELL THESE ARE THE AREAS WHERE
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE SEEING ANCHOR
POINTS THAT WE CAN REALLY.
COME TOGETHER --
AS MULTIPLE AGENCIES FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL AND AND
ESTABLISH A PLACE TO WORK OUT
FROM.
THANK YOU.
MEN CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW
WATERSHED RESTORATION AND FUEL
REDUCTION ACTIVITIES OVERLAP OR
ARE DIFFERENT.
AND ALSO IN YOUR OPINION IF YOU
THINK HOW FIRES THE BEST AGENCY
TO REALLY BE EVALUATING AND
DIRECTING THE WATERSHED EFFORTS.
A GREAT QUESTIONS AND WHAT WHAT
I WOULD SAY --
TO FUELS AND WATERSHED
ABSOLUTELY THEY ARE LINKED --
THIS IS ALL A SYSTEM.
AND FUEL REDUCTION IS PART OF
THE THE SYSTEMATIC APPROACH TO
MANAGING WATERSHEDS.
AS WELL AND SO --
I VERY CLEAR NEXUS THERE --
RELATED --
TO CAL FIRE BEING THE BEST FOR
WATERSHED MANAGEMENT I WOULD SAY
IN FORESTRY YES.
YES.
OF ON THE PRIVATE LANDS --
I WOULD SAY THERE'S MORE TO
WATERSHED MANAGEMENT THAN
FORESTRY --
AND TO THAT END --
WE ARE WE ARE A PART OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
AND WE HAVE BEEN COLLABORATING
WITH -- WITH --
OTHER AGENCY DEPARTMENTS ON ON
LOOKING AT OUR OUR AND AND
HELPING US REVIEW OUR APPLICANTS
ESPECIALLY ON THAT WITH THAT
WATERSHED LEVEL PROJECT.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
AND AND GROW.
GREAT AND LASTLY YOU HAVE A GOAL
I BELIEVE OF SIXTY THOUSAND
ACRES FOR FIRE THREAT REDUCTION
TREATMENT --
WHERE ARE YOU ARE YOU ON TRACK
FOR THAT AND KIND OF WHERE WHERE
ARE YOU?
WE WE ARE ON TRACK --
THE EARLY RAIN SLOWED SOME OF
OUR WELL THE THE LATE FIRES AND
EARLY RAIN SLOWED SOME OF OUR
PRESCRIBED BURNING AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO CATCH UP ON THAT.
BUT WE WE ARE --
ALMOST AT 40% OF OUR OF OUR
CUMULATIVE --
GOAL SPRINGS COMING AND WILL
WILL BE PICKING UP IT'S IT'S
IT'S A FISCAL YEAR GOAL SO WE WE
WE AREN'T ON A CALENDAR YEAR FOR
THAT FOR THE FUELS TREATMENT.
THAN THE FUELS TREATMENT IS --
BOTH PRESCRIBED BURNING OF AND
OTHER TYPES OF OF TREATMENT SO
THAT BE MECHANICAL OR HAND
CUTTING PILING BURNING THOSE
KIND OF THINGS --
ALL WOULD BE IN THE OTHER AND WE
HAVE A WE HAVE A STATEWIDE GOAL
THIS YEAR OF TWENTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF THE OTHER TYPE OF FUELS
TREATMENT.
AND FOR TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
ACRES FOR A TOTAL OF FORTY FIVE
WHICH IS NOT THE SIXTY BUT
THAT'S WE'RE SIXTY IS ARE ARE
PROJECTED GOAL IN THE FUTURE.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE A FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRE.
GOAL AND AND WE'RE ABOUT 40% OF
THE WAY THERE WERE WORKING
TOWARD.
THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS MR STONE.
THANK YOU PROFESSOR ITCHING YOU
YOU MENTIONED THE PONDEROSA
PINES AND I'M NOT AS FAMILIAR
WITH THEM IN THE SIERRA.
BUT ON THE IN THE COASTAL AREAS
ON THE THE AGING COASTAL MARINE
TERRACES THAT ARE THEIR
PONDEROUS IS ARE SIGNIFICANT
PART OF THE SAND HILLS HABITAT
AND THAT'S A HABITAT THAT'S
DESIGNED TO BURN.
IN ORDER TO PERPETUATE AND TO
SURVIVE IT HASN'T BAD BECAUSE
IT'S ALSO AN AREA UNDER TRUMP.
MEDICINE DEVELOPMENT PRESSURE
AND SO BEING ABLE TO MANAGE IT
THE WAY THE SYSTEM WAS DESIGNED
BECOMES A CHALLENGE.
WHICH IS WHY LOOKING AT THE THE
NATURE THE FORCED YOU BROUGHT UP
IN THE NATURE THAT THE FORCE MAY
END UP BEING AND BY YOUR SLIDES.
ARE FORCED TO REALLY STRUGGLING
BECAUSE OF DECISIONS THAT WERE
MADE OVER THE LAST HUNDRED YEARS.
IN HOW WE MANAGE FORESTS OR
DIDN'T MANAGE FORESTS.
AND IF WE'RE LOOKING.
TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE DO FORCE
TREATMENTS NOW.
WHICH IS YES FUEL REDUCTION BUT
IT'S ALSO GETTING THE FORCE TO
FUNCTION AS FORCED USED TO SO
THAT THEY CAN SURVIVE BIRDS THAT
THEY CAN MANAGE BECAUSE WHEN WE
CLEAR CUT WHEN WE RE PLANTED
HIGHER DENSITIES OR WITH THE
WRONG TYPE TO TREES OR THE WRONG
TYPES OF MANAGEMENT.
THAN WERE JUST GROWING TREES TO
GROW TREES BUT NOT CREATING
FUNCTIONAL FORESTS.
SO HOW DO WE TAKE.
OR GUESS WHAT'S THE STATE OF THE
SCIENCE OF THAT AS WE'RE DOING
FORCED RESTORATIONS NOW.
AND LOOKING AT FUTURE IMPACTS.
TWENTY THIRTY FIFTY YEARS DOWN
THE LINE WHEN THE SYSTEMS ARE
DESIGNED TO FUNCTION BECAUSE THE
WORK THAT NOW IS GOING TO WORK
OVERTIME.
HOW DO WE HAVE A SENSE THAT
THOSE RESTORATIONS THE WORK
WE'RE DOING TO PROTECT
WATERSHEDS TO MANAGE FORESTS NOW?
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING THE
RIGHT THINGS BECAUSE OF HOW
THOSE FORCE MAY CHANGE OVER TIME.
TO HELP.
AND WE DEVELOPED ANY THOUGHTS ON
ABILITY TO PREDICT.
HOW MUCH TIME ARE YOU GETTING
THE?
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION --
I WOULD SAY THAT IT'S AN AREA OF
VERY ACTIVE INTEREST AND WELL.
POINTING TO THE SAND HILLS I
CAN'T RESPOND DIRECTLY TO THAT
WITHOUT LOOKING AT MAPS AND
GETTING A LITTLE BIT MORE
ORIENTATION.
GENERALLY SPEAKING OF FORESTRY
HAS USED SEEDS OWNS ARE AS WE
WHICH ARE APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND FOOT BY ONE HUNDRED
MILE BLOBS ON A MAP THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY DRAWN IN NINETEEN
FORTY IN THE MOST RECENT VERSION
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY AND THE IDEA IS.
THE THE SEEDS THAT WE MIGHT
PLANT I MEAN THERE THERE THERE
THERE COULD BE A BOTTLENECK
WHERE WE WE DON'T HAVE SEATS
OKAY SO WE THE ASSUMPTION IS --
YEAH WE CAN GO ON WE COULD DO
PLANTINGS WELL THE WAY THAT THAT
OPERATION WORKS IS THERE ARE.
OF A THERE'S A NURSERY THE LA
MORAN NURSERY CAL FIRES OF
ACTIVATING IN DAVIS THAT HAS A
OF FROZEN BROOM WITH.
THOUSANDS OF BOXES OF SEEDS IN
IT THERE'S ANOTHER ONE AT THE
INSTITUTE FOR FORCED GENETICS UP
IMPOSSIBILITY FOR SERVICE THAT'S
ONE OF THE BIG ONES THERE'S A
NUMBER OF OF PRIVATE INDUSTRY
ONES AS WELL.
BUT PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE WHO COLLECT THE SEEDS
GO OUT INTO AND AND THEY GET THE
PINE CONES THEY BRING THEM IN
AND THOSE ARE RECORDED.
IN A A RATHER.
OLD SYSTEM OF ITS IN THIS SEEDS
OUT.
AND PLANTING WITH A TAKING THOSE
SEEDS AND PLANTING THEM AGAIN IN
THE SAME SEATS OWN IS WHAT IS
NOW.
LOOKED AT BUT WE MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT WELL IF YOU HAD.
A BIG FIRE IN THE MIDDLE
ELEVATION AND YOU WERE GOING --
TO TRY TO GROW PONDEROSA IS
THERE YOU MIGHT WANT PONDEROSA
SEED FROM LOWER ELEVATIONS AND
PLANTED AT MIT ELEVATION IN
ANTICIPATION OF BECAUSE THOSE
GUYS WERE EXPOSED TO WARMER
CONDITIONS.
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
ANTICIPATE THAT'S ONE THE OTHER
THE OTHER PIECES THAT WE MIGHT
CHANGE THE MIX SO THE THAT.
I'M CONVINCED THAT IN THIS YEAR
AS THERE'S PARTS OF IT THAT ARE
BECOMING MORE HARDWOOD DOMINATED.
AND SO PERHAPS THEN --
NOT ONLY GOING BACK IN PLANTING
THE MOST.
OF WHAT LOVING CHURCH --
CONNOR FOR TREES BUT HAVING A A
FEW MORE HARDWOODS IN NOW TO
RECOGNIZING THE HEART WHICH MAY
COME INTO THEIR AS A NATURAL
TRANSITION.
AND MAY BE CHANGING YOUR SEATS
STOCK MIX AS YOU'RE GOING IN TO
DO A RESTORATION OF THAT WOULD
BE AN EXAMPLE OF ANTICIPATORY.
PLANTINGS THE THE MOST RADICAL
ONES -- IN
WHICH ARE MORE ACADEMIC THAN
THAN -- REAL
ARE -- WHAT --
WE SERPENTINE AS OUR STATE ROCK
AND WE HAVE MAYBE. 25% OF ALL OF
OUR ENDEMICS OF OVER A THOUSAND
SPECIES LIVE ON SERPENTINE WELL
THOSE ARE LITTLE ISLANDS OF
UNUSUAL --
CONDITIONS RIGHT AND ARE THE
PLANTS THAT GROW ON THIS ONE
LITTLE ONE THAT'S OVER IN THE
BAY AREA GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MIGRATE TO SOME OTHER PLACE.
WE DON'T KNOW MAYBE THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO BE PICKED THE
SEEDS ARE GONNA BE PLANTED IN
THAT OTHER PLACE AND THAT WOULD
BE MUCH MORE.
IF THAT'S IS A RAGING DEBATE
ABOUT WHETHER THAT'S GOOD OR BAD
WE MOVE SPECIES AROUND THE GLOBE.
ALL THE TIME THAT'S THE REALITY
BUT OF I WOULD SAY THOSE ARE
THAT THAT'S SORT OF WHERE THE
STATE OF THE SCIENCES NOW IS.
I KNOW IT EITHER AND THAT'S YEAH
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I'M GETTING
AT IS BECAUSE IF WE'RE WE'RE
MAKING DECISIONS BECAUSE FORCED
GROW SLOWLY.
AND OF WAS WERE MAKING
RESTORATION DECISIONS NOW WE'RE
GONNA BE END UP IN FOREST'S IN
THIRTY FORTY FIFTY YEARS THAT
MAY NOT BE FUNCTIONING BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THESE CHANGES.
I THINK WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
THE MECHANISMS TO LOOK AHEAD AT
WHAT WE EXPECT THOSE FORCED TO
FUNCTION OR HOW THEY EXPECT THEM
TO FUNCTION.
IN THAT CHANGED ENVIRONMENTS.
AS WE DO RESTORATIONS NOW OR
WE'RE GOING TO AND REALLY UNITED
THE AND SAYING AND AND HAVING
SIMILAR KINDS OF PROBLEMS
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF THE
ABILITY THE FORCE OF FUNCTIONS
FORCE.
IT IS CAL FIRE YOUR SHOE
DIVISION.
AS YOU DO RESTORATIONS ARE YOU
ARE YOU STARTING TO LOOK AT SOME
OF THESE CONNECTIONS I I'M I'M
GLAD YOU ASKED BECAUSE SOME --
IT AND THE SIDE --
THAT THINGS ARE CHANGING AND WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT AT A DIFFERENT
WAY WHEN WE'RE WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT REFORESTATION.
OF OF INSURING THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE FORCE THAT COMES
FROM THAT ACTIVITY WE DON'T
WANNA JUST PLANT TREES FOR THEM
TO DIE --
BECAUSE THINGS HAVE CHANGED IN
THEIR CLIMATE THEIR MICRO
CLIMATE WHATEVER HAPPENS TO BE
SO -- WE DID
IT.
OVER A YEAR AGO NOW TO START A
WHOLE PROCESS OF REDEFINING WHAT
ARE SEEDS ZONES ARE AND WHAT
THEY NEED TO BE.
BUT ALSO LOOKING AT THE SEA THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE AND
DETERMINING WHAT THE BEST
[inaudible]
PLATE LIKELY.
MIGRATION OF WHERE THAT SEED
GOES BACK ON TO THE LANDSCAPE
SHOULD BE SO SO ARE PLANTING
GUIDES.
AND OR OR PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
THAT AT THE LA AROUND --
RESEARCH AND SEED SEED BANK AND
NURSERY --
ARE WORKING TOWARD THAT --
AND THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
DOES THAT IS THE WAY WE WILL BE --
REENTER INTRODUCING THE OVER
OVER THE LAST DECADES BACK INTO
THE LANDSCAPE --
GOING FORWARD THEY WILL BE GOING.
NOT TO WHERE THE MOTHER TREES
CAME FROM THEY WILL PROBABLY BE
GOING UP SLOPE.
AND PROBABLY FURTHER NORTH
[inaudible]
YEAH.
OUR NEXT QUESTION IS FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES FOLLOWED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
EGGMAN.
THANK YOU CHIEF --
ONE OF THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT IT
IS THE THE COMPETITIVE GRANTS
AND THE DIRECT FUNDING TO ANCHOR
POINTS ARE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT THE BIG
PICTURE.
SO IT ISN'T JUST THOSE WHO HIRE
THE BEST GRANT WRITERS --
WHO GET THE GRANTS BUT LOOKING
AT THE BIG PICTURE TAKING ON
THAT RESPONSIBILITY APPRECIATE
THAT --
GIVEN THE FREQUENCY AND THE
INTENSELY THE MOST RECENT FIRES.
HOW MANY FIRE PREVENTION
PROJECTS?
WORKING AT BIG COMPLETED EACH
YEAR.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND IT'S
A MOVING TARGET EACH ONE OF OUR
UNITS WE HAVE TWENTY ONE UNITS
PLUS WE HAVE --
SIX CONTRACT COUNTIES SO IN IN
EACH OF THOSE --
TWENTY SEVEN AND ADMINISTRATIVE
AREAS --
THEY HAVE A FIRE PLAN --
AND IT'S A CERTIFIED PLAN AND
AND IT HAS A NUMBER OF PROJECTS
SOME SOME TIMES --
THE PROJECTS ARE --
SCATTERED SO WE COULD BE DOING --
IN SOME AREAS.
OR IN SOME COUNTIES OR MULTIPLE
COUNTIES YOU MAY HAVE THIRTY
PROJECTS THEY GET DONE IN A YEAR
IN THAT ADMINISTRATIVE UNIT --
OTHERS MIGHT HAVE JUST ONE OR
TWO BECAUSE THEY'RE BIGGER AND
MORE COMPLEX PROJECTS THAT
THEY'RE WORKING ON SO.
THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF PROJECTS
THAT GETS DONE --
IS IS KIND OF IT CHANGES VERY
DRASTICALLY FROM YEAR TO YEAR --
THE ACREAGE THAT THAT WAS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY --
THAT FORTY FIVE THOUSAND THEY
WERE TRYING TO GET TO THIS YEAR
THAT'S ENCOMPASSING ALL THOSE
PROJECTS AND SO WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS IS FOR A A MAN A MEASURE IS
IS TO TRY AND UTILIZE THE
ACREAGE THAT IS BEING TREATED.
AND THEN USE THE THE FORCE
CARBON PLAN AS OUR GUIDING
DOCUMENT TO TO IDENTIFY WHAT CAL
FIRES.
AND OUR CAPACITY WHAT CAL FIRES --
TARGET IS IN THE KERR'S ANNUALLY --
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE --
IN IN ALL.
TYPES OF TREATMENT THAT WOULD BE
CAL FIRE PRIVATE AND AND OTHER
LOCAL -- AND
THEN THE FOR SERVICE IS ALSO
TRYING TO GET TO A FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRE NUMBER. FOR A
TOTAL OF A MILLION ACRES ACROSS
THE ENTIRE LANDSCAPE OF
CALIFORNIA --
SOMETIME IN THE NEXT DECADE.
WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST HINDRANCES
TO COMPLETING THE COMMUNITY FIRE
PROTECTION PROJECTS?
COMMUNITY FIRE PROTECTION
PROJECTS --
MOST OFTEN COVER.
MANY MANY SMALL LANDOWNERS AND
GETTING BY AND FROM ALL OF THE
LANDOWNERS --
IS ONE OF THE BIG HINDRANCES.
ANOTHER ONE THAT SLOWS PROJECTS
BUT DOESN'T KICKING I KEEP THEM
FROM BEING DONE IS IS THE SEQUEL
PROCESS SO WE WE DO HAVE A
SEQUEL PROCESS THAT.
THAT TAKES IN SOME CASES --
TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
COMPLETE --
AND IT SLOWS IMPLEMENTATION
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE WE DON'T
GET TO THOSE PROJECTS BUT
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THOSE --
AND THEN SMALL LANDOWNERS THAT
ARE SKEPTICAL --
IN SOME CASES OF SEE CgA AND
AND SKEPTICAL OF WANTING
GOVERNMENT --
ENTERING ONTO THEIR LAND --
AND THE SCRUTINY THAT COMES WITH
THAT THAT THAT IS A LOCAL --
CONCERN THAT WE THAT WE RUN INTO
AROUND MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE TRY AND DO THESE THESE --
FIRE PREVENTION TYPE OF
ACTIVITIES AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MS EGGMAN.
THANK YOU IN.
AND AND AND I'M GONNA ASK A
QUESTION I NEED TO LEAVE BEFORE
TOO LONG AND I WOULD ASK MY
COLLEAGUES --
THINK MY COLLEAGUE MISTER STONE
PRESSING MOST FASTENED QUESTION
OF THE DAY.
SO I WAS GONNA ASK --
ABOUT THE SMALL.
THE SMALL PROJECTS --
THE SMALL LANDOWNERS SO JUST UP
IN THE WOODS I'VE SEEN A WHOLE
LOT OF STOCKTON TIMBER --
SO THAT WAS GONNA BE MY QUESTION --
LONG LINES OF MISS REYES HOW HOW
WE WORKING TO BE ABLE TO GET ALL
THAT TIMBER OUT ARE YOU GOT A
LOT OF PLANS OUT THERE AND THEN
A LOT OF SMALL LANDOWNERS AND SO
YOU'VE GOT.
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS WORKING AT THE
SAME TIME DO WE HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO GET THE TIMBER OUT
SOMEWHERE ELSE SO IT'S NOT JUST
PILED UP.
AND THEN ALONG THE LINES OF
MISTER STONE.
ALSO WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
HOW SEEDS SPREAD.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THE IMPACT
ON THE ANIMAL POPULATION THAT IS
ALSO THE BIRDS AND THE SQUIRRELS
AND THE INSECTS THAT SPREAD THE
SEEDS -- AND
ALSO OUR OUR THE WILDLIFE LOOKS
DIFFERENT NOW THAN IT LOOKED A
DECADE AGO IN PARTS OF THE
SIERRA --
ARE WE LOOKING AT THAT AND
TAKING THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
AS WE MAKE OUR PLANTS.
BOTH VERY GOOD QUESTIONS ARE
TAKING THE FIRST QUESTION ON ON
SMALL LANDOWNERS THAT HAVE AN
ACCUMULATION OF OF LOGS AND
DIFFERENT THINGS --
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS I I JUST
WANT TO QUALIFY THIS --
DEFENSIBLE SPACE THE AREA THAT
IS REQUIRED FOR A LANDOWNER TO
CLEAR AROUND THERE.
STRUCTURE THERE HABITABLE
STRUCTURE THAT'S THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY --
AND SO THERE ARE SOME PLACES
WHERE THERE'S DISADVANTAGED --
GRANT A CAPABILITIES STATE TO
HELP WITH SOME OF THOSE COSTS
BUT IT REALLY IS THE THE
LANDOWNERS RESPONSIBILITY WHEN
WE GET INTO KIND OF THE THE THE
NEXT.
TIER OF THAT OUTSIDE OF THAT
DESPITE DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND WE
HAVE ACCUMULATION OF WOODY
MATERIAL WHETHER IT'S STILL
STANDING OR OR CUT AND AND ON
THE GROUND --
WITH THAT'S WHERE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTNER
WITH WITH GROUPS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN DEALING WITH THAT
ON THOSE FIRE PREVENTION TYPE OF
GRANT OPPORTUNITIES ARE THERE --
THEY'VE BEEN USED IN THE PAST
FOR CHIPPING PROGRAMS AND OTHER --
IN SOME CASES --
SUBSIDIZING THE THE
TRANSPORTATION OF CERTAIN
MATERIALS TO BIOMASS PLANTS AND
OR OTHER TYPES OF OF UTILIZING
PLANTS --
BUT THAT IS IS THAT IS THAT THAT
IS AN ISSUE FOR US AND THIS THAT
SMALL LANDOWNER PIECES WHERE WE
FEEL CAL FIRE FEELS THAT WITH
THAT.
WE HAVE THE GREATEST NEED AND
PROBABLY THETHE THE GREATEST
CHALLENGE --
TO TO GET WHERE WE NEED TO GO --
IN IN MOVING TO THAT LARGER
NUMBER OF OF ACRES TREATED AND
ON ON THE ANIMAL POPULATION I AM.
I DO WANT TO KICK THIS TO JIM I
DON'T WANT --
TO SURE COULD THE THE THAT I
DON'T I DON'T WANT YOU TO THINK
THE CAL FIRE DOESN'T THINK OF
THIS BUT THIS IS ANOTHER --
LANDOWNER AND LAND MANAGER
DECISION --
AND WE AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT
WITH LANDOWNERS.
ABOUT THE VALUE OF DIFFERENT
TREES FOR MAST OR FOR FEED --
FOR BIRDS OR OR DIFFERENT THINGS --
AND SO WE WE DO TALK ABOUT THAT
WHEN WE'RE HAVING --
KIND OF FORESTRY DISCUSSION WITH
A LANDOWNER AND WE ENCOURAGE
THEM TO CONSIDER GOING FORWARD
BUT RELATED TO SPECIFICS I THINK
I MAKE THAT TO JIM [inaudible]
OKAY OF WHEN YOU HAVE A REALLY
BIG WILD FIRE.
IT'S NOT LIKELY THAT THE LOCAL
SEED SOURCES.
AND THE BIRDS THAT MIGHT BRING
THEM ARE GOING TO RE VEGETATE
THAT AREA.
ARE AND THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
STUDIES --
THERE WAS A BIG ONE ON THE RIM
FIRE WHERE THEY WERE LOOKING AT
A A WOODPECKER AND AND SAYING
HOW MANY.
WOULD YOU HAVE IN HERE AND YOU
WOULD THEY BE BRINGING IN ACORNS
OR WHATEVER AND AND YOU KNOW
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT THAT WE
NEED TO ACTIVELY MANAGE WE'RE
NOT GOING.
TO JUST BE ABLE TO ALLOW THOSE
AREAS TO NATURALLY REGENERATE OF
THE THE RISK --
FOR TO AT THE VERY LEAST THE
RISK FOR DEBRIS FLOWS IS VERY
HIGH FROM THOSE AND SO YOU YOU
NEED TO GET IN THERE AND DO
SOMETHING.
SO -- IN
TERMS I I THINK THAT'S MAYBE
MORE OF A MOTIVATION FOR ACTIVE
RESTORATION.
IN TERMS OF MONITORING THE
POPULATIONS OF SPECIES.
YOU KNOW I THINK THE I HAVEN'T
HEARD OF SORT OF FOLLOW ON
STUDIES WE KNOW WHAT A LOT OF
THE SPECIES DO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE IS.
REALLY QUITE VERSED IN THE
INDIVIDUAL SPECIES FOR EXAMPLE
MANY DEER POPULATIONS MIGRATE UP
AND DOWN THE SIDES OF THE
MOUNTAIN --
JUST LIKE THAT OF AMERICANS USED
TO DO.
AT AND SO --
WE WE KNOW WHAT A LOT OF THE
THAT SORT OF THE NATURAL
TRAJECTORIES ARE MAINTAINING
CONNECTIVITY ON THE LANDSCAPE.
AND WHICH IS.
DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING
FROM FOREST SERVICE TO PRIVATE
LAND TO MAYBE TO YOU A RIVER
CORRIDOR THAT'S GOT SOME OTHER
JURISDICTION --
BUT YOU WANT TO TRY TO RETAIN
SOME NATURAL VEGETATION ACROSS
THAT.
ALL ALONG THAT CORRIDOR THAT
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE WIDELY POINTED TO FOR A
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT.
WOULD ALLOW FLEXIBILITY AND
ALLOW PLANTS AND ANIMALS
THEMSELVES TO HANDLE SOME OF THE
MOVEMENT NEEDS THAT THEY MIGHT
MIGHT REQUIRE.
THANK YOU. FOR I WANTED TO
WELCOME SOME MEMBERS AMOUNT AS
TO THE HEARING --
MISTER TO YOU DID YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANYBODY
ELSE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK THE PANEL THIS WAS A VERY.
INTERESTING EDUCATIONAL PANEL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
AND I'M GONNA WELCOME OUR SECOND
PANEL UP --
THANK YOU OUR SECOND PANEL WILL
FOCUS ON SOME OF THE MAIN G. G.
R. F. AND GRANT PROGRAMS THE
STATE IS CURRENTLY USING TO
ADDRESS.
A FIRE RISK RESTORE FIRE --
FOREST CHANGE IN ADDITION TO AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH THESE
INVESTMENTS --
WE ARE PARTICULARLY I'M HURT I
MEAN IT JUST TRANSMIT TO THE
PANEL RIGHT NOW THAT I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
WHETHER THERE'S ANY IMPEDIMENTS
TO THE EFFECT EFFICIENT
EXECUTION OF THESE PROGRAMS.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN HELP
ADDRESS.
HOW WE'RE COORDINATING BETWEEN
THESE VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND IF WE
NEED TO DO MOVE FASTER AND DO
MORE IN ORDER TO PREPARE FOR A
FUTURE CLIMATE?
DO WE NEED TO RETHINK HOW WE
IMPLEMENT THESE PROGRAMS I'M
GOING TO IN TO BRIEFLY INTRODUCE
THE PANEL AND I WOULD ASK YOU TO
SPEAK IN THIS ORDER.
RACHEL ELLERS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE ANY
CHIANG DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER
AT THE A. R. B..
ANGELA LOTS ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTR FOR CLIMATE AND ENERGY
FROM CAL FIRE.
ANGELA AVERY THE NEW EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THIS YEAR NEVADA
CONSERVANCY.-JOHN DONNELLY EXECUTIVE OFFICER
AT THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD.
AND HE'LL LEAVE A BRIGHT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION --
BUT WHO INTEL RECENTLY WAS THE
ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF CLIMATE
AND ENERGY AT THE NATIONAL
RESOURCES AGENCY WELCOME.
WITH THAT WE WERE ASKED MISS --
HERS TO BEGIN THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING RACHEL EHLERS WITH
ALLEGE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT WHICH
HOPEFULLY --
YOU ALL HAVE A COPY OF FROM THE
SERGEANT AND IT'S ALSO AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEBSITE FOR THOSE NOT
SITTING HERE --
THERE'S A FAIR AMOUNT OF AKRON
IN HERE WHICH I WILL PUT I'M
TIME AND EXPERTISE YOU HAVE IN
YOUR PANEL BUT FEEL FREE TO
HOLLER AT ME IF I SHOULD SLOW
DOWN.
I AM SPEAKING I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
SPEAK ON A REPORT THAT OUR
OFFICE PUBLISHED LAST APRIL ON
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S WITHOUT
FORCING WATERSHED MANAGEMENT AS
WELL AS A REPORT WE PUBLISHED
ONLINE IN NOVEMBER ABOUT HOW CAL
FIRE IS SPENDING RECENT --
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
FOR FOREST HEALTH.
SO TURNING TO PAGE ONE OF THE
HAND OUT AGAIN THIS IS JUST
BACKGROUND OUR FORESTS ARE
IMPORTANT AND THERE AN UNHEALTHY
CONDITION I THINK WE'VE HEARD
THAT ALREADY TODAY.
I THIS IS ONE POLICY AREA THAT
YOU ARE FACING THAT THERE
ACTUALLY IS A PRETTY BROAD
CONSENSUS ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IT'S DIFFERENT FROM SOME OF
THE AREAS THAT THAT YOU ARE
FACED WITH AN CHALLENGES YOU'RE
FACED WITH.
DOESN'T MEAN THERE ARE AREAS BUT
THERE IS A PRETTY BROAD
CONSENSUS ABOUT THE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES THAT WILL YIELD
PROGRESS IN THIS AREA.
I THINK THAT THE FIGURE HERE ON
PAGE ONE SHOWS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES WERE FACING YOU CAN
SEE THE STATE'S SHARE OF
OWNERSHIP OF THE STATE'S OF
FORCE ACROSS CALIFORNIA IS QUITE
SMALL -- SO
THAT PRESENTS CHALLENGES BUT
ALSO OPPORTUNITIES THE STATE
CAN'T GO IN AND FIX THE PROBLEM
ALL BY ITSELF EVEN IF IT WANTED
TO IT TAKES A LOT OF
COLLABORATION AND COORDINATION I
THINK YOU'LL HEAR FROM THAT --
ARE ON THE PANEL THAT WE
NECESSARILY NEED TO BE WORKING
WITH OTHER PARTNERS AND IN
PARTICULAR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GIVEN THEIR LARGE
SHARE OF OWNERSHIP HERE.
TURNING TO PAGE TWO OF THE HAND
OUT JUST A VISUAL REPRESENTATION
OF THE BENEFITS OF HEALTHY
FORESTS AND THE POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES OF UNHEALTHY
FOREST'S --
WILD FIRES RESILIENCE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THEN WATER SUPPLY
WHICH I'M --
I THINK YOU'LL BE HEARING ABOUT
EVEN MORE IN THE THIRD PANEL
TODAY WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT AS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS REALLY DIVED
INTO THIS ISSUE IN RECENT YEARS
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF FOCUS ON
WELFARE AND WELFARE RISK BUT
PROBABLY NOT QUITE AS MUCH
DISCUSSION ABOUT --
THE WATER ASPECT OF OUR FORESTS
AND AND BENEFITS --
AND CONSEQUENCES OF AND HEALTHY
FORESTS SO I THINK AGAIN YOUR
THIRD PANEL WILL TALK ABOUT THAT
BUT THAT IS THE THEME OF SOME OF
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS SO I WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT.
TURNING TO PAGE THREE OF THE
HAND OUT ANOTHER VISUAL
REPRESENTATION OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF UNHEALTHY
FOREST'S THIS SUCH REPORTER
TALKED ABOUT THIS BUT THAT HERE
IT IS FOR YOU IN VISUAL FORM OF
THE TWENTY LARGEST AND TWENTY
MOST DESTRUCTIVE.
FIRES SINCE CALIFORNIA HAS
STARTED TRACK YOU CAN SEE THEY
HAVE BEEN VERY.
NOTABLY CLUSTERED IN THE PAST
TWO DECADES AND THE TOP.
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WHEN WE
PUBLISHED OUR REPORT THEM
LARGEST AND MOST DESTRUCTIVE HAD
JUST HAPPENED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EVEN SINCE WE'VE
PUBLISHED THOSE HAVE BEEN
SURPASSED BY THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIRES.
SO TURNING TO PAGE.
FOUR I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT WE
HAD MORE RECOMMENDATIONS THAN
ARE SHOWN HERE IN OUR REPORT AND
SEVERAL OF THEM HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ADOPTED IN THE LAST
LEGISLATIVE SESSION --
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
HAD ABOUT FUNDING FOR PILOT
PROJECTS FOR HOW TO DEAL WITH
WOODY BIOMASS AND MAKING SOME
CHANGES TO SOME OF CAL FIRES
PROGRAMS FOR LANDOWNERS TO MAKE
THEM EASIER --
TO TO UNDERTAKE SOME OF THEIR OF
FORCE PROJECT SO --
TO THIS IS A SCALED DOWN VERSION
WHICH IS GREAT.
I'LL TALK JUST PRIMARILY ON
THESE FIRST THREE BULLETS THAT
OUR OVER ARCHING AROUND
IMPROVING AND INCREASING FUNDING
IN COORDINATION.
THE FIRST ONE IS ALREADY BEEN
DISCUSSED HERE TODAY.
ABOUND THE REAL NECESSITY FOR
CLEAR PRIORITIZATION CRITERIA
OVER HOW WE USE OUR FUNDING AND
HOW WE'RE TARGETING --
THERE'S SOME PROGRESS BEING MADE
ON THE HERE AT AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY ONE THAT IS DIRECTING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PUT TOGETHER
PRIORITIZATION PLAN.
BUT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THIS CNH OVERSIGHT
HEARING IN EACH BUDGET
APPROPRIATION HOW ARE WE MAKING
SURE WE'RE MAXIMIZING THE USE OF
OUR FUNDING AND WHAT CRITERIA
ARE WE USING --
A THE FORMER EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF YOUR NEVADA CONSERVANCY WOULD
TALK ABOUT LET'S MAKE SURE WE'RE
NOT --
UNDERTAKING RANDOM ACTS OF
RESTORATION WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
A GREAT.
WAY TO THINK ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WERE REALLY BUILDING ON THE
EFFORTS WERE DOING AND AND
ENTERING IN THERE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS WE COULD BE
PRIORITIZE AND WE COULD
PRIORITISE KEY WATERSHEDS.
WE GET PRIORITIZE PUBLIC SAFETY
WE GET PRIORITIZE GREENHOUSE GAS --
REDUCTION WE COULDN'T PRIORITIZE
WHERE WE HAVE PARTNERS IN PLACE
THERE A LOT OF DIFFERENT --
AVENUES WE COULD USE BUT IF
WE'RE KIND OF STRIKING --
IN TRYING TO STRIKE EACH ONE WE
MAY LOSE THE CUMULATIVE IMPACTS
THAT WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
MAXIMIZE GIVEN THE SIZE OF THE
PROBLEM AND THE LIMITED FUNDS.
THE SECOND BULLET AT THIS WAS
ALSO TOUCHED ON ALREADY IN SOME
OF THE CONVERSATION WE
RECOMMENDED IN OUR REPORT
ELEVATING THIS ISSUE TO AN
AGENCY LEVEL AND HAVING A FOUR A
FOREST HEALTH TEAM.
OUT OF RESOURCES AGENCY THAT'S
IN CHARGE OF THESE PROACTIVE
FOREST HEALTH ACTIVITIES.
CERTAINLY COVER WOULD BE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THAT BUT THERE
WERE TWO REASONS WE THOUGHT THAT
THIS MADE SENSE FIRST TO BREAK
DOWN SOME OF THE SILOS ACROSS
THE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS --
ESPECIALLY WITH FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND WATER BOARD AND
OTHER AGENCIES THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN PERMITTING --
AND FOR AND ALLOCATING FUNDING
FOR THESE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE ARE MORE
STREAMLINED AND SEAMLESS BUT
ALSO SECONDLY GIVEN THE EXTENDED
WILDFIRE SEASON THAT WE'RE
SEEING.
HOW FIRES UNDERSTANDABLY?
HAVING TO SPEND A LOT OF
ATTENTION SPECIALLY AT THE
LEADERSHIP LEVEL RESPONDING TO
THESE FIRES FOR LONGER PERIODS
OF TIME AND WE THOUGHT THAT
HOUSING IT AT THE AGENCY LEVEL
COULD KEEP THE FOCUS.
ON EVEN SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE TASKS LIKE
DEVELOPING GRANT CRITERION
MAKING SUR GRANTED GRANTS GET
OUT THE DOOR --
YOU WHEN CAL FIRE LEADERSHIP MAY
BE AGAIN UNDERSTANDABLY AND AND
JUSTIFIABLY FOCUSED ON FIGHTING
FIRES THAT WE DON'T LOSE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND THEN THE THIRD BULLET THIS
IS AN AREA THAT HASN'T HAD AS
MUCH --
LEGISLATIVE FOCUS IN THE RECENT
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGES IN RECENT
[inaudible]
MONTHS.
REALLY LOOKING AT WHO ARE IS
BENEFITING FROM OUR FOREST AND
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY IS --
CONTRIBUTING TO THE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
SPECIFICALLY ARE THERE WAYS THAT
DOWNSTREAM WATER USERS SHOULD BE --
GENERATING AND CONTRIBUTING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO TO SUPPORT
SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES TO KEEP
OUR FORESTS HEALTHY SO WE HAD
THREE SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS
HERE THE FIRST REQUIRING THE
STATE WATER PROJECT TO MAKE AN
ANNUAL CONTRIBUTION.
TO HELPING MAINTAIN THE HEALTH
OF THE FEATHER RIVER WATERSHED --
DEBTS OF THEY CONTRIBUTE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FOR THE STATE WATER
PROJECT WE THOUGHT.
WE THROUGHOUT A NUMBER OF MAY
PERHAPS TEN MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR OR SOMETHING ALONG THOSE
LINES THAT WOULDN'T CAUSE ON DO
YOU.
FISCAL BURDEN ON REPAIRS BUT
ALSO WOULD HELP CONTRIBUTE TO
THE WATER SOURCE.
SECOND WE THOUGHT IT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE TO TRY IN ENCOURAGE WATER
AGENCIES TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW
THEY'RE BENEFITING FROM THEIR
WATERSHEDS AND UNDERTAKE SOME.
IT COST AVOIDANCE FOR IN THE
CASE OF WATER --
WILDFIRES OR COST BENEFIT
STUDIES FOR HOW INVESTMENTS
MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO HELP JUSTIFY
TO THE RATE PAYERS WHY THESE
TYPES OF INVESTMENTS MIGHT MAKE
SENSE.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME INSTANCES
OF AGENCIES THAT HAVE DONE THIS
NOTABLY AT EASTBAY MUD IN THE
MCCALL MANY WATERSHED AND
PLASTER COUNTY WATER AGENCY --
SO WE THOUGHT THE STATE
PROVIDING SOME MATCHING FUNDING
TO HELP INCENTIVIZE SOME OF THAT
ACT ACTIVITY BY LOCAL WATER
AGENCIES MIGHT --
MAKES SENSE TO HELP AGAIN --
DEMONSTRATE THE VALUE THAT THERE
WAS --
RECOMMENDATION ON A WATER GRANT
PROGRAM THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES RUNS TYPICALLY
BOND FUNDED THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT PERHAPS COULD BE WORKED
INTO A FUTURE --
WATER BOND WHERE THEY ARE
INCENTIVE POINTS GIVEN TO
AGENCIES THAT ARE SUBMITTING
GRANT APPLICATIONS TO DO WORK --
IN THE UPPER WATERSHED REALLY
CAUSING FOLKS TO LOOK UP AND SEE
WHETHER WATER SOURCE COMES FROM.
PAGE FIVE OF THE HAND OUT IS
JUST FOR YOUR REFERENCE IT'S
SHOWS YOU THE FUNDING THAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED SINCE THIS IS
PARTLY A BUDGET COMMITTEE.
MEETING.
YOU CAN SEE.
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS PRIMARILY FROM
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS --
TO JEFF BUT ALSO SOME I'M
PROPOSITION.
SIXTY EIGHT YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT
SOME OF THESE --
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE PANEL SO
REALLY JUST FOR YOUR REFERENCE.
AND THEN FINALLY --
PAGES SIX AND SEVEN WE HIGHLIGHT
SOME OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS THAT WE
THINK WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO FOCUS ON NOT JUST
TODAY BUT IN THE COMING.
WEEKS MONTHS AND YEARS AND AND
YOU ALL ARE RIGHT IN IT THAT
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF THESE
QUESTIONS ALREADY TODAY --
ARE WE HIT IT'S WHAT KIND OF
PROGRESS ARE WE MAKING ARE THERE
BARRIERS ARE CHALLENGES THAT YOU
ALL CAN HELP WITH THROUGH
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION.
HOW ARE WE INSURING WHAT'S A
PRIORITIZATION THIS THEME HOW
ARE WE INSURING WHERE ACHIEVING
OUR BENEFITS --
WHAT PROACTIVE STEPS ARE
DEPARTMENTS TAKING AND
PARTICULAR CALVARY NOW SINCE
THEY'RE IN CHARGE OF MOST OF THE
MONEY TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
HITTING ALL OF OUR TARGET AREAS
AS?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS MENTION
NOT WE'RE NOT JUST GIVING THE
FUNDING TO THE BEST GRANT
WRITERS BUT WE'RE TARGETING
WHERE THE FUNDING IS REALLY --
IT'S GOING TO MAKE THE MOST --
TO CHECK IMPACT.
I THINK THIS FINAL ROUND THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE SIX THIS SET OF
QUESTIONS AROUND LOCAL CAPACITY
IS SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
IMPORTANT TO REALLY KEEP AN EYE
ON DO WE HAVE ENOUGH FORESTERS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO UNDERTAKE
THESE PROJECTS TO WE HAVE.
BEEN OF GREAT WRITERS AND LOCAL
PROJECTS SPONSORS OBSEQUIES
SPONSORS ARE THE TYPES OF OF
PROACTIVE WORK NEEDING TO BE
TAKEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IN THE
AREAS WE NEED THEM TO BE DONE
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL STEPS THE
STATE NEEDS TO TAKE TO BE SURE
THAT WERE --
UNDERTAKING THOSE PROJECTS IN
THE KEY AREAS.
PAGE SEVEN WHAT CREATURE WE
USING TO ALLOCATE FUNDING ACROSS
THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS AS WAS
ALREADY ASK BETWEEN FOREST
HEALTH AND FIRE PREVENTION THAT
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS LARGELY DELEGATED TO CAL
FIRE TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
ACROSS THOSE TO PROGRAMS.
THAT MAY BE SOMETHING IN THE
FUTURE IF YOU'RE NOT.
COMFORTABLE WITH THE DECISIONS
YOU'RE MAKING THEY'RE MAKING YOU
MAY WANT TO GET MORE INVOLVED IN
HELPING MAKE THOSE ALLOCATION
DISCUSSIONS DECISIONS AS WELL.
AND THEN HOW DO WE KNOW THAT
WERE YIELDING SUCCESS WHAT KIND
OF METRICS THIS IS A TOUGH ONE
BECAUSE HOW DO WE KNOW IF WE
AVOIDED A SEVERE WILD FIRE OR
NOT THESE THESE ARE THESE ARE
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS BUT WE DON'T.
SPECIALLY WITH THE LEVEL
INVESTMENT THE STATE'S MAKING WE
DON'T I'VE SPENT A BILLION
DOLLARS AND WONDER WHAT WE GOT
FROM IT.
SO CONTINUING TO ENGAGE WITH THE
SCIENTISTS WHO CAN DO THIS KIND
OF RESEARCH AND THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE RUNNING THESE PROGRAMS
ABOUT HOW ARE WE MEASURING
SUCCESS AND HOW ARE WE
IDENTIFYING THE AREAS THAT WE
THINK WE WILL.
GET THE BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR
BUCK.
SO REALLY ENCOURAGED TO SEE
THESE QUESTIONS ALREADY BEING A
FOCUS OF THE DISCUSSION TODAY
AND WE REALLY THINK KEEPING OUR
FOCUS ON THIS OVER THE COMING
MONTHS AND YEARS WILL HELP.
ENSURE THAT OUR INVESTMENTS ARE
ARE A STRATEGIC AS WE CAN.
THANK YOU WE WILL HOLD OUR
QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END OF THE
PANEL --
WITHOUT WILL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR FRIEDMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
AND MY NAME IS EASY CHIANG A
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
OUR CLIMATE CHANGE STRATEGY AND
HOW THE STATE'S NATURAL WORKING
LANCE FIT INTO THAT STRATEGY.
SO YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD TODAY
ABOUT HOW CLIMATE CHANGE IS
IMPACTING OUR LANDS AND THE NEED
FOR US TO ADAPT TO THE CHANGING
CLIMATE.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALSO RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF NOT FROM
WORKING LANDS IN CLIMATE
MITIGATION SINCE OUR FIRST
CLIMATE CHANGE COPING PLAN IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT R.
NATURAL WORKING LANDS INCLUDING
FOREST'S FOR THE ONLY FACTOR
THAT CAN SEQUESTER CARBON THAT
IS THEY CAN PULL CARBON DIOXIDE.
OUT OF THE AIR FROM A CLIMATE
CHANGE MITIGATION PERSPECTIVE
THAT MAKES THE SECTOR UNIQUE.
I WILL CARB RECENTLY COMPLETED
THE FIRST NATIONAL WORKING LANDS
GREENHOUSE GAS INVENTORY.
LANDS EXPERIENCED A NET LOSS OF
OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION METRIC TONS OF CARBON
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND ONE AND
TWENTY FOURTEEN MOST OF THAT IS
DUE TO WILD FIRE.
THAT TRANSLATES TO OVER SIX
HUNDRED AND ENDS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE EQUIVALENT OVER THAT
TIME.
NOW WE'VE ALREADY HEARD TODAY WE
SHOULD BE CLEAR THAT FIRE IS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECOSYSTEMS IT BELONGS ON OUR
LANDSCAPES.
BUT WE NEED TO STRIVE FOR
NATURAL SYSTEMS IN WHICH FIRE IS
PART OF A REAL ZILLION SYSTEM
THAT SEQUESTERS MORE CARBON THAN
IT LOSES.
OUR MOST RECENT SCOPING PLAN WAS
ADOPTED BY THE BOARD IN LATE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS PLAN CALLS
FOR NEAR TERM ACTION TO ACHIEVE
THE LONG TERM GOAL OF
MAINTAINING OUR NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS AS A CARBON SINK.
THE PROGRAMS THAT MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE PANEL TODAY
ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT ARE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF RESTORING OUR
LANDS AND AVOIDING THE MOST
CATASTROPHIC IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THE IMPORTANCE OF HELPING LANCE
HAS ALSO BEEN RECOGNIZED
INTERNATIONALLY.
LAST OCTOBER HE
INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL ON
CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUED A SPECIAL
REPORT ON CLIMATE WHICH CALLED
FOR GLOBAL CARBON NEUTRALITY IN
THE TWENTY FORTY TO TWENTY FORTY
FIVE TIME FRAME.
ACHIEVING CARBONNEUTRALITY IS
GOING TO REQUIRE DEEP EMISSION
CUTS.
AS WELL AS INCREASED CARBON
STORAGE AND SEQUESTRATION.
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE STILL GONNA
HAVE SOME COMBUSTION AND TWENTY
FORTY FIVE SO WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME SEQUESTRATION INCLUDING
SEQUESTRATION ON NATURAL WORKING
LANDS TO BALANCE OUT THOSE
EMISSIONS.
NEAR TERM ACTION ON NATURAL
LANDS BECOMES EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT AS WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
TODAY WHEN YOU REALIZE IT'S
GOING TO TAKE DECADES TO HEAL
THE LAND AND GROW THE TREES TO
MAXIMIZE SEQUESTRATION.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE ACT NOW TO
ESTABLISH HEALTHY NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS FOR THE FUTURE.
THEY NEED TO ADDRESS OUR LANDS
FOR CLIMB IT COMES WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET MULTIPLE
OBJECTIVES.
IN JANUARY CARB CALLIE PA THE
RESOURCES AGENCY CDFA AND THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
RELEASED THE DRAFT NATURAL
WORKING LAND IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS MANAGER
LANDS FOR MULTIPLE BENEFITS AND
THIS PLAN EXPLICITLY ADDS CARBON
SEQUESTRATION TO THOSE BENEFITS.
THAT MEANS THAT STATE SUPPORTED
LAND CONSERVATION RESTORATION
AND MANAGEMENT ACTIONS WILL BE
ORIENTED TOWARD STRATEGIES THAT
PROVIDE LONG TERM CLIMATE
BENEFITS.
BY PROTECTING CARBON STOCKS
INCREASING SEQUESTRATION AND
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
THESE ACTIVITIES ARE ALSO GOING
TO ENHANCE THE PLANS TO THREATS
INCLUDING WORSENING CLIMATE
IMPACTS. TO MEET THE TARGETS
IDENTIFIED IN THE DRAFT PLAN
AGENCIES WILL WORK TO MAXIMIZE
CLIMATE BENEFITS ALONG SIDE
TRADITIONAL NATURAL RESOURCE
OBJECTIVES WHEREVER POSSIBLE.
ADMINISTERING ALL OF OUR NATURAL
WORKING LANCE PROGRAMS UNDER A
UNITED AND COORDINATED APPROACH
WILL HELP US MOVE TOWARD OUR
COMBINED GOAL OF NET CLIMATE
BENEFITS.
RESILIENT LANDS IMPROVE WATER
QUALITY WILDLIFE HABITAT
RECREATION AND OTHER BENEFITS.
AS WE TURNED IMPLEMENTATION WE
MUSTRECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUPPORTING REGIONAL AND LOCAL
CAPACITY FOR PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION.
STATE OWNS LESS THAN 3% OF THE
LAND IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THE ROLE OF LOCAL TRIBAL
FEDERAL AND PRIVATE PARTNERS
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED.
RESOURCES FOR CAPACITY BUILDING
COALITION FORMING PLANNING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ARE ALL
CRITICAL.
THROUGH INCREASED COORDINATION
IN ACTION AND LINKING STATE
POLICY WITH SUPPORT FOR LOCAL
AND REGIONAL IMPLEMENTATION.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
LEVERAGE THE ENORMOUS
OPPORTUNITY INHERENT IN OUR
NATURAL WORKING LANDS. FOR
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
SUPPORTING MULTIPLE CRITICAL
STATE OBJECTIVES FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY TO SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES GOOD WATER GOOD AIR
HEALTHY SOILS CLIMATE BENEFITS
AND MORE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WHAT'S YOUR NEXT.
THANKS.
I'M GOOD MORNING --
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ANGIE LET
US SAY --
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
CLIMATE AND ENERGY CAL FIRE AND
I'M JUST GOING TO TALK TO YOU A
LITTLE BIT TODAY --
VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT THE CLAIM AND
ENERGY PROGRAM --
DETAIL TO THE FOREST HEALTH
PROGRAM WHICH YOU'VE HEARD.
ABOUT A FEW TIMES ALREADY TODAY.
THANK YOU RACHEL FOR THAT
INFORMATION --
CALPERS CLIMB IN ENERGY PROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SO IT'S A FAIRLY NEW
PROGRAM --
IT WORKS TO PLAY CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION AND MITIGATION
MEASURES TO FORESTED LANDS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BOTH STATE
FEDERAL AND PRIVATE LANDS --
WHILE ALSO REPRESENTING CAL FIRE
AND IN CLIMATE AND BIOENERGY
RELATED WORK AT THE STATE LEVEL
SUCH AS WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCIES --
NETWORKING LANDS IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN AND CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD'S RECENT BIOENERGY
RESOURCES ECONOMY SUMMIT BY
RESOURCES ECONOMY SUMMIT.
AND FIFTEEN DEDICATED AS A
COMMON INTERVIEW PROGRAM ALSO
IT'S FIFTEEN DEDICATED STAFF
THAT IMPLEMENT THE FOREST HEALTH
PROGRAM AND WORK WITH OTHER CAL
FIRE PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED
THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUN AUCTION PROCEEDS.
AND THE FOREST HEALTH PROGRAM
ITSELF IS CURRENTLY CLOSING ON
ITS FOURTH GRANT SOLICITATION --
IN THAT TIME THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN ALLOCATED ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
WILL RECEIVE UP TO EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION ALONG WITH THE FIRE
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM --
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS XIN
REFORESTATION PEST MANAGEMENT
PRESCRIBED FIRE BY MASS
UTILIZATION.
RESEARCH AND CONSERVATION
THROUGH EASEMENTS OR FEE FOR
TITLE -- AT
A LANDSCAPE LEVEL --
AT SCALE OF PROJECTS AGAIN
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE HAVE A IT THROUGH THE
PAST THREE SOLICITATIONS AWARDED --
OVER SIXTY PROJECTS --
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND HAVE.
THOSE PROJECTS WILL TREAT OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES AND
THAT STARTED IN.
A FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND AS I
MENTIONED THE FOURTH
SOLICITATION JUST CLOSED AND SO
WERE --
SCORING GRANT APPLICATIONS RIGHT
NOW AM AND WILL ANNOUNCE AWARDS
FOR ANOTHER DOZEN OR SO PROJECTS
PROBABLY NEXT MONTH.
AND THE PROGRAM IS QUITE
SUCCESSFUL IN FACT HAS ONE OF
THE LOWEST COSTS AND PER
EMISSIONS AT UNIT SAVED --
ACROSS SOME OF THE CC I PROGRAMS.
SINCE THE PROGRAM STARTED CAL
FIRE HAS WORKED INTERNALLY AND
WITH OUR PARTNERS TO STAND UP
AND STREAMLINE IT TO GET.
FUNDING FROM THE BUDGET TO OUR
PARTNERS ON THE GROUND.
AT TURN AROUND TIME FROM BUDGET
ALLOCATION TO ANNOUNCEMENTS HAS
REDUCED FROM OVER A YEAR TO LESS
THAN NINE MONTHS AND I THINK BY.
OUR NEXT ROUND WE MAY BE AS LOW
AS SIX MONTHS FOR THE
COMPETITIVE GRANT SOLICITATIONS --
WE ALSO HAVE BEEN PILOTING
DIRECT FUNDED PROJECTS --
WHICH ARE IDENTIFIED AND
IMPLEMENTED THROUGH CAL FIRE
UNITS AND UNIFIER PLANS AS CHIEF --
PORTER MENTIONED --
AND ALSO LEVERAGING --
AT GRANT AGREEMENT --
FOR ON GOING PROJECTS OF FOR
PROJECTS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
STARTED WE CAN --
HELP IN CERTAIN MORE FUNDING TO
TO ENHANCE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THAT.
PROJECT AND SKIP THE WHOLE
PROCESS OF OF RE VETTING AND
DOING DILIGENCE ON THAT PROJECT
AND THEN GOING TO THE THEIR
GRANTED EXECUTION GRANT
AGREEMENT EXECUTIONER
CONTRACTING PROCESS --
WE ARE NOW ALSO PILOTING DIRECT
FUNDED AWARDS TO PARTNERS AND SO
THAT'S A REALLY EXCITING PART OF
OUR OF OUR PROGRAM IT'S STARTING
THIS YEAR.
DESPITE MAKING GAINS THE TIMING
IN TERMS OF MOVING FUNDING INTO
THE HANDS OF LAND MANAGERS AT
PROJECTS NOW ACTUALLY HAVE LESS
TIME TO COMPLETE THEIR ON THE
GROUND PROJECTS.
BECAUSE EXPENDITURE LIQUIDATION
TIMELINES IN THE BUDGET HAVE
CHANGED FROM A TOTAL OF SIX
YEARS TO A TOTAL OF FOUR YEARS.
AND WE HAVE HEARD ANECDOTALLY
THAT THIS FORCES PARTNERS TO
IMPLEMENT PROJECTS AND SOMEWHAT
UNFAVORABLE WAYS AND THEY WILL
SOMETIMES SPLIT PROJECTS INTO
PHASES SO THAT THEY ARE ONLY
ASKING FOR FUNDS THAT THEY KNOW
THEY CAN ACHIEVE.
IN A TWO OR THREE YEAR TIME LINE.
AND ONE PHASE OF THE PROJECT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE BY
TIME THEY'RE DONE THEY DON'T
COME BACK FOR MORE FUNDING --
WE HAVE HEARD THAT SOME
CONTRACTORS ARE ASKING --
FOR OVER MARKET RATE FOR LABOR
BECAUSE THE TIMELINE IS SHORTER
AND SO --
THEY HAVE TO SOMETIMES FOREGO
OTHER JOBS OR JUST BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT THE DEMAND IS HIGH
THEY ALSO RAISE THEIR RATES.
AND FINALLY SOME PROJECTS ARE
COMPLETING SMALLER PROJECTS
BECAUSE THEY'LL HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE TO DO
AND SO IF THERE'S ONLY TWO OR
THREE YEARS TO FINISH THE
PROJECT AND THEY SPEND HALF OF
THAT.
ON ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE THE
PART OF THE IMPLEMENTATION IS IS
SIX SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN IT
WOULD BE.
AND THE THE PROGRAM WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM EXTENDED
FUNDING PERIODS AND I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T JUST POINT
THAT OUT THANK YOU.
I'M FINALLY --
WITH FUNDING CERTAINTY WE'VE
BEEN ABLE --
TO BEGIN INTEGRATING PROGRAM
OFFERINGS WITH A NUMBER OF THE
ENTITIES HERE SO WITH THE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH NATURI SOURCES
AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION.
AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND US FISH AND WILDLIFE --
AND THE THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. TO START
ENSURING THAT OUR OUR SUITE OF
OFFERINGS TO GRANTEES ARE AM ARE
AT COMPREHENSIVE SET ALL ALL
FACETS OF A PROJECT THAT A LOCAL
ENTITY WOULD WANT TO IMPLEMENT
CAN BE COVERED.
BY AVAILABLE PROGRAMS --
AND WE'VE AS HERE IN ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY PROJECTS AND ALSO
FOR PROJECTS --
FOR PARTNERS OF THEIRS IN ONE OF
THEIR PROJECTS AND SO WE ARE
BEGINNING TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
TOGETHER --
TO GIVE PROJECT STAKEHOLDERS --
A SUITE OF SUPPORT YOU PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THE LAST THING I'LL JUST SAY
THAT WE ALSO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE US FOREST SERVICE AND
AS A CHIEF PORTER MENTIONED.
WE AT ALSO FUN TO THEM AND A
DECENT PRIVATELY INDUSTRIAL
LANDOWNERS TO ENSURE THAT
PROJECTS ARE EFFECTIVE ACROSS
FUNDING SOURCES IN OWNERSHIP
BOUNDARIES --
WE HAVE BEGUN MAPPING EFFORTS
ACROSS BOTH OWNERSHIP BOUNDARIES
AND PROGRAMS AND FUNDING SOURCES
SO THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND THIS
SPATIALLY AND I THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER WAY THAT --
WITHIN THE YEAR WE WILL BE --
ENHANCING THAT.
THE PROGRAM THAT WE DELIVER.
WITHOUT BOTH WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT IN WITH ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS SO I REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO PLAN
PRIORITIZE ACROSS REGIONS OF THE
STATE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MS AVERY.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR FRIEDMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANGELA
AVERY ON THE NEW EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THIS YEAR IN ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY --
NECKLACE BUT A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT THE BACKGROUND OF
THE S. AND SEE IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
THEM -- OFF
LINE -- WE
ARE STATE CONSERVANCY AND AS WE
HAVE RECEIVED A VARIETY OF AND
INITIATIVES THAT HAVE PASSED
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS AND SO I
REALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING.
IN THIS YEAR NEVADA.
REGION US STARTING WITH THE
WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
WHICH IS --
A PROGRAM THAT THE ESSENCE HE
DEVELOPED IN RESPONSE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN IN RESPONSE TO A
STEADILY INCREASING TREND OF
LARGE AND DAMAGING WILDFIRES
ACROSS OUR REGION --
WE WANT WE LAUNCHED THE WHIP AS
WE CALL IT --
AS A LARGE LANDSCAPE SCALE
HOLISTIC RESTORATION PROGRAM --
THAT'S BEING BEING IMPLEMENTED
ACROSS OUR REGION THROUGH A
STRONG NETWORK OF PARTNERS THAT
INCLUDE A STATE LOCAL FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TRIBAL GOT TRIBAL.
REPRESENTATIVES AND PRIVATE AND
NONPROFIT PARTNERS --
SADLY SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN
WE ORIGINALLY CONCEIVED OF THE
WEB -- IF
INSTEAD OF A COULDN'T OF
OCCURRED LIKE THE CAMPFIRE AND
THE INCREASE --
IN UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF TREE
MORTALITY HAVE TRULY REINFORCED
THE NEED FOR A STATE --
LEVEL WATERSHED SCHOOLS FULL
REGIONAL SCALE.
PROGRAM LIKE THE WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM --
THE WHIP WAS ACTUALLY CODIFIED
LAST YEAR --
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO REPORT THAT --
INTERESTING INNOVATIVE WAYS OF
DOING BUSINESS UNDER THIS
PROGRAM TO ADDRESS MANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY
FROM A REGIONAL PRIORITIZATION
TO WORKING CROSS AGENCIES --
TO IMPROVING FOR SOME WATERSHED
HEALTH LOOKING AT MEADOWS AND
AND THAT'S ABOUT THAT'S BIG
FOCUS OF OF HOW WE ARE WORKING --
WHO TO START WITH TALKING ABOUT
SOME THE HISTORY OF OUR GRANT
PROGRAM --
SINCE WE SINCE OUR CREATION.
WE'VE BEEN THE ESSENCE HE HAS
AWARDED MORE THAN SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION
EIGHTY FOUR PROPOSITION ONE AND
NOW PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
FUNDING --
ARE PROJECTS ARE HOLISTIC THEY
DO -- ARE
INTENDED TO ADDRESS LONG TERM
CLIMATE BENEFITS AND WATER
BENEFITS AND ALL OF THE BENEFITS
THAT COME WITH INVESTMENT IN
UPPER WATERSHEDS.
SPECIFICALLY WE LOOK AT WORK
THAT INCREASES THE PACE AND
SCALE OF ECOLOGICAL RESTORATION
ON THE GROUND THAT PROTECTS
COMMUNITIES.
THAT IMPROVES FORCED A MORTAR
SAID HEALTH --
INCLUDING MEADOWS IN RIPARIAN
AREAS -- IN
ORDER TO PROTECT WHAT WATER
SUPPLY AND PROJECTS THAT SECURE
CARBON.
OF AGAIN WITH THE OVERALL GOAL
OF TRYING TO IMPROVE --
CLIMATE RESILIENCE FOR THE STATE
BY LOOKING AT AN AREA THAT'S OUR
HOME SO MANY OF THE BENEFITS
THAT THAT ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF PROJECTS
THAT ARE UNIQUE TO THE WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM THAT BUILD
ON AND KIND OF OUR PART OF SOME
OF THE STUFF THAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM OF OTHER OF MY COLLEAGUES
UP HERE TODAY.
THE FIRST ONE IS THE TAHOE
CENTRAL SIERRA INITIATIVE
PROJECT --
THIS IS A PROJECT THAT IS A
LANDSCAPE SCALE PILOT PROJECT
IT'S ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION ACRES.
THAT IS LOOKING AT BRINGING
TOGETHER PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PARTNERS ACROSS THE CENTRAL
SIERRA NEVADA AND THE LAKE TAHOE
AREAS.
THIS PROJECT UTILIZES BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE TO IMPLEMENT.
ECOLOGICALLY BASED MANAGED FORCE
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS WHILE LOOKING
TO CREATE OPPORTUNITIES TO
SUPPORT OF FORCED RESTORATION
ECONOMY AND TO EXPLORE
INNOVATIVE PROCESS INVESTMENT
AND GOVERNMENT'S TOOLS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS YOU'VE
HEARD -- AND
YOU THINK MISS FLORIDA SIDE OF
THE T. CSIA PARTNERS WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN RECEIVING JUST
OVER THIRTY MILLION AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
FOR HIGH PRIORITY FORCE
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS.
ACROSS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LANDS.
ANOTHER PROJECT THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON THE CHIEF SOME OF THE
GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED
HERE ABOUT SORT OF CROSS
INVESTMENT IN AMPLIFICATION OF
PROJECTS TO LOOK ACHIEVE MORE.
LARGER LARGER GOLD RESILIENT
SCHOOLS IS THIS YEAR IN ABOUT A
STRATEGIC INVESTMENT PLAN.
THIS IS A PARTNERSHIP EFFORT
ALSO UNDER THE WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM THAT'S
REALLY FOCUSED ON COORDINATING A
VAST INVESTMENT ACROSS STATE
AGENCY AGENCIES.
UTILIZING EXISTING STATE GRANT
PROGRAMS --
AND REALLY WORKING TO ENSURE THE
HERE IN ABOUT A REGION.
THIS GROUP IS EXPLORING
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE
INVESTMENTS TO ALIGN GRANT
PROGRAMS TO TRACK PROJECT
EFFECTIVENESS AND TO WHAT
COLLABORATIVE COLLABORATIVELY TO
ACHIEVE SHARED GOALS --
MANY OF THE FOLKS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD FROM THIS MORNING OR
MEMBERS OF THIS GROUP AND WE ALL
SIGN THEM AND AMMO YOU IN LATE --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WORKING NOW
TO ADD THE FOR SERVICE TO THIS
GROUP --
WITH THE GOAL OF ACTUALLY
GETTING WORK WORK DONE ON THE
GROUND IN AND IN A WAY THAT
AMPLIFIES WHAT WHAT WHAT EACH OF
THE PROGRAM'S IS INTENDED TO DO.
ADDITIONALLY IN A TO THE ESSENCE
HE RECEIVED A UNIQUE ONE MILLION
DOLLAR APPROPRIATION IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FROM THE
TIMBER REGULATION ENFORCED
RESTORATION FUND --
THE GRANT WAS GIVEN I MEAN THE
DELICATE APPROPRIATION WAS GIVEN
TO THE US AND SEE TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF WILL INNOVATIVE.
A WOODEN BY AMOUNT BIOMASS
UTILIZATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
ODD JUST A REPORT QUICKLY ON
THAT WE HAVE AWARDED TO DATE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SUPPORT OF A
BIO ENERGY PROJECT.
IN CAMDEN BILL --
THAT WAS INTERESTING --
MILLION I WISH --
THOUSAND HOSEN DOLLARS REMAINING
BUT WE'VE GOT MORE THAN A
MILLION DOLLARS IN INTEREST FROM
PROJECT PROPONENTS THROUGHOUT
OUR REGION.
PROJECTS THAT MEET NEEDS IN THE
AREAS OF MILL SITE DEVELOPMENT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WOOD
PRODUCTS MANUFACTURING BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT.
I WANT TO ADD QUICKLY THAT A KEY
COMPONENT OF WHAT THE ESSENCE HE
DOES WITH THE WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM IS WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT CAPACITY.
AND WE HAVE EXPANDED THE WHIP SO
THAT IT FOCUSES ONMORE THAN
JUST FORCED AND WATERSHED HEALTH --
AND IS LOOKING AT HOUSE TO TO
STRATEGIC LAND CONSERVATION
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THE GOALS THAT
MS CHIANG MENTIONED SORT OF
LARGER CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
RESILIENCE --
HOW -- ARE
WE RECREATION RESOURCES CAN BE
PROTECTED BY INVESTING IN FORCE
AND WATERSHED HEALTH --
TO MAKE SURE THAT --
SEE ON ABOUT A RECREATION
RESOURCES CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
VALUE AND BENEFIT TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY.
BUT ALSO LOOKING AT RESILIENCE
HERE IN ABOUT A COMMUNITIES AND
THINKING ABOUT HOW THOSE HOW ARE
EFFORTS WHICH ARE REALLY FOCUSED
IN THE NATURAL RESOURCES.
ROME -- CAN
BE PROTECTED THROUGH THE WORK
THAT WE DO --
SO THESE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES
OF THE WAY THAT THE US AND SEE
IS APPROACHING THE RISKS AND
CHALLENGES FACING THIS YEAR IN
ABOUT A REGION AND OUR STATE.
WE LAUNCHED THE WHIP KNOWING
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDED A TRULY
DRAMATIC SHIFT AND SYMBOL
THINKING ABOUT THE WAY THAT
WE'RE APPROACHING FORCED HEALTH
TO GET IT. TO GET AHEAD OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT OF TYPES AND
KINDS OF PROJECTS THAT THE
ESSENCE HE IS WORKING ON ARE ALL
OR ARE PROJECTS THAT WILL SECURE
FOR SOME WATERSHED HEALTH IN OUR
REGION --
BUT THE IMPLICATIONS ON THE
BENEFITS OF THE WORK THAT WE
DEAL ARE MUCH FARTHER REACHING --
AND GO BEYOND OUR REGION AND
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA REMAINS.
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE AND HEALTHY
BECAUSE IT'S GOT CLEAN WATER
CLEAN AIR --
AND A PLACE TO GO AND REST OUR
MINDS.
AND PLAY.
SO -- I
THINK THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD
OVERALL OF DESCRIPTION OF WHAT
WE DO I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
DONNELLY.
GREAT THANK YOU AND IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE INVITED HERE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING
TODAY AND I APPRECIATED I'M MY
NAME'S JOHN DONOVAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD.
AND TO BEGIN THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD RECEIVED TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS --
LAST YEAR WITH THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION.
SIXTY EIGHT THESE FUNDS WILL
SUPPORT A VARIETY OF PROJECTS IN
SUPPORT OF REGIONAL CONSERVATION
INVESTMENT STRATEGIES.
NATURAL COMMUNITY CONSERVATION
PLANNING WORK.
IN NATURE YOU UNIVERSITY RESERVE
SYSTEM PROJECTS WILDLIFE
ORIENTED PUBLIC ACCESS.
AS WELL AS WILDLIFE AND FISH
PASSAGE INCLUDING WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS AND CONNECTIVITY.
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION
PROTECTION RESTORATION AND
IMPROVEMENT OF OUR UPPER
WATERSHED LANDS WITHIN THE
SIERRA NEVADA AND CASCADE
MOUNTAINS.
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
APPROVED PROP SIXTY GUIDELINES
IN NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR AND
WILL RELEASE A SERIES OF
SOLICITATIONS. FOR PROJECTS OVER
THE NEXT SIX MONTHS BASED ON
THOSE.
SUPPORTING --
USES.
ALSO TO FURTHER SUPPORT OUR WORK
WCBS CONTINUING TO SOLICIT FOR
PROJECTS THAT ARE PROPOSITION.
ONE STREAM FLOW ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM.
FUNDING IS DIRECTED TO PROJECTS
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
ENHANCEMENT TO THE AMOUNT TIMING
AND AND OR QUALITY OF WATER
AVAILABLE. FOR NATOMAS FISH
SPECIAL STATUS THREATENED AND
ENDANGERED OR AT RISK PC'S OR TO
PROVIDE RESILIENCE. TO CLIMATE
CHANGE INVENTOR VULNERABLE
WATERSHEDS.
WE ARE IN OUR THIRD YEAR OF
PROJECTS SOLICITATION
IMPLEMENTATION AND WILL BE
CONSIDERING A SWEET A PROPOSALS
DURING W. SEABEES MEETING.
AS SCHEDULED ON APRIL FOURTH.
IN ADDITION WCBS CLIMATE AND
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY
PROGRAM WAS CREATED.
THROUGH ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH
NINE WHICH ON SEPTEMBER
SIXTEENTH OF LAST YEAR IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AMENDED
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO PROVIDE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. TO W. C. B. FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE PROJECTS
PAYABLE FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND.
THE FUNDING WILL BE IS FOR
PROJECTS A PART TACT AND RESTORE
NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS TO PROVIDE
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE.
ASSISTS NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS MANAGERS TWO AND BECOMING
MORE RESILIENT TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
FACILITATE THE REDUCTION OF G.
G. H. G. EMISSIONS.
INCREASED CARBON SEQUESTRATION
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS.
AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SOCIAL
ECONOMIC.
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
GUIDELNES FOR THE PROGRAM WERE
APPROVED AND SOLICITATION WAS
RELEASED IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN W. CV RECEIVED
AT FORTY NINE FOUR PROPOSALS
REQUESTING MORE THAN THIRTY TWO
MAN.
MILLION DOLLARS UNDER THIS
PROGRAM.
FINAL APPROVAL OF THE PROJECTS
AND A WARD OF THE FUNDS
RECOMMENDED BY W. CITY SELECTION
COMMITTEE WILL BE CONSIDERED BY
THE WILL OF CONSERVATION WERE
STARTING ON MARCH SEVENTH AT ITS
FIRST YEAR OF TWO THOUSAND NINE
FIRST MEETING.
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN DEBBIE
C. B. AS A SMALL AND DEDICATED
STAFF TO IMPLEMENT FOURTEEN
FUNDING PROGRAMS --
STATEWIDE.
WE SECURE THE HELP OF OUR VALUED
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL PARTNERS
TO ASSIST US IN PROJECT
EVALUATION.
SELECTION PROCESS AND
PRIORITIZATION FOR ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS AT THE B. C. B..
AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE PROJECTS
APPROVED BY THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD.
INCLUDES A PRE EVALUATION THE
BIOLOGICAL MERITS OF THE
PROPOSAL BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND UNDER OUR FORCE PROGRAM
APPLICATIONS ARE EVALUATED
SCORED IN REVIEW.
AND PRIORITIZED.
BY AT A PANEL MADE UP OF CAL
FIRE.
FARMING FISHING WILDLIFE AND
DEPARTMENT OF WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD STAFF.
DEBBIE C. B. CONTINUES TO STAY
ENGAGED IN SEVERAL COORDINATION
ACTIVITIES FOCUSED ON STATEWIDE
CONSERVATION PRIORITIES.
SENATOR ON CLIMATE RESILIENCY
AND ADAM EATING HEALTHY
ECOSYSTEMS FOR IN FOREST LANDS
AND WORKING LANDSCAPES.
THE SIERRA NEVADA STRATEGIC
INVESTMENT PLANNING GROUP.
SIERRA NEVADA'S LEADERSHIP FORUM
THE SIERRA MEADOWS PARTNERSHIP.
CALIFORNIA NATURAL WORKING LANCE
GROUP ARE JUST EXCELLENT ARE
EXCELLENT EXAMPLES.
OF THE EFFORTS UNDER WAY TO
DISCUSS CONSERVATION GOALS
PRIORITIES AND STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS AND PACKS IN A TO AND
OBTAIN POSITIVE RESULTS
ASSOCIATED WILDFIRE.
STRESSED FOR US AND WORKING
LANDS WITHIN THE SEARS.
THE B. C. B. HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
IMPORTANT WATERSHEDS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF OUR
VALUED FEDERAL STATE LOCAL AND
NON PROFIT PARTNERS.
NATE ONCE AGAIN I JUST
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE THIS MORNING AND BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER BREAK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
CHAIR FRIEDMAN A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SO MY NAME IS CALEY BRADEN I'M
NOW THE DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION
OF LAND RESOURCE PROTECTION AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION --
AND TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO
YOU GUYS BRIEFLY ON THE WORK
WE'RE DOING WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY --
TO BUILD CAPACITY OF THERE'S TO
LEAVE FORCED HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION WORK --
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT THE
STATE SHOULD BE REALLY PROUD OF
THE WORK WE DID LAST YEAR --
WE PASSED THIS LEGISLATURE LEAD
AND THE PASSING OF SWEEPING
STATUTORY REFORMER AND FORESTRY.
AND WE MADE HISTORIC FUNDING
COMMITMENTS TO FORCED AND FIRE
PREVENTION WORK [inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW ALL OF THIS IS IS
FANTASTIC BUT LET'S AS I THINK
WITH THE CHAIR AND CHIEF PORTER
MENTIONED IT REALLY SUCCESS OF
THIS WORK REALLY HINGES.
ON THE ABILITY OF OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS TO LINE UP PERMITTED
PROJECTS THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
MOVE FORWARD AND DO ON THE
GROUND -- WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THOSE PROJECTS
ARE PROJECTS THAT ACTUALLY ARE
WANTED BY THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THEIR PROJECTS THAT MEET
COMMUNITY NEEDS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THEY ALSO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR STATEWIDE --
PUBLIC SAFETY CLIMATE AND ECO
SYSTEM GOALS.
LAST YEAR OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY WAS
APPROPRIATED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN CAP AND TRADE FUNDS
TO LEAVE THIS TYPE OF EFFORT --
REALLY EMPOWERING REGIONAL
LEADERS IN THE SPACE OF
IDENTIFYING THE PRIORITIES THAT
ARE MOST IMPORTANT TO THEIR
REGION'S DEVELOPING PROJECTS
AROUND THOSE PRIORITIES.
AND THEN --
GETTING THOSE PROJECTS READY TO
PLUG DIRECTLY INTO OUR LARGER
STATE --
FUNDING PROGRAMS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD OF TODAY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION --
IN AT MY WORK ON THIS PROJECT
THIS PROGRAM AT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AND WHEN I WHEN
I MOVED TO THE DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION.
WE WERE THRILLED TO CAN A
PARTNER WITH THE AGENCY IN
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE THAT A FIRST DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION IS A LONG HISTORY
OF BUILDING CAPACITY LOCAL
PARTNERS.
WE HAVE BEEN THE PRIMARY KIND OF
OUR OUR PRIMARY RELATIONSHIP
GOES BACK TO REALLY THE DUST
BOWL YEARS WHEN WE ARE FORM TO
WORK WITH OUR CD'S I'M
PROTECTING --
THE STATE'S LANDS AND SOIL
QUALITY THAT HAS GROWN OVER THE
YEARS THROUGH OTHER --
FARM LAND AND SEE PROGRAMS MOST
RECENTLY AND PROBABLY MOST --
CONNECT THIS IS THE WATER SAID --
COORDINATOR PROGRAM THAT RAN
OVER THE LAST.
FROM THE FIRST MUST THE FIRST
DECADE OF ON THE TWO THOUSAND WE
FROM THAT PROGRAM WE REALLY
LEARNED FROM THE WATERSHED
COORDINATOR PROGRAM WE REALLY
LEARNED THAT.
IF YOU JUST INVEST A LITTLE BIT
OF MONEY INTO OUR STATE PARTNERS
YOU KNOW THESE ARE STATE
PARTNERS ARE OUR CD'S OR NON
PROFITS ARE --
WATERSHED CENTERS THE ONE TO
BRING PROJECTS TO OUR STATE
FUNDING PROGRAMS ARE PRETTY MUCH
AND UNDER FUNDED IN ANYTHING BUT
THE GRAPH AND THEY GET SO THEY
HAVE VERY LITTLE CAPACITY TO
THINK STRATEGICALLY --
GO OUT AND BUILD COALITIONS
AROUND PRIORITIES REALLY DO THE
WORK THAT YOU NEED TO HAVE A
BROADER VISION THAN JUST THE
SINGULAR GRANT THAT YOU GET FROM
A FUNDING PROJECT.
ENOUGH UP FROM A FUNDING PROGRAM.
IN IN IN AS WE IMPLEMENT OUR
WATERSHED COORDINATOR PROGRAM WE
WE REALLY LEARNED THAT IF YOU
JUST FIND ONE OR TWO STAFF
PEOPLE AND SOME OF THESE NON
PROFITS.
YOU IMMEDIATELY SEE EXPONENTIAL
BENEFITS ON THOSE INVESTMENTS --
THOSE ONE OR TWO STAFFS ARE ABLE --
TO GO OUT INTO THE FIELD AND
BUILD SUPPORT BRING MATCHING
FUNDS YOU KNOW.
DOUBLING TRIPLING INVESTMENTS ON
THE GROUND.
FOR AND THEN THEY'RE ABLE TO
MOBILIZE A MUCH MORE THAN JUST --
YOU KNOW.
THOSE GROUPS COULD IN OTHER
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE WERE JUST
WILL OPERATE UNDER --
KIND OF SINGULAR GRANT FUNDING
MODELS.
SO WE REALLY ARE TRYING TO
EXPAND UPON THIS MODEL FOR THE
FORCE AND FIRE --
THE REGIONAL FORCE IN FACT
PASSED THE PROGRAM WE SEE
REGION'S AS THE ENGINE AND KIND
OF THE MECHANICS BEHIND GETTING
PROJECTS TO CAL FIRE TO THE W.
C. B. TO THE CINEMATIC
CONSERVANCY. TO MEET THESE
LARGER GOALS A CHEAP PORTER WALK
THROUGH EARLIER TODAY --
LAST YEAR FOR THIS PROGRAM --
YOU KNOW NATURAL RESOURCES WAS
APPROPRIATED FUNDING AND THEN
THIS THIS TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS APPROPRIATED.
IS GOING TO BE PUT OUT IN BLOCK
GRANTS TO REGIONAL --
REGIONAL LEADERS IN THE IN THE
NORTH COASTAL SOUTH IN EASTERN
REGIONS OF THE STATE.
THESE BLOCK GRANTS WILL BOOK
GOOD A ORGANIZATIONS LIKE ST
CONSERVANCY'S LOCAL R. CD'S AM
AND OTHER NON PROFITS THAT HAVE
THAT REGIONAL REACH WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION BUT ALSO HAVE.
STRONG FISCAL CAPACITY PARTNER
RELATIONSHIP SO THAT THEY CAN.
IN LISTS SUPPORT FROM AND AND
HELP FROM ALL OF THEIR LOCAL
PARTNERS --
IN ADDITION TO THIS THIS PROGRAM
WILL BE FUNDING BLOCK GRANTS TO
A STATEWIDE SUPPORT ENTITY THAT
WILL BE --
INTO PLAYING A ROLE OF PROVIDING
QUALITY ASSURANCE AND
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE WHOLE
PROGRAM.
AND THEN LASTLY --
THIS FUNDING WILL BE SPENT AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH CALLED --
FOR SPATIAL PLANNING AND
PRIORITIZATION OF OF PROJECTS
AND PERMITTING STRUCTURES WITHIN
THE WATER SHEDS THAT FEED THE
STATE.
WATER PROJECT POST THE STATE'S
WATER SYSTEM --
ONE IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS
SENDING THIS GOES TO THE CHAIR'S
COMMENTS ON ON BARRIERS AND
TRYING NEW THINGS TO GET THESE
PROJECTS MOVING --
WE ON THIS PROGRAM REALLY IS
INTENDED TO BE A SACRAMENTO
LIGHT APPROACH --
WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE FUNDING
EFFICIENTLY TO OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS AND THEN REALLY RELYING
ON THEM TO COORDINATE THE
STRATEGIES AND THE PARTNER
NETWORKS TO IMPLEMENT THOSE.
PRIORITIES --
WORK WE'RE GOING TO BE TESTING
ADVANCE FUNDING STRATEGIES THAT
ARE REALLY DIFFICULT TO DO IN
STATE GOVERNMENT --
WE'RE TRYING TO SIMPLIFY OUR
CONTRACTING PROCESS SEES SO THAT
WE CAN REALLY GET GET PROJECTS
MOVING THE BILL FLEXIBILITY INTO
OUR CONTRACTING SO THAT AS
REGION TO KIND OF SEE THE NEEDS
IN REAL TIME.
WE DON'T GET BOGGED DOWN BY AN
OF OUR OWN CONTRACTING --
ARMED CONTRACTING SYSTEMS.
WE WE WILL BE REQUIRING THAT
REGIONAL BLOCK GRANT TEASE
ANALYST PARTNERS SO WE WHAT WE
DON'T WANT OUR SINGULAR ENTITIES
DICTATING THROUGHOUT THEIR
REGION'S WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
THE GOAL OF THIS REALLY IS TO
BUILD THE KIND OF POLITICAL
NETWORKS THE SOCIAL NETWORKS AND
THE TECHNICAL NETWORKS TO
DEVELOP.
REGIONAL PRIORITY PLANS THAT BY
IN AND HAVE --
RESPECT AMONGST ALL THE
COMMUNITIES IN THOSE REGIONS --
THOSE THOSE REGIONAL BLOOD
GRANTEES WILL ALSO --
SO THEY WILL BE KIND OF THEY'LL
BE CHARGED WITH AND LISTING
PARTNERS --
AGAIN THOSE THEIR SUB GRANTEE
PARTNERS WILL WILL INCLUDE --
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
WATER SAID CENTERS TRIBES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND NO --
YOU KNOW AN EXAMPLE IN THIS RACE
IS DISTRICT WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING A LOT WITH THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
RESOURCE CONSERVATION TO REACH
THE RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT.
AND IT'S JUST IT'S REALLY
REMARKABLE KIND OF WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND THE
DITCHES IS READY TO REALLY PLUG
INTO WHAT THE STATE'S DOING --
THIS WORK WILL BE DESIGNED TO
MAXIMIZE COMMUNITY AND
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH. ONE WHEN
NATURAL --
WITH SITUATION WE SEE AND MANY
FORCE YOU PRIDE KIND OF EFFORTS
AS THAT THE CIRCLES VERY SMALL.
OVER OF THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
COME TO THE TABLE AND TALK ABOUT
THESE PROJECTS IS USUALLY IT'S
THE FORRESTERS WITH THE
NONPROFIT THAT HAVE FORSTER'S
IT'S THE IT'S THE FEDS AT THE
STATE.
AND WHAT WHAT THIS PROGRAM
REALLY WANTS TO DO IS EXPAND THE
CONVERSATION TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT LIVE IN AND AROUND THOSE
PROJECTS.
AND THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT RELY
ON THE BENEFITS FROM THOSE
PROJECTS --
THAT AGAIN IS KIND OF THE
SELFISH GOAL OF BUILDING
POLITICAL SUPPORT FOR ITS WORK
LOCALLY AND SO OUR PROGRAMS CAN
HAVE A STRONG BASE TO WORK FROM
WHEN YOU KNOW TWO THREE YEARS
OUT WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO KEEP.
ALL THIS MOMENTUM GOING AND WE
SEE PROJECTS ON THE SHELF KIND
OF DWINDLING [inaudible]
THE LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
WILL ALSO BE A REALLY.
CRITICAL PIECE OF THIS AND IT'S
A LITTLE IT'S IT'S A LITTLE MORE
NEBULOUS BUT IT HAS TO BE A
PRIORITY --
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE WE WILL BE
INVESTING LARGE SUMS OF MONEY IN
TO REGIONS OF THE STATE THAT
HAVE NOT SEEN.
SOME KIND OF MUCH JOB
OPPORTUNITY IN THE GROWTH OF THE
REST OF THE STATE HAS
EXPERIENCED --
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE LABOR
SHORTAGES AND SHORTAGES OF
TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO GET TO DO
THE SECRET TO DO THE PLANNING TO
DO EVERYTHING ELSE.
IN THIS REALLY IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD --
LOCAL LABOR FORCES THAT CAN
ACTUALLY.
PLUG INTO THIS FUNDING STREAMS
OR NOT BRINGING CREWS AND FROM
TEXAS AND ARIZONA AND OTHER
STATES WHERE THEY YOU KNOW
TRAVEL AND IN THE CALIFORNIA
OFTEN TO DO THIS WORK --
IF WE ARE SUCCESSFUL.
AND IT'S GOOD TO JUST BE KIND OF
HONEST ABOUT SUCCESS HERE IS
THAT.
YOU KNOW WE WILL HAVE EMPOWERED
REGIONS.
THAT -- HAVE
ACTIVATED AND AN ARCHITECTURE OF
OF OF OF LOCAL PARTNERS LOCAL
COMMUNITY GROUPS.
IN ARE ARE ARE ARE ABLE TO BRING --
A CONSISTENT Q. TO OUR STATE
PROGRAMS OF PROJECTS THAT MEET
THEIR NEEDS BUT ALSO MEET OUR
STATE CLIMB IN NEEDS.
AND OUR ECOSYSTEM AND PRIORITIES
SO I THINK THE THAT THAT
DISTINGUISH ARE THERE IS THAT
YOU KNOW YOU YOU.
YOU HAVE TO BALANCE BETWEEN THE
LANDSCAPE IN THE SMALLER
PROJECTS AS WE HAVE WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER.
AND THEN YOU ALSO NEED TO
BALANCE BETWEEN SIX THAT.
MAY MEET --
IMMEDIATE PUBLIC SAFETY NEEDS
AROUND COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO
THOSE THAT PROVIDE THE WATERSHED --
INSURANCE POLICIES. FOR FOR
YEARS TO COME BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
THINK BROADER THAN THE THE THE
THE THREATS THAT ARE IMMEDIATELY
IN FRONT OF US --
AT THIS POINT IN THE PROCESS
WE'VE --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING THIS FUNDING
WAS APPROPRIATE AT THE END OF
THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH BLACK
POTENTIAL BLOCK GRANTEES --
FOR THEIR PROPOSALS IN THEIR
BUDGETS.
WE CLOSED OUR GUIDELINES --
PUBLIC COMMENT ON OUR GUIDELINES
LAST WEEK WE'RE GETTING READY TO
ANNOUNCE OUR AWARDS FOR THE FOR
THE BLOCK GRANT IT'S HOPEFULLY
VERY SOON.
AND THOSE WILL BE DRAFT AWARDS
AND THEN THOSE WILL BE POSTED
FOR I THINK TEN OR FIFTEEN DAYS
UNTIL THE FINAL AWARDS WERE WERE
SCOPING OUT TOWARDS THE END OF
THE MONTH.
SO HOPEFULLY THE NEXT TIME WE
TALK ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IT'LL BE
SOMEBODY.
ENOUGH FROM THOSE REGIONS THAT
ABOUT WHAT IS ACTUALLY NEEDED IN
THOSE REGION THE CAN REALLY TALK
TO YOU ABOUT HOW.
YOU KNOW.
THERE HELD THEIR NEEDS ARE BEING
ADDRESSED OR WHAT THEY SEE AS
THEIR HORIZON LINE.
SO I I GUESS.
YEAH ONE MORE TO MORE POINTS OR
ONE MORE POINT.
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THIS WORK IS.
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE WERE.
AS WE'RE TAKING A LIGHT ALLIED
APPROACH OF WATCHING OVER THE
WORK THAT THEY DO.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THEY
ACTUALLY DELIVER PROJECTS TO
MEET OUR STATE NEEDS --
THAT IS BEING STRUCTURED AND
TORE STATE FOREST MANAGEMENT
TASK FORCE AND THE REGIONAL
PRIORITIZATION GROUPS THAT HAVE
BEEN FORMED.
SO IN THOSE REGIONAL
PRIORITIZATION GROUPS THAT ARE
UNDERNEATH TASK FORCE.
THESE.
THESE BLOCK GRANTEES WILL ENGAGE
WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF THOSE
GROUPS.
AND THEY WILL ALSO TAKE THE WORK
THAT IS BEING DONE RIGHT NOW
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER THE FORTY FIVE DAY PLAN AS
IT'S BEING CALLED.
AND KIND OF USE THAT AS THE THE
THE PLANET IS PRIORITIZING
STATEWIDE FIRE AND FORESTRY
NEEDS.
AND THEY'LL USE THAT ALL --
TO BRING THAT TOGETHER AND AND
AND AND MAKE SURE THEY HAD IT
LINES UP AND AND AND IT'S AND
THEY BRING TO US PROJECTS THAT
MAKES SENSE AND THAT WE WE WANT
TO FUND SOME.
IF IT ALL WORKS AS PLANNED WILL
BE -- WILL
BE IN GOOD SHAPE OVER THE SUMMER.
AND I REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
SHARING WITH WITH THE COMMITTEE
IN THE MEMBERS ABOUT THEIR
SPECIFIC REGIONS AS THOSE
PARTNERS ARE LINED UP SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU --
I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS AND
BECAUSE YOU'RE RUNNING LATE I'M
GONNA ASK EVERYONE TO TRY TO BE
AS CONCISE AS YOU CAN.
AND A LOT OF EXCELLENT
PERMISSION ON PRESENTED.
OFFERS FOR MISTER AHLERS --
ONE OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET BILLS
SB EIGHT FIFTY SIX REQUIRE THE
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY AND CAL FIRE TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT PRIORITIZE
EXPENDITURES. FOR THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM HEALTHY
FOREST PRESCRIBED BURNS AND
OTHER FUEL TREATMENT IN FOREST
WATER SAID PROGRAMMATIC WORK.
I'M WONDERING --
IF YOU FEEL THE THIS REQUIREMENT
ADDRESSES THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR PRIORITIZATION YOU MADE IN
YOUR REPORT OR IS THERE MORE TO
BE.
DONE AND IF SO WHAT DIRECTION
WOULD YOU SUGGEST WE DO THAT
WORK.
YEAH I THINK AS I MENTIONED YOU
KNOW THERE WAS DEFINITELY
PROGRESS MADE AND I AND I AND IF
THAT WASN'T CLEAR THAN I I TO
MAKE IT MORE CLEAR PROGRESS MADE
ON THIS LAST YEAR BOTH BOTH
THROUGH SB FIFTY SIX AS WELL AS
AB. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE I
THINK OUR OUR MAIN POINT TO YOU
IS THIS NEEDS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO CHECK BACK AND SEE
WHAT THOSE PLANS COME BACK TO
YOU AS AN ARE YOU SATISFIED WITH
THE CRITERIA THAT THAT YOU'RE
RECEIVING --
BUT ALSO HOW IS IT BEING
IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE I THINK.
PARTICULARLY AS WE LOOKED AT THE
THAT FORCE HEALTH GRANT PROGRAM
NOW ALL OF THE CRITERIA THEY
LIST ARE --
SEEM GOOD AND AN APPROPRIATE BUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM AND SO I
THINK OUR CONCERN IS THAT.
I BEAT THE THAN THAT SUCH A
TARGET RICH ENVIRONMENT RIGHT
NOW THERE ARE SO MANY NEEDS THAT
IF -- IF WE
CAN CONTINUE TO HIT ALL OF THOSE
PRIOR TO POSITION CRITERIA AND
STILL NOT HAVE A STRATEGIC
CUMULATIVE IMPACT BECAUSE OF THE
NEEDS AND SO I THINK.
THAT'S OUR MAIN MESSAGE TO YOU
IS -- WE'RE
MAKING GREAT PROGRESS BUT LET'S
LET'S KEEP OUR EYE ON IT AND CAN
CONTINUE HEARING BACK AND AND
ENSURING THAT.
THOSE GOALS ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED GOT IT THANK YOU.
OF MR BRADY --
I WONDER IF YOU CAN JUST.
BRIEFLY EXPLAIN IF THERE ARE
OTHER REGIONS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN LARGE INITIATIVES
LIKE THIS YEAR IN ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
AND ALSO WHAT THE SCOPE OF
AREAS.
SO THERE.
THE REGIONS THAT WE HAVE
OUTLINED IN OUR PROGRAM COVERALL OF THE MAJOR FORCE IT
REGIONS OF THE STATE --
AND WE WE WERE WORKING WITH THE
CINEMATIC CONSERVANCY IS ONE OF
THOSE THAT WE SOLICIT A PROPOSAL
FOR FOR OUR PROGRAM --
THE WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM THE MODEL THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EXPORTING IN THIS
PROGRAM.
AND IT REALLY IS YOU KNOW.
BEING ABLE TO FULLY DEVELOP THE
WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
AND ALL OF ITS LARGE
JURISDICTION WOULD BE.
EXCELLENT --
I I MAY NOT BE THE BEST PERSON
TO SPEAK ABOUT ALL OF THE
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS IT
BECAUSE IT IT DIFFERS FROM
REGION TO REGION BUT JUST IN MY
OWN WORK SETTING UP THIS PROGRAM --
WE HAVE.
WE HAVE WE HAVE REALLY STRONG
FEDERAL PARTNERS AND I'VE BEEN
I'VE BEEN REALLY SURPRISED AT
HOW STRONG THOSE ARE YOU KNOW
ACROSS THE STATE I KNEW FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE NORTH --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK UP IN
THE CLAIMS CASCADES IT'S KIND OF
A LINE PRIORITIES AND UP INTO
THE THAT THE TRIBUTARIES DOWN IN
THE IN THE NORTH NORTH NORTH
COAST AREA.
BUT EVEN DOWN INTO THE SOUTHERN
PART OF THE STATE THERE'S JUST A
REAL CONVERGENCE AND CONSENSUS
FORMING BETWEEN THAT THE
MANAGERS OF THESE TYPES OF
EFFORTS.
TO ALIGN THEIR PRIORITIES AND
THEIR WORK SO.
I DON'T KNOW I THINK THAT'S A
THAT'S THAT WAS MY EXPERIENCE.
RATE AND HOW DOES THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY PLAN UNDERSTAND
THE CURRENT HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S LARGE WATERSHEDS
AND I'M WONDERING HOW THOSE
NEEDS AND FUEL REDUCTION NEEDS --
INTERACT --
INTERSECT.
IT IT IT IT IS DIFFERENT IN EACH
REGION --
BECAUSE THEY ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
RELATIONSHIPS SO THE PARTNERS
WERE TALKING TO IN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF THE REGION HAVE VERY
STRONG RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
WITH THE SOUTHERN --
WITH THE WITH THE SANTA ANA
RIVER YOU KNOW WATERSHED WATER
DISTRICTS AND WE WE REALLY HELP
TO BRIDGE THAT --
THAT ISSUE WITH THIS PROGRAM
HAVE WATER DISTRICTS WHO WHO WHO
KIND OF INTUITIVELY UNDERSTND
THE BENEFITS OF THIS WORK BUT
THEY HAVEN'T QUITE GOTTEN
INVOLVED IN.
PUSHING THE ENVELOPE AND
PARTICIPATION --
WE HOPE THAT BY TAKING ONE STEP
FORWARD AND KIND OF WORKING WITH
THE PARTNERS THAT THEY'RE MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH YOU CAN START
TO BRING THOSE WATER WATER
DISTRICTS IN WHO DO UNDERSTAND
THE WATER FILLED THE LARGER
WATER SAID NEEDS FOR WATER
SUPPLY -- IN
A WERE YOU HAVE TO UNLESS THE
ALSO THE PARTNERS AND UNDERSTAND
THE OTHER BENEFITS OF A WATER
SAID AND BRING THOSE INTO THE
FALL THAT YOU BUILD PRIORITIES --
TARGET RICH ENVIRONMENT LIKE --
RACHEL JUST MENTION IT WILL BE.
IT'LL BE DIFFERENT EVERYWHERE
AND ANOTHER PIECE IN A WERE WERE
SHAPING IN THE NORTH AND THE
NORTHERN DISTRICT NORTHERN
REGION WE'RE LOOKING AT WE WE
HAVE SHAPED AROUND THE THE WALK
THOUGH THE NORTH COAST REGIONAL
WATER BOARD.
DISTRICT WHICH IS REPRESENTS THE
WATER SAID SET ALL DRAIN INTO
THE INTO THE PACIFIC.
THAT ARE ALL KIND OF COVERED BY
THE SAME REGULATORY BODIES OF
THANK YOU --
IS A VERY A SPEAKNG OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I'M WONDERING
HOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
INTERACTED WITH YOUR WORKING
WITH THEY'VE A GOOD PARTNER FOR
YOU.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE US
FOREST SERVICE HAS BEEN A
CRITICAL PARTNER IN THE
WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
THEY WERE ONE OF THE THEY WERE A
KEY PARTNER WHEN WE ORIGINALLY
IMPLEMENTED THE WATERSHED AND
LAUNCH THE WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM IN --
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND OUR
PARTNERSHIP IS SHIFTED A LITTLE
BIT IN THE LAST FEW YEARS AS WE
HAVE.
TRIED TO FOCUS MORE ON GETTING
WORK DONE ON FEDERAL LANDS TO
YOU KNOW ADDRESS ALL OF THE
VALUES AND AND AND AND FORCE
HEALTH NEEDS THAT NEED TO BE
ACTUALLY ADDRESSED SO --
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE'VE DONE
THAT AS WE'VE ESTABLISHED A GOOD
AND REGION FOUR AS IT RELATES --
TO AT THE SIDE OF OUR REGION AND
WE'RE TRYING TO UTILIZE THAT TO
GET -- ARE
FUNDING THE FUNDING THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO US ON THE GROUND IN
MORE EFFICIENT AND MORE QUICKLY
TO ADDRESS ISSUES.
RAPIDLY GREAT SO ONE OF THE
MESSAGES I'M HEARING OVER AND
OVER FROM ALL OF YOU IS ABOUT
THE COORDINATION AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT BETWEEN
DIFFERENT ENTITIES NOT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOWN TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING I'LL OKAY
SO ASK YOU MS EVERY --
WHETHER THERE'S MORE THAT WE CAN
DO TO HELP FOSTER ANY OF THAT
COORDINATION AND COMMUNICATION.
YOU CAN SAY NO IF YOU WANT I
KNOW.
IT'S IT'S A GOOD QUESTION BUT I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW --
AGENCIES LIKE OURS YOU KNOW
WE'VE GOT LOCAL RELATIONSHIPS
AND LOCAL PARTNERS ARE CRITICAL
TO WHAT WE DO WE ARE NOT
SUCCESSFUL IN ANYTHING THAT WE
IMPLEMENT UNLESS WE'VE GOT INPUT
FROM OUR PARTNERS --
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO SAY ON THE
SPOT -- IF
THERE'S ANYTHING LEGISLATORS
COULD DO TO IMPROVE THOUGHT --
OUR RELATIONSHIPS ARE BASED ON I
THINK TRUST AND OF OUR
AVAILABILITY AND OUR DESIRE TO
SORT OF RAISE LOCAL ISSUES UP TO
STATE.
HERE'S IF YOU WILL --
SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
THOUGHTS ON NOT BUT I FEEL LIKE
IT'S A THING THAT THE ESSENCE HE
IS REALLY GOOD AT THAT WE
SUCCEED I'D AND I CAN IMAGINE
HOW YOU WOULD.
IMPROVE THE THERE MAY BE WAYS
I'M NOT THINKING OF I I WOULD
JUST I WOULD JUST GO BACK TO THE
YOU KNOW THE R. C. D. EXAMPLE
THAT KIND OF SHOWCASE HOW.
MANY OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
DOING AMAZING WORK WITH
PRACTICALLY NO FUNDING.
AND IN A SPECIFICALLY WITH OUR
CD'S THEY ARE ONE OF OUR
STRONGEST PARTNERS ACROSS ALL OF
OUR WATER SAID WORK.
AND IN MANY OF THEM YOU KNOW NOT
ALL OF THEM BECAUSE SOME OF THEM
DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT FUNDING.
MANY OF THEM DON'T HAVE ANY --
TAX BASE TO WORK FROM AND
THERE'S THERE'S SOLELY DEPENDENT
ON GRANTS IN THE THE SMALL BITS
OF ADMIN THEY GET FROM THOSE
GRANTS -- TO
OPERATE SO --
FOR US IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THIS IS THE GOAL OF OUR PROGRAM
I THINK THAT THIS IS JUST THIS
IS JUST A ONE TIME PROGRAM YOU
KNOW FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO BE
STRATEGIC.
LONG STANDING PARTNERS TO THE
STATE THEY NEED TO HAVE SOME AND
STATES CAN ASSURANCES THAT THEY
HAVE.
THEY CAN BUILD A PROGRAM AROUND
THESE THESE CALLS OTHERWISE
YOU'RE JUST CHASING
OPPORTUNISTIC LEE WHAT WE THROW
OUT THERE ON THE TABLE.
I JUST WANT TO SECOND WHAT HE'S
SAYING ADICIONAL FUNDING TO
SUPPORT CAPACITY BUILDING TO
REALLY --
ADD -- TO
WHAT THESE GROUPS ARE.
ADD TO THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
GROUPS ACTUALLY IT'S AND IN THE
REGION'S WOULD BE HELPFUL SO.
CORRECTION.
CAN I MAKE ONE QUICK COMMENT
ALSO TO ADD ON TO THAT AND I
THINK IT GOES BACK TO DIRECTOR
PORTERS COMMENTS THIS MORNING
ABOUT WORKING WITH LANDOWNERS.
IN YOUR C. D. REALLY PROVIDES A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF WORKING
WITH THE LOCAL LANDOWNERS.
IN JURISDICTIONS WHERE WE NEED
TO WORK AND WE SHOULD BE WORKING.
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY OWN
PROPERTY AND THAT THE AREA THEY
LIVE THERE SO THEY PROVIDE THAT
NEXUS BETWEEN THE LOCAL THE
LOCAL THE LOCAL LANDOWNERS.
AND THE AND THE GOVERNMENT SO I
THINK THEY'RE CRITICAL AND AND
WE'RE GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU KNOW LAST MISS AVERY A
LAST QUESTION WHICH IS ARE THERE
ANY BARRIERS THAT YOU CAN
IDENTIFY. TO INCREASING THE
SCOPE IN THE PACE OF YOUR OF THE
RESTORATION WORK IN THIS YEAR AS
THERE ARE.
A VARIETY OF BARRIERS INCREASING
THE SCOPE AND PACE BUT I THINK
THAT -- IN
SOME OF THE PROJECTS THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTING THE TAHOE CENTRAL
SEER INITIATIVE AREA WORK WE'RE
EXPLORING HOW TO ADDRESS THOSE
BARRIERS VIA --
LARGE LANDSCAPE SCALE PROJECTS --
WORKING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS --
TO ESTABLISHED.
LONGER TERM STEWARDSHIP
AGREEMENTS THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO ACTUALLY GET --
MORE OF THE BIOMASS THAT NEEDS
TO FOREST'S TO ON THE FACILITIES
THAT NEED TO PROCESS IT --
BE THOSE BY AMOUNTS.
OF ENERGY OR BIOMASS UTILIZATION
OF THE TWO THOUSAND TWO ZERO
INITIATIVE AREAS ALSO LOOKING AT
STREAMLINING --
THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND PERMITTING
PROCESS SEES AND THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
OUT AS WELL --
AT SB NINE A ONE ADDRESSED SOME
OF THE BARRIERS LAST YEAR IN THE
SENSE OF LOOKING AT A SECRET
EXEMPTIONS AND THINGS THAT ALLOW
US TO GET WORK DONE MORE QUICKLY --
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE INITIAL
ONES THAT I CAN THINK OF GREAT.
AND THEN --
MISS CHANG I JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU FIRST OF ALL --
WE'VE BEEN INVESTING WHAT DO
BEST OPTION IS FOR MATERIAL
REMOVED FROM THE FAR AS FOR AIR
QUALITY AND GHG EMISSIONS I KNOW
THAT THAT'S A BIT OF A
CONTROVERSIAL SUBJECT I'D LOVE
TO HEAR.
YOUR PERSPECTIVE FROM --
FROM YOUR AGENCY SURE THAT IS SO
I'M NOT SURE THAT THERE'S ONE
BEST ANSWER TO THIS AND I THINK
THAT --
ENCHILADAS MENTIONED --
IN HER REMARKS THAT THERE BE
HOSTED WITH UC BERKELEY A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO A BUYER WILL COME TO
ME FROM IT AT ON THE CAMPUS AT
BERKELEY AND IT WAS REALLY
EXCITING TO LISTEN.
TO THE POTENTIAL THAT WE HAVE TO
REALLY MOVE BEYOND THE KIND
ABOUT BIO MASS PROJECT THAT WE
ALL THINK ABOUT SO WE THINK
ABOUT THESE DIRTY BIOMASS PLANTS.
MANY OF WHICH ARE IN COMMUNITIES
OF THAT --
REALLY CAN'T TAKE THAT POLLUTION
BURDEN AND AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW
WE CAN MOVE BEYOND THAT INTO AN
ECONOMY WHERE WE HAVE.
BUT THAT THEY ARE CLEANER
BIOMASS PLANTS WHETHER WE ARE
USING THIS WASTE PRODUCT TO MAKE
TRANSPORTATION FUELS.
ON THERE'S A LOT OF OPTIONS OUT
THERE BUT THESE ARE THINGS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO
DO THAT AND HOW WE AND SENSE
THOSE THINGS.
AND I THINK THE CHALLENGE RIGHT
NOW IS THERE ARE AND WE HAVE TO
FIND PLACES TO PUT THIS WASTE
RIGHT NOW AT THE PERFECT
SOLUTION THIS IS LOOKING AT THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WE NEED ON THE
GROUND SORT OF IN THE REALITY
THAT WERE LIVING AND I'M.
I I WAS ACTUALLY --
AND ENCOURAGED BECAUSE OVER THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS I'VE HAD
MEETINGS WITH A COUPLE DIFFERENT
GROUPS OF FOLKS THAT ARE LOOKING
AT HOW CAN WE TAKE FOREST WASTE
HOW CAN WE TAKE AGRICULTURAL
WASTE.
AND MAKE PRODUCTS OUT OF IT THAT
WE COULD SELL AND THIS IS KIND
OF A A WIN WIN WIN IT GIVES US
SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE WASTE
IT PROVIDES ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN THESE RURAL COMMUNITIES --
IT AND IT MERE DEPENDING ON HOW
THE PROJECTS ARE DONE CAN HELP
US FROM A CLIMATE PERSPECTIVE SO
I THINK THAT THOSE ARE THE KINDS
OF WINDS THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR IS WERE THINKING
ABOUT THIS GOING FORWARD
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
I KNOW ANY QUESTIONS.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL --
AS A NEW MEMBER OF SUB THREE
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY IMPORTANT
PRESENTATION --
I AND I AGREE MISS ELLERS THAT
WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT THIS.
EVERY YEAR OUT ON A REGULAR
BASIS WE CAN'T WAIT TO THE END
OF FIVE YEARS AND SAY WE SPENT
FOR A BILLION DOLLARS WHAT WE DO
AND DID WE REACH.
THE THE GOALS THAT WE HAD SET
OUT TO DO.
THAT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE A
GOAL FOR ME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE KEEPING TRACK AND WE ARE.
WE DO HAVE METRICS --
WE WE WE DO HAVE.
THAT WE DO REACHING GOALS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS OTHERWISE AT THE
END OF FIVE YEARS IN THE BILLION
DOLLARS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE TALKING TO
THE TAXPAYERS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE DIDN'T DO WHAT WE SHOULD
HAVE DONE.
I I DID HAVE A QUESTION FOR MS
LOTUS -- AT
THE BEGINNING OF YOUR COMMENTS
YOU SAID THAT THERE WERE SIXTY
PROJECTS.
AND YOU MENTIONED IT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES.
CAN YOU REPEAT WHAT YOU SAID
PLEASE --
SURE OF COURSE SO --
SPECIFICALLY I THINK I SAID OVER
SIXTY PROJECTS I LIKE TO HEDGE
IN THAT WAY OKAY --
AND AT THE HAVE BEEN AWARDED A
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO CANCER THAT IS --
THREE THREE THREE BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS AND FISCAL YEAR
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN ONE IN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND THEN --
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
ALLOCATION HAS ALSO BEEN AWARDED.
I AM WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF OF
SELECTING PROJECTS FOR THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ALLOCATION OF
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION.
FOR THE FOREST HEALTH ARE ARE WE
SAYING IT'S AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY
PROJECTS A YEAR.
AND SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN THAT IN THAT FOR
THE VERY FIRST YEAR IN FISCAL
YEAR --
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN CAL FIRE
DISTRIBUTED THE FUNDING THROUGH
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND SO WITH
THAT YOU'RE A BELIEVE WE
ACTUALLY --
AWARDED THIRTY FOUR PROJECTS AND
AND THEY WERE MUCH SMALLER.
AND MANY --
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THEN IN FISCAL YEAR SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN ALL OF THOSE PROBLEMS
PROGRAMS GOT ROLLED UP INTO THE
FOREST HEALTH OF PROGRAM OR MANY
OF THEM DID.
AND THEN WE STARTED --
AWARDING MUCH LARGER AND ONE TO
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR PROJECTS
THAT WERE REALLY LOOKING AT
INTEGRATING A NUMBER OF
ACTIVITIES WHERE WE WE ASK
APPLICANTS TO BRING US PROJECTS
THAT HAVE --
SEE -- YOU
KNOW USUALLY THREE OR MORE OF
THE ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES IN THE
THE PROJECT LINE UP SO THEY'RE
DOING REFORESTATION AND FUEL
REDUCTION IN DIFFERENT AREAS OF
THE WATERSHED IN WAYS THAT
COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER FOR THEIR
THE GOALS OF THAT COMMUNITY.
AND AND SO IN IN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN WE AWARDED SIX
PROJECTS AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
WE WERE.
TO TWENTY TWO SO HOPEFULLY
THAT'S MORE THAN.
SIXTY IT IS I THINK.
SIXTY TWO I'M SURE IT IS IF YOU
SAID IT WAS OVER.
SIX AND I ALSO WANTED TO COMMENT --
MISTER BRIGHT.
COMMENT THAT YOU MADE TO THAT WE
NEED TO THINK BROADER THAN THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS WE FACE NOW.
AND THAT GOES BACK TO THE SAME
THING WE HAVE TO HAVE A BIGGER
PLAN.
AND WE NEED IT'S ALL SMALL
PROJECTS BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
BIG PLAN.
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE A GOAL
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO REACH IT WE
HAVE TO STATE THE GOLDEN KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO REACH IT WE
NOW HAVE FOR THE FIRST TIME A
BILLION DOLLARS.
OVER FIVE YEARS --
I I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
ABOUT THIS SHOULD MANAGE IT SOME
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING MORE
ABOUT HOW IT IS BEING MANAGED
AND TO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
HAVE IT.
IN THE RIGHT DEPARTMENT UNDER
THE RIGHT LEADERSHIP --
TO MAKE SURE WE GET THE BIGGEST
BANG FOR THE BUCK AS THEY SAY.
BUT THANK YOU ALL I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU I HAVE ONE QUESTION.
IT'S IT'S EXCITING TO SEE THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND GROUPS
WORKING TOGETHER AND THE
COLLABORATION BEEN ABLE TO
FOSTER OVER THE YEARS AND A
HIGHER EXPANDING THAT ASK MONIES
QUICKLY BEING INFUSED AND HOW
YOU'RE WORKING TO FIND WAYS TO
EXPEDITE THAT AND EMPOWER THE
LOCAL GROUPS.
OUT THERE --
I HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT SPECIFIC
THINGS WERE DOING RIGHT NOW AND
ACCOUNTABILITY --
AND MAKING SURE THAT.
COM A YEAR FROM NOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME CLEAR IT'S SOME CLEAR
METRICS AND TRANSFORMATION ARE
DELIVERING TO THAT AND I
UNDERSTAND SHORT TERM VERSUS
LONG TERM IT'S GONNA TAKE
DECADES TO MAKE SURE SOMETIMES
THAT WE ARE GOING ON THAT PATH
WHEN DID WE PROJECT PROPERLY.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT AND NOT
JUST A FIVE YEARS BUT A YEAR
FROM NOW WHAT ARE WE TELLING
THESE TROOPS ON THE GROUND THAT
THE NEED TO BE DOING HOW WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
ARE THEY WERE OF THAT ARE WE
GOING TO FIGURE THAT OUT
[inaudible]
LATER.
WHEN I GET NEARLY KILLS --
FOR WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
LAST YEAR --
WE IMPLEMENTED A MONITORING
PROGRAM WE HIRED A STAFF PERSON.
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING WE WE
RECOGNIZE WE WEREN'T ABLE TO GO
OUT AND MONITOR EVERY PROJECT --
ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF OUR
GRANT AGREEMENT IS THAT --
GRANTEES ARE TO REPORT BACK TO
US ANNUALLY SO THAT WE RECEIVE
THE ANNUAL REPORT OF THE
MONITORING THAT THEY DO ON THE
GROUND.
SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE
ALL OF THOSE BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE
AS THE VERY VERIFICATION OF THE
INFORMATION CONTAINED THOSE
REPORTS.
SO WE DID WE LOOKED AT THE TOTAL
SUITE OF PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE
DONE.
OVER THE YEARS AND WE'VE FUNDED
OVER AND RECOGNIZING THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE WE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO GO OUT AND LOOK AT
PROJECTS ALL OF THOSE PROJECTS
AT ONCE --
WE ATE WE REQUIRED STAFF THAT WE
SELECTED A HUNDRED PROJECTS AND
IT WENT ACROSS ALL.
A IT WAS A REALLY GOOD
REPRESENTATIVE EXAMPLE OF THE
KINDS OF ORGANIZATIONS AND THAT
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS WE WILL
WORK WITH --
IN OUR GRANTING PROGRAMS AND THE
STAFF IS GONE OUT --
WE'VE CREATED.
A ARE WORKING ON CREATING AN
APPLICATION THAT YOU CAN TAKE
APPLE IPADS OUT IN THE FIELD YOU
CAN UPLOAD REAL INFORMATION
TIMES TIME.
WHEN YOU'RE OUT ON THE GROUND
PICTURES INFORMATION YOU TAKE
NOTES SO ALL THAT STUFF IS IN
PLACE NOW?
AND STAFF --
COMPLETED --
IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR --
THE MONITORING OF ONE HUNDRED
PROJECTS.
AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT. 98%
OF THOSE PROJECTS WERE IN
COMPLIANCE OF THE GRANT
AGREEMENTS.
AND THEY WERE ALSO MEETING THE
TARGETS OF THE EITHER THE
CONSERVATION EASEMENT --
DOCUMENTS THAT --
OUR ON THE PROPERTIES OR THE
RESTORATION PROJECT WAS STILL ON
THE GROUND WAS STILL WORKING SO.
YOU KNOW IT.
IT WAS A GREAT EYE OPENING FOR
US THAT WE WE REALLY DIDN'T TAKE
THE TIME TO DO THAT.
BUT YOU KNOW WE DO WE ARE NOW
WE'VE WE'VE GOT THE THE PROCESS
IN PLACE AND WE'RE FINDING THAT
PEOPLE ARE REALLY SAYING WHAT
CITY YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING
WHAT THEY SAID THEY WERE GOING
TO DO.
WITH OUR FUN SO IT'S IT WAS A
GOOD THING.
HAD.
SOME SO I WOULD SECOND --
WHAT MISTER DONNELLY SAID --
AS THE GRANTING AGENCY THAT
SPANS TWENTY FIVE MILLION ACRES
IT'S IMPLEMENTED THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FOUR GRANTS TO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO DISTINCT
ENTITIES WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST
MONITORING REQUIREMENT.
OUR AREA STOP OR REQUIRED TO
VISIT PROJECTS ON A EVERY THREE
YEARS -- AND
ALSO OUR GRANTEES ARE REQUIRED
TO REPORT TO US THEIR PROGRESS --
AND THEN THAT IS VOTED ON THE
GROUND BUT AS WE THINK INTO THE
FUTURE AND THINK ABOUT --
HOW ALL WERE MAKING PROGRESS?
WHAT'S RESILIENCE AGAIN I'M OF
REFERENCE THE TAHOE CENTRAL'S
HERE INITIATIVE --
PROJECT THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
WITH SO MANY PARTNERS ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS OF THAT PROJECTS IS A
SCIENCE ENTERPRISE --
AND IN THAT EFFORT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IS ASSESSING --
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THAT
PARTICULAR LANDSCAPE AND LOOKING
AT THE NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TAKING ACTION ON THE
GROUND THAT KEEPS THAT AREA OR
MOVES THAT AREA TO A AND IMPROVE
STATE OF RESILIENCE OVER TIME.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT AND EXPLORING AND I
DON'T THINK WE'LL GET THERE IN A
YEAR BUT WE'RE GOING TO TRY.
IS IMPLEMENTING A RESILIENCE DOT
DASH BOARD AND NOT SOMETHING
THAT TRACKS MANAGEMENT.
ACTIVITIES OR WE ENVISION IT.
TILL --
ULTIMATELY TRACK MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES ON THE GROUND AND
REPORT OUR PROGRESS --
AS WE ACHIEVE THOSE ACTIVITIES
WHETHER.
WE'RE STILL WORKING OUT THE
DETAILS OF THAT AND WE'RE
WAITING FOR THE RESULT RESULTS
OF AN EFFORT THAT --
DOCTOR NORTH WILL YOU'LL HEAR
FROM IN A LITTLE WHILE --
AND OTHERS ARE DOING ON ON THE
GROUND THERE THE ASSESSMENTS OF
THAT THEY'RE DOING AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW ALL OF THAT FEEDS
TO THE PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND
THINGS THAT MISS SELLERS WAS
BLOOM WAS MENTIONING EARLIER.
INTO SOMETHING THAT.
ROLLS UP THE BENEFITS
COMMUNICATES THE BENEFITS.
GIVES LEGISLATORS AND OTHER
POLICY AND THIS IS A FUNDING
DECISION MAKERS --
SOME EVIDENCE OF WHAT THE VALUE
AND BENEFIT OF STATE INVESTMENT.
IS AND HOPEFULLY AT SOME POINT
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL INVESTMENT.
AND SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
ONCE WE TESTED IT'S ONE OF THE
INNOVATIONS WERE TESTING IN THE
TAHOE CENTRAL SPHERE INITIATIVE
AREA ONCE IT'S TESTED INVENTED
THERE.
ARE HOPE IS TO ROLL IT OUT
ACROSS THIS YEAR AND ABOUT OUR
REGION RECOGNIZING THAT EACH
REGION IS DIFFERENT AND SO THE
METRICS IN THE INDICATORS THAT.
INFORM --
THAT DASHBOARD --
WOULD CHANGE AND SO CLEARLY
TRYING TO BASE ALL OF THOSE
THINGS THOSE ITEMS AND AND WHAT
GOES INTO THAT ON ON SCIENCE.
AND WE'LL OBSERVATION OF WHAT'S.
I WOULD JUST ADD TRADITIONALLY
THE WAY THE STATE HAS --
HAS HELD PROJECTS ACCOUNTABLE IS
DID YOU TREAT THE NUMBER OF
ACRES THAT YOU SAID YOU WERE
GONNA TREAT AND THEN NOW WE'VE
BROUGHT IN --
YOU KNOW SOME MATH OF OF HAVE WE
SEQUESTER THE AMOUNT OF CARBON
THAT BASED ON THE QUANTIFICATION
THAT THEIR BORDERS COME UP WITH
BUT IT'S BEEN PRETTY CONCRETE IN
THAT WAY.
AND SO I THINK THIS TYPE OF WORK
OF REALLY BRINGING IN SCIENCE
AND GOING BEYOND THAT AND SAYING
HOW ARE WE MORE RESILIENT.
CAN WE MODEL THAT THE IF A
WILDFIRE CAME THROUGH IT WOULD
BE LESS SEVERE CAN WE MODEL THAT
THERE'S GREATER WATER SUPPLY
THEM SNOW PACK BEING KEPT THERE
OR YOU KNOW MEADOW SOAKING UP
THE WATER AND WHEN WATER COMING
OUT.
THAT THESE ARE IT'S IT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE SQUISHY MEN DID
YOU TREAT THIS NUMBER OF ACRES
YES I DID BUT I THINK IF IT'S IF
IT'S BASED ON SCIENCE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF WORK THAT
REALLY THE STATE SHOULD BE
PUSHING FOR AND LOOKING FOR IN
ORDER TO REALLY ENSURE THAT WE
ARE GETTING THE TYPES OF
BENEFITS THAT WE WANT BEYOND
JUST.
THE CONCRETE NUMBER OF ACRES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I I DO HOPE
AS YOU'RE MOVING FOR THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST DID YOU DO WHICH
SAID YOU'RE GONNA DO BUT IS.
ARE YOU DOING WHAT WE NEED FOR
THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE ON AND SO
I HOPE THAT THIS INNOVATION.
SOMETHING THAT CAN BECOME A
MODEL I'M QUICKER THAN.
THE NOT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
WE'RE SURE FOR TIME --
AND SO OUR FINAL PANEL TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS IN ON THE
ROLE OF WATERSHED TH THAT WATER
SAID TO PLAY AS THE FOUNDATION
FOR A WATER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HOW OUR INVESTMENTS IN FOREST
AND WATERSHED RESTORATION CAN
HELP IMPROVE.
THE RELIABILITY OF OUR WATER
SUPPLY.
THIS IS QUESTION SEEMS
PARTICULARLY TIMELY GIVEN THAT
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO BE FOCUSED ON AN
ILLEGAL AN ILL ADVISED EFFORT TO
RAISE SHASTA THEM.
INUNDATING SACRED SITES AND
MILES OF THE WILD AND SCENIC
MACLEOD RIVER.
WITH THIS TODAY WE HAVE LAURIE
WEBERN PRESIDENT AND CO FOUNDER
OF THE PACIFIC FORCE TRUST.
AND M. VERSUS GUY WHO LEADS THE
LAND WATER AND EAT YOUR PROGRAM
AT THE RESEARCH FOR THE FUTURE.
AND MALCOLM NORTH PHD MR NOR
DOES THE RESEARCH FOR IS THE
COLLEGES WITH THE US FOREST
SERVICE PACIFIC SOUTHWEST
RESEARCH STATION.
AND FRET PROFESSOR EASY DAVIS I
AM THISIS POSSIBLE I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE TIME WE ARE
RUNNING LATE AS YOU SEE WE'VE
LOST MOST OF THE COMMITTEE --
AND MULTIPLE TEARS UP ALONG THE
WAY INSIDE APPRECIATE.
YOUR YOU WORKING WITH US AND I
DO APOLOGIZE AHEAD OF TIME FOR
GIVING YOU SUCH A SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME.
WE WILL DO OUR BEST AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING THE
HEARING AND THANKS TO YOUR STAFF
FOR HAVING PUT SUCH A GREAT
GROUP OF PEOPLE TOGETHER --
MY NAME IS LAURIE WEBERN I AM
PRESIDENT AND CO FOUNDER THE
PACIFIC FORCE TRUST.
OUR ORGANIZATION IS.
COMMITTED TO CONSERVING FORCED
RESOURCES FOR ALL THE BENEFITS
THAT THEY PROVIDE.
OF THROUGH BUILDING A
REGENERATIVE FOREST ECONOMY THAT
SUSTAINS PEOPLE ON THE PLANET IN
THIS ERA OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO.
WE'VE SEEN TODAY FIRE IS A
DOMINANT FORCE IN OUR WATERSHEDS
EITHER FOR ILLNESS WE SAW SO
MUCH IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN OR FOR GOOD AS WE ARE
INCREASINGLY SEEKING TO DO WITH
PRESCRIBED FIRE.
OF FIRE FLOOD AND DROUGHT ARE
DOMINANT FORCES IN OUR
WATERSHEDS AND TODAY YOU MIGHT
BE FORGIVEN FOR THINKING THAT WE
WERE BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WITH THE PREACHER THE OROVILLE
DAM.
BUT HOW OUR WATERSHEDS FUNCTION.
IS HIGHLY DETERMINATIVE OF THE
AMOUNT OF WATER THAT WE HOUSE.
OF THE WATER THAT FLOWS INTO OUR
RESERVOIR IS HAT DETERMINES HOW
MUCH WATER WE USE --
AND SO BY PUTTING OUR WATERSHED
NOT ONLY --
IMPROVE THE TOTAL AMOUNT AND
QUALITY AND TIMING OF OUR WATER
BUT WE CAN ALSO HAVE BENEFITS
ACROSS THE BOARD IN TERMS OF
MITIGATION ADAPTATION TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
UP FOR WHILE I FOR PEOPLE AND
FOR SUSTAINABLE ECONOMIES.
TOOK CALIFORNIA HAS PERHAPS THE
MOST SOPHISTICATED AND COMPLEX
PLUMBING SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
AND WE MOVE WATER AS YOU KNOW --
SIX HUNDRED PLUS MILES FROM THE
NORTH DOWN TO THE SOUTH ONE OF
THE THINGS DR THORN WAS POINTING
OUT EARLIER TODAY IS THAT SOME
WATERSHEDS HAVE IMPACTS THAT ARE
NOT JUST LOCAL BUT THEY ARE
RIPPLE ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THEREFORE WE WANT TO LOOK AT
IMPACTS NOT ONLY LOCALLY AS
YOU'RE POINTING OUT IN TERMS OF
METRICS ON THE GROUND BUT HAVE
WE ACHIEVED WHAT WE WANTED TO DO.
AND THIS NORTHERN REGION OF THE
STATE BOTH OVER THE PAST HUNDRED
YEARS AND PROJECTED GOING
FORWARD REMAINS WETTER AND
COOLER THAN THE REST OF THE
STATE.
AND INDEED WITH IN THAT AREA
THERE ARE FIVE KEY WATERSHEDS
THAT ARE THE BACKBONE OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT.
THOSE IVE KEY WATERSHEDS FILLED
THE DEEPEST RESERVOIR IN THE
COUNTRY AND THE LARGEST
RESERVOIR IN THE COUNTRY AND
THEY THAT BEING THE SHASTA AND
THE OR A BILL BUT THAT'S ALSO
THE SOURCE OF WATER FOR THE ST
LOUIS RESERVOIR FOR THE LOS
VAQUEROS.
SO THIS AREA OF THE STATE IS
WHAT IS CORE TO DRINKING WATER
FOR OVER TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS TO ALL OF OUR
IRRIGATED AGRICULTURAL LANDS AND
FOR INDUSTRIAL USES.
THAT'S AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
DEPENDENCE UPON JUST THOSE SEVEN
MILLION ACRES --
AS OUR PARTS POPULATION
CONTINUES TO GROW AND IS
CONCENTRATED IN URBAN AREAS THAT
RELIANCE WILL BE EVEN MORE SO
BECAUSE THE CENTRAL AND SOUTH
PART OF THE STATE CONTINUES TO
WARM AND DRY.
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS AND I
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THIS THIS
PROVIDE 7% OF THE POWER FOR THE
STATE THROUGH THE HYDROELECTRIC
CAPACITY OF THESE PROJECTS.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT SUB OPTIMAL
WATERSHED CONDITION THAT WE HAVE?
THREATENS NOT ONLY ARE AIR
QUALITY THROUGH THE FIRES BUT
OUR WATER SUPPLY AND THAT WE
HAVE TO APPROACH IT AS A WHOLE
AND THAT'S COME THROUGH IN MANY
OF THE COMMENTS FROM THIS
MORNING --
EVEN SCALING UP.
WE ARE STILL WELL BELOW THE
SCALE THAT WE NEED TO BE OUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SEVEN MILLION
ACRES.
AND COORDINATING INVESTMENTS AND
ACTIVITIES ACROSS SO SEVEN
MILLION ACRES REALLY REQUIRES A
DIFFERENT WAY OF THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE APPROACH OUR WATERSHEDS.
AND THAT WAY OF THINKING REALLY
IS CLOSER TO WHAT WE COMMONLY
USE IN INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING.
SO IF YOU'RE PLANNING TO BUILD A
DAM YOU DON'T SAY GEE I'M GOING
TO PUT DOWN A TON OF CONCRETE
THIS HEARING FIVE YEARS ALL PUT
DOWN ANOTHER TOWN A CONCRETE
NUMBER MAYBE ALL ORDER THE REBAR
AND I SHOULD HAVE SOME PEOPLE
LINED UP FOR THIS.
TO YOU WOULD SAY LET'S LOOK AT
THIS AS A WHOLE TOP TO BOTTOM
IDENTIFY OUR LABOR NEEDS ARE
PROJECTS SPECIFICS.
AND WHAT'S THE FINANCING THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE A IT UP BECAUSE
EVEN WITH A BILLION DOLLARS
ACROSS THE STATE IT'S VERY
LITTLE.
WHAT WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT IS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AS WE DO IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND WE
NEVER PLAN CANNOT?
SO THERE ARE A COUPLE OF NEW.
TOOLS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
TOOLBOX NOW AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY WHICH WAS MISTER BLOOMS
BILL IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN ACTUALLY CODIFIED
THAT WATERSHED ARE PART OF THE
WATER SYSTEM INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THE STATE.
AND ENABLED US TO BE THINKING UP
AND THAT WAY.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE OF LAST
YEAR.
PUT IN PLACE A CALL FOR PLANNING
AT THAT LEVEL TO HAVE AN
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN TO MOVE
AHEAD.
IN PARTICULAR IN THIS REGION.
AND THEN THERE'S A NEW FEDERAL
TOOL THAT I WANT TO FLY BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND THAT'S THE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE INNOVATION ACT.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
PROVIDING NEW FEDERAL GRANTS AND
FINANCING FOR WATERSHEDS ALONG
WITH THE WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING AND INNOVATION ACTOR
WITH VIA.
THESE ARE KEY TOOLS THAT CAN
SCALE UP THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE HAVE AT OUR DISPOSAL TO
DO THIS.
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO TAKE OUR
YOUNG HOMOGENEOUS FORESTS AND
RETURN THEM TO OUR MORE
RESILIENT STATE WHICH PRODUCES
MORE WATER AS WELL THE STORES
MORE CARBON.
DOING THIS CAN CAPTURE MORE THAN
70% OF THE SNOW THAT CURRENTLY
EVAPORATES ON THE TOP OF THESE
FORESTS AS WELL AS CAPTURE MORE
WATER THROUGH HAVING THE KINDS
OF TURBULENCE THAT.
CATCHES CLOUDS AND MILKS THEM IN
A WAY THAT CAN INCREASE WATER BY
10225% OF WHAT COMES IN WITHIN
THOSE WATERSHEDS WITH
SIGNIFICANT.
IF WE RESTORE OUR STREAMS WE CAN
HOLD THE WATER LONGER WE CAN
TAKE THE SETTLEMENT OUT OF IT
AND WE CAN RECHARGE GROUNDWATER
WE CAN ALSO REDUCE FLOOD
INTENSITY WHEN WE COMBINE THAT
WITH RESTORING WET MEADOWS.
THIS CAN REDUCE THE FLOOD
IMPACTS 12240%.
SO YOU CAN THINK BACK ON THE OR
A VILLAIN GO GOSH IF WE'D HAVE
THAT IN PLACE AND WE HAD A MORE
NATURAL HYDROGRAPH WOULD WE HAVE
HAD THAT DISASTER --
THIS IS KEY HERE IN LIGHT OF THE
CAMPFIRE AND THE RIM FIRE THE
SLIDE THAT IS ON THE LEFT THAT
IS THE AMOUNT OF SETTLEMENT THE
CAME DOWN FROM THE RED FIRE.
THE YEAR AFTER THAT CATASTROPHE
OCCURRED.
WE ALSO NEED TO KEEP OUR
WATERSHEDS WHOLE THINKING OF
THIS IS INFRASTRUCTURE AND NOT
FRAGMENTING THEM FURTHER NOT
DEVELOPING IN PLACES THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO DEVELOP.
AND WE WANT TO WORK WITH THE
HOME THIS IS THE FEATHER RIVER.
WATERSHED.
THE LARGE AREA COME DOWN TO THAT
LITTLE RESERVOIR.
HOW DOES ONE WORK WITHOUT?
THE GREAT THING ABOUT TOOLS THAT
WE HAVE TODAY IN OUR MAPPING IS
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT THINGS FROM
SPACE AND ANALYZE THEM THIS IS A
PART OF ANALYSIS THAT WE'VE DONE.
OF THE SEVEN MILLION ACRES IT
TELLS YOU WHERE DO WE NEED TO
WORK ON THESE STREAMS.
AND THAT FOR EXAMPLE PROVIDES A
GOOD TOOL TO THEN BUILD UPON AND
SAY ONE OF THE SPECIFICS OF A
PROJECT ARE WE DELIVERING ON
THAT PROJECT CAN WE TRACK THAT
BACK ON THE GROUND AND SHOW THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE --
AS WE'VE HEARD MANY TIMES TODAY
MANAGING ACROSS THE CHECKERBOARD
OF OWNERSHIPS IN A COORDINATED
FASHION IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
OBVIOUSLY WHAT'S ON THE LEFT IS
THE MAP.
WHAT'S ON THE RIGHT IS THE
ACTUAL LANDSCAPE AND YOU CAN SEE
THAT THE DIFFERENCES AND
OWNERSHIP LEAD TO VASTLY
DIFFERENT MANAGEMENT OUTCOMES
WHICH LEADS TO DIFFERENT WATER.
AS WELL AS CLIMATE THE FIRE OUT
COMES.
SO I WOULD BRING THIS DOWN TO A
SPECIFIC AND SHOW HOW ALL THESE
THINGS CAN COME TOGETHER. ONE OF
THE EMPHASES THAT WE HAVEHERE
IS WORKING WITH OUR NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WATER
SECURITY OUTCOMES AND FOR
CLIMATE OUTCOMES.
OF THE NATURAL APPROACH TO
ENHANCING WATER SECURITY WE CAN
LOOK AT WITHIN THE SHASTA A
NUMBER OF YOU ARE PROBABLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S MOVE AHEAD. TO
RAISE THE SHASTA DAM.
THEY HAVE USED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE NGUYEN ACT TO
DO PLANNING ON THAT TO MOVE
AHEAD.
AND YOU CAN SEE ON THE LOWER
LEFT THIS IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN
THIS IS WHAT IS PROJECTED TO
HAPPEN.
WHEN WE RAISE THE SHASTA DAM IF
WE FOLLOW THAT IT'S OF COURSE
ILLEGAL UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW BUT
IT HAS BEEN MOVING AHEAD NONE
THE LESS?
THERE WILL BE ZERO INFLOW
INCREASE AND AS I SAID EARLIER
WHAT FLOWS INTO OUR WATERSHEDS
INTO IT FROM OUR WATERSHEDS INTO
THE DANCE.
IS THE ADDITIONAL WATER WE HAVE.
THERE WILL BE NO MORE WATER.
THERE WILL BE NO SPECIFIED FLOOD
PROTECTION WILL BE SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED JOB YEARS.
THE IMPACTS ON FISH WILL BE
NEGATIVE ACCORDING TO THE FISH
AND WILDLIFE SERVICE.
THE IMPACTS ON CLIMATE CHANGE
WILL BE NEGATIVE IT WILL
INCREASE EMISSIONS.
IT WILL RARELY HAVE ANY INCREASE
IN SUMMER COLD WATER WHICH IS
THE WATER WE MOST NEED IT'S THE
MOST EXPENSIVE FOR AGRICULTURE
IT'S WHAT'S MOST NEEDED FOR FISH.
AND THE INCREASE STORAGE IS
POSSIBLE PERHAPS A THIRD OF THE
TIME.
UNDER A NATURAL APPROACH THE
INFLOW INCREASE WILL BE ON
AVERAGE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER YEAR.
EVERY YEAR.
IT'LL VARY YEAR TO YEAR BUT
THAT'S THE AVERAGE WE CAN REDUCE
FLOOD INTENSITY BY 12240%.
THE FIRE BENEFITS WE WERE
CALCULATING THESE PRIOR TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE NUMBERS THAT ARE TO DATE.
BUT THROUGH TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
WOULD SAVE AT LEAST A HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
WE HAVE THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN JOB
YOU'RE INCREASES SIGNIFICANT IN
TERMS OF THESE RURAL ECONOMIES
AND THE CIRCULATION OF DOLLARS
WITH IN WORLD ECONOMIES MANY OF
THESE ACTUALLY FALL.
IN THE MOST DEPRESSED NOT ONLY
IN THE STATE BUT IN THE COUNTRY.
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS FOR FISH A
CLEAR EXTENSION OF COLD SUMMER
WATER BY TWO TO THREE WEEKS AN
INCREASE STORAGE IN TERMS OF THE
TOTAL BENEFITS THAT ARE THERE.
NOW WE KNOW THAT WORKING WITH.
NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE IS.
CHEAPER --
THEN IN OUR TASK OF WILL BE
DISCUSSING THIS FURTHER BUT I
JUST WANT TO FLANK HERE WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE COSTS.
THIS IS FROM NEW YORK CITY IT'S
A CLASSIC EXAMPLE LET'S LOOK AT
THE COST OF OR A BILL A BILLION
DOLLARS IN EMERGENCY COST.
IT'S ESTIMATED TO BE TWO POINT
TWO FIVE TO TWO POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN REPAIR WHICH
WE SPENT ONE POINT TWO FIVE
ALREADY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE COST OF THE
SHASTA REYES IT'S VERY
CONSERVATIVELY ESTIMATED AT ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION?
IN. TWENTY EIGHTEEN DOLLARS.
THAT'S ALMOST FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. FOUR FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS WE COULD RESTORE THE
ENTIRE WATERSHED OF THIS AREA
THIS ENTIRE SEVEN MILLION ACRES.
NOW IN ADDITION.
WE WOULD HAVE MORE WATER.
WE WOULD HAVE LESS COST IN TERMS
OF FIRE FIGHTING WE WOULD NOT
HAVE THE IMPACTS IN TERMS OF
LOSS OF THAT YOU KNOW.
I FIVE TRANSPORTATION AS
HAPPENED WITH THE FIRES THIS
YEAR HERE FOR OF THE STATE'S
FIVE MEGA FIRES WERE IN THIS
REGION THIS YEAR HALF A MILLION
ACRES.
WE SPENT FOUR HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS JUST IN THIS
REGION.
SO THE BENEFITS OF WORKING WITH
NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE ARE
MANIFEST WITH THIS.
I'M I WOULD TAKE A MINUTE TO
FOCUS IN ON WHAT RACHEL ELLIS
WAS TALKING UP WHO'S CURRENTLY
PAYING FOR THESE WATERSHEDS.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE IN THIS
ROOM.
TAXPAYERS AND PRIVATE LANDOWNERS
WE DID THIS ANALYSIS SEWING ON
THE KINDS OF COSTS THAT ARE
COVERED UNDER AB.
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO RESTORE FUNCTION TO
WATERSHEDS.
AND SO WHAT WE CAN C. IS ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND AGAIN THIS
WAS AS OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
TOOK AN AVERAGE OVER THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS ABOUT THOSE COSTS
ARE THEY HAVE BEEN ESCALATING
EVERY YEAR.
THE QUESTION IS WHO BENEFITS --
WELL I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
PIECES HERE THAT IS MISSING AND
RACHEL WAS REFERRING TO THIS.
IS THAT THE TWO KEY BENEFACTORS.
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
AND THE STATE WATER PROJECT
WHICH ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR
SYSTEM.
OUR WATER CONTRACTORS AND
HYDROELECTRIC.
DURING THE DROUGHT FOR FOUR
YEARS THE COSTS OF P. GINNY TO
REPAIRS ONE UP BY TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
THE COST OF WATER IN AGRICULTURE
WENT UP FROM A HUNDRED AND FORTY
DOLLARS AN ACRE FOOT TO ALMOST.
A THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
AN ACRE FOOT
SO CLEARLY THOSE ENTITIES DO PAY
IN A TIME OF EMERGENCY.
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS COULD WE
PAY SIGNIFICANTLY LESS BUT IN A
MUCH MORE THOUGHTFUL WAY.
AND FINANCED AS WE FINANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE IF WE INCLUDED
THOSE BENEFICIARIES IN THIS
PICTURE.
AND FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S THE
APPROACH THAT NGUYEN TAKES THE
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE --
INNOVATION ACT.
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SHASTA
THE WATER CONTRACTORS WILL BE
PAYING INTO THAT?
A SINGLE BENEFICIARIES THE MAIN
OUTCOME THEIR WORDS IF WE PUT
THAT INTO THE WATERSHED WE WOULD
ALL BE BENEFICIARIES.
SO IN SHORT WORKING WITH NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A WIN WIN WIN
WIN WIN.
OF WHETHER IT IS FOR THE
WATERSHEDS THEMSELVES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES FOR THE RECIPIENTS
OF THE WATER IN THE BOTTOM PART
OF THE STATE AS A LOCAL SOURCE
OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
OR FOR THE FISH AND WILDLIFE
THAT ARE A KEY PART OF THE
HERITAGE OF THE STATE.
OF THE OUTCOMES.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
THE WATER SECURITY FOR THE STATE
AND THEY'RE MUCH MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENT.
WATER SUPPLY WRIT LARGE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT I'LL DIVE RIGHT IN AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
OF AND IT'S ALWAYS VERY
INSTRUCTIVE TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA HERE WE HOW MUCH IS
GOING ON HERE IT'S ALWAYS AT THE
AMAZING --
AND IT'S IT'S VERY INFORMATIVE
TO MAY WHAT I WAS ASKED TO DO
AND BY THE WAY MY MY NAME
SANDBAR TESCO I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR LAND WATER NATURE
OF RESOURCES FOR THE FUTURE
WHICH IS ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMICS.
THINK TANK IN WASHINGTON DC
THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE SINCE --
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO BUT I COME TO
THAT THAT POSITION GROUND THAT
US DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
MOST OF WHICH WAS FROM OF THE
FOREST SERVICE --
LAST WITH AS HEAD OF RESEARCH
FOR THE FOR SERVICE AS WELL AS
BEING VERY INVOLVED A LOT OF THE
NATIONAL FOREST MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES SO HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF BACKGROUND BEYOND THE
ECONOMIC SPACE --
SO THE REASON I WAS VERY EXCITED
TO TO COME HERE IS IS TAKING A
STEP BACK AND LOOKING AT THE
CONTEXT FOR THIS ISSUE OF
NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND
WATER AND FOREST MANAGEMENT.
AND ACTUALLY LAND MANAGEMENT
LAND MANAGEMENT AND GENERAL.
AND PART OF WHAT --
BRINGS ME TO THE TOPIC AREAS
WHEN WE STARTED PURSUING A
SERIES OF ROUNDTABLES FOR LAND
WATER OUR LAND WATER NATURE
PROGRAM AROUND WATER RESOURCES
I'M NOT TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHAT
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT TOPICS.
THAT WE COULD TAKE ON AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMICS THINK
TANK WE DID A SERIES OF REGIONAL
ROUND TABLES AND CHICAGO SAN
FRANCISCO DENVER HOUSTON OF AN
ENDING IN WASHINGTON DC.
AND OF A VERY SHORT LIST OF
TOPICS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
PROBABLY IN THE TOP THREE WAS AS
NOTION ACROSS ALL OF THOSE
LOCATIONS.
THAT SOURCE WATERSHED SOURCE
WATERSHED PROTECTION AN ACTIVE
MANAGEMENT WAS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE UNITED
STATES.
OF YOU PROBABLY KNOW THAT 50% OF
WATER DOES COME OFF OF OUR
DRINKING WATER COMES OFF
FOREST'S.
SO TO BE ABLE TO BE GOOD
STEWARDS OF THAT LAND TO BE
PROACTIVE IN MANAGING IT IS
CRITICAL NOT ONLY IN THE NEAR
TERM NOT ONLY FOR PARTICULAR
LOCATION BUT FOR THE NATION AS A
WHOLE.
SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT HAS LED US --
TO MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION OF
MY PARTICULAR INTEREST IS HOW DO
WE WHAT ARE THOSE UNDERLYING
PRINCIPLES I HAVE GOT EXCITED
ABOUT THE TOPIC.
AND I THINK PART OF IT IS THE
THE COST.
AND THE THE TRADE OFF IN COSTS
AND AND LAURIE CERTAIN IS
POINTED OUT SEVERAL EXAMPLES ON
HER PRESENTATION.
OF COURSE THE BIG ONE IS THE
NORDICS NEW YORK CITY WATERSHED
AND CATSKILLS MANAGEMENT AND A
CLEAR BENEFIT IN TERMS OF THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY SPENT ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION ORIGINALLY.
VERSES THE TEN BILLION TO
ACTUALLY DO THE WATER FILTRATION.
SO MANAGEMENT ECOSYSTEM ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION BRING WATER
FILTRATION SYSTEM REPLACE A TEN
BILLION TO CONSTRUCT A HUNDRED
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
OBVIOUSLY A VERY GOOD COST
BENEFIT RATIO AND THAT BUT
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF OF A
SERIES OF NOW DEVELOPING EGGS OF
EXAMPLES THAT WE HAVE AROUND THE
WORLD FOR HOW VALUABLE.
THAT NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE IS
FOR DOWNSTREAM WATER SUPPLY.
IT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT QUANTITY
IT'S ALSO ABOUT QUALITY AND I
THINK WE HAVE INCREASING
EXAMPLES WHERE THE THE QUALITY
OF THE WATER THAT COMES OUT OF
THESE SYSTEMS.
REQUIRES LESS FILTRATION LESS
TREATMENT THAT HAS DOWNSTREAM
COSTS ALSO BUT IT ALSO ALLOWS US
TO START THINKING ABOUT WATER IS
A WHOLE IT'S NOT JUST THE
DRINKING WATER BUT IT'S ALSO
INTEGRATING WASTEWATER STORM
WATER IN A MUCH MORE.
OF AN INTEGRATED MANNER THAT
INCLUDE STREAM.
BUT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE
HAVE IS THAT WHO PAYS FOR THIS --
AND THE THE EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE
ABOUT NEW YORK CITY IS ALSO
PLAYED OUT.
IN PORTLAND --
ACTUALLY PORTLAND IN NEW YORK
OUR TO ONLY FIVE LARGE CITIES IN
UNITED STATES THAT HAVE ON
FILTERED DRINKING WATER SUPPLIES.
TO THEM IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE
MANAGING THAT UP WATERSHED THEN
THE COSTS CLEARLY WORK OUT.
BUT IT DOES TAKE SUSTAINED
ENGAGEMENT TO TAKE SUSTAIN
MANAGEMENT.
AND THE PORTLAND EXAMPLE WHERE
THEY ACTUALLY PUT THEIR WATERS
BUT THERE WATERSHED IN
PROTECTION.
DOUBLE ONE WATERSHED IS THE
PRINCIPAL SOURCE FOR THE THE
WATER IT'S ASSOCIATE WITH THE
MOUNT HOOD NATIONAL FOREST.
AND THEY PUT THAT IN IN PLACE IN
THE LATE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
OF IT HAS BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE
AND BEING ABLE TO HAVE AN
UNDISTURBED VERY LARGE WATERSHED
SYSTEM TO BOOT TO BE OPERATING
WITH HIM.
HOWEVER MORE RECENTLY THEY'RE
FINDING THAT THEY'RE HAVING
CRYPTOSPORIDIUM WHICH IS A
FACTORY OF A PROBLEM DOWNSTREAM.
PARTLY BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD
WILDLIFE COMING AND PART MOSTLY
BEAR HAVE BECOME HAVE TAKEN OVER
THAT LANDSCAPE.
SO NOW THEY'RE ACTIVELY MANAGING
TO THINK ABOUT HOW DO THEY
ADDRESS THE WILDLIFE LINKAGES
THAT OCCUR WHICH HAVE OTHER THAT
BENEFITS.
AND ASIDE MOLD REALLY THIS IDEA
OF CREATE MANY MULTIPLE BENEFITS
BUT THE THE ACTUAL COST OF
PUTTING IN A FILTRATION SYSTEM
FOR THOSE THAT.
CRYPTOSPORIDIUM IS STILL FAR
LESS THAN WHAT IT WOULD HAVE
TAKEN TO BE PUTTING IN A MAJOR
FILTRATION SYSTEM.
AND RUNNING IT ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS IN THE OPERATIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
DENVER IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE MORE
DEAR TO MY HEART.
BECAUSE I WAS VERY ACTIVE IN THE
FOREST MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AT THE
TIME.
WHEN THERE WAS A VERY LARGE FIRE
IN THE THE IMMEDIATE WATERSHED
ON NATIONAL FORESTS?
THAT BASICALLY ELIMINATED TREE
COVER RESULTED IN THE MAJOR
SETTLEMENT LOADING ON THE DENVER
RESERVOIR AND THEY LOST PROBABLY
TWENTY TO THIRTY YEARS OF LIFE
OF THE RESERVOIR AND THE WATER
SUPPLY BECAUSE OF THE THE
SETTLEMENT LOADING.
THAT RESULTED IN A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE NATIONAL FORESTS WITH
MANY OF THE LOCAL BUSINESSES
WITH OTHER COMMUNITY GROUPS TO
REDUCE THE SEDIMENT LOAD BY.
ACTIVELY RESTORING THE FAR SO
HAVE SOME VERY CLEAR EXAMPLE OF
HOW THAT FOREST MANAGEMENT PLAYS
OUT.
BUT YOU STILL HAVE THE PROBLEM
AND THIS IS PART OF OUR AND SON
OF STRUCTURE ON HOW DO YOU GET
THE DOWNSTREAM BENEFICIARIES OF
THAT WATER SUPPLY. TO HELP PAY
UP WHERE THE STEWARDS ARE DOING
THE WORK AND THAT'S THAT IS
PROBABLY THE ONE LESSON TO TAKE
COME FROM MANY THE OF EXAMPLES.
THAT BY THE THREE EXAMPLES I'VE
TALKED ABOUT NEW YORK DENVER IN
PORTLAND IS THAT IT DOES TAKE AN
ACTIVE --
LEGISLATURE REGULATION OF ITS
CAPITALS VOLUNTARY AND HOW DO
YOU THAN WORK THROUGH IT AND
SOME OF STRUCTURE. TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE THAT LINKAGE.
AND PART OF IT FROM AN ECONOMIC
SPUR OF WHAT THAT WATER IS AND
AND WE HAVE VERY BAD REALLY
UNDERVALUED.
ACCESS TO WATER AND THE FLOW OF
WATER ON OVER AND NOT JUST.
IN THE UNITED STATES BUT OVERALL
GLOBALLY IT'S IT'S A IT'S
CONSIDERED A SOMETHING THAT WE
EXPECT TO GET BUT WE DON'T
NECESSARILY COSTED OUT. TO JUST
A FEW LAST MINUTE POINTS TO
REYES AND A FEW LAST THINGS AND
AND I I ALSO HAVE TO COMMAND THE
THE WHOLE MOVEMENT TOWARDS MORE
INTEGRATED WATERSHED BASED
APPROACHES AT A LANDSCAPE SCALE
SO THE EXAMPLE WE HEARD EARLIER
ABOUT THE SIERRA NEVADA.
WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM IS
REALLY A GREAT EXAMPLE OF MOVING
FROM A PROJECT SPECIFIC.
LOCAL A COMMUNITY SPECIFIC TO
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE DONE AT
A MUCH LARGER SCALE AND ALLOW
THOSE TRADE OFFS --
I THINK ONE OF THE THERE WAS A
QUESTION EARLIER ABOUT THE ROLE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES AROUND THE FOREST
SERVICE IN THOSE PARTNERSHIPS
ARE REALLY VALUABLE.
PUBLIC LAND THE FEDERAL LAND
MANAGERS WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
I COMMEND THE RISK RECENT FOREST
SERVICE STRATEGY ON TOWARDS US
CHAIRED STEWARDSHIP THAT IS
EXPLICITLY TALKING ABOUT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE FEDERAL
STATE TRIBAL AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. TO TAKE AN
INTEGRATED APPROACH.
BEING ABLE TO USE THAT AS A WAY
TO CHECK END OF ACTIVITY WHERE
NOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
PROVIDING FUNDS TO THE STATES TO
DO COOPERATIVE FEELS MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS. TO ME THAT IS A PART
OF THOSE GOOD NEIGHBOR IDEA THAT
HAS BEEN FLOATED.
BUT I STILL THINK WE HAVE THAT
PARTNERSHIP IS A GREAT EXAMPLE
BUT IT STILL REQUIRES RESOURCES
AND REQUIRES A STANDARDS. TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT TAKE THOSE
ACTIVE MANAGEMENT TO TAKE THAT
THE GOAL OF BEING ABLE.
TO WORK AT THE WATERSHED SCALE
WITH MULTIPLE ACTIVITIES TO BE
ABLE TO PUT INTO PLACE AND TO
PUT IT INTO PLACE OF PRIORITY
WATERSHEDS AND WE HEARD A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT.
TODAY BUT WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO
GET THE BIGGEST BANG FOR YOUR
BUCK WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO GET.
THE DANVERS AND THE SUCCESSES OF
THOSE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES WHERE
YOU HAD A LOT OF PEOPLE AND A
AND A VERY POSITIVE AND
SIGNIFICANT WAY.
A LOT OF GOOD WORK AND I I THINK
THERE'S THERE ACTUALLY I
PROVIDED A THE STATEMENTS THAT
HAS A LITTLE MORE DETAIL AND AT
THE WHAT I JUST WENT THROUGH BUT
I AGAIN I APPRECIATE.
BEING ABLE TO BE HERE AND THAT
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FILL IN SOME
IDEAS OF THAT I THINK ARE GOING
TO BE ECHOED BY MALCOLM OVER
THERE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE --
I GUESS I'M PROBABLY GOING LAST
BECAUSE I'M OF FORCED ECOLOGISTS
IS BEEN STUDYING THESE SYSTEMS
FOR A ALMOST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
NOW AND I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT KIND OF
WHAT MAKES THE FOR IT WORKS --
AND HOW WE WOULD STORE MORE
CARBON IN IT AND WHAT THE
ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS WOULD BE OF
DIFFERENT CONDITIONS IN THE
FOREST.
AND I'M GONNA CUT RIGHT TO THE
QUICK WHICH IS BASICALLY ALMOST
ALL OF MY RESEARCH AND EVERYONE
I WORK WITH HIS WORKED ON THIS.
HAS SHOWN THAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE ALL
THREE OF THOSE BENEFITS IN TERMS
OF IMPROVING WATER QUALITY AND
QUANTITY IMPROVING CARBON
STORAGE.
IMPROVING THE ABILITY OF FOREST
TO BE RESILIENT TO DROUGHT AND
ALSO TO BE RESILIENT TO WILD
FIRE.
BY RETURNING THE KIND OF
STRUCTURE AND THE CONDITIONS IN
THE FOREST THAT WE KNOW --
THAT WE'VE WORKED ON TO BE ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND OVER THE LAST FIVE
OR TEN YEARS AND SO I THINK IN
THIS CASE IT REALLY IS A WIN
CONDITION IN WHICH ALL OF THOSE
GOALS AND UP SYNERGIZE. TO A
COMMON.
GOAL OF TRYING TO GET THE FOR
INSTANCE THE RIGHT TYPE OF
CONDITION.
LET ME START WITH THE FACT THAT
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD HERE TODAY
IT'S PRETTY INEVITABLE THAT BOTH
DROUGHT AND WILDFIRE ARE GOING
TO BE INCREASING ITS THE NATURE
OF THE BEAST WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
WE HAVE A LOT OF EVIDENCE TO
SUGGEST THAT THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE A STRESSOR.
ON FORESTS.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO DO IS THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE THE
FOREST'S LESS RIGID MORE
FLEXIBLE TO BE ABLE TO ADAPT AND
RESPOND TO THESE TYPE OF
CONDITIONS.
GOING ON THERE.
AND WHAT WE OFTEN HAVE IN OUR
FOREST'S NOWADAYS IS KIND OF A
BINARY CONDITION --
YOU KEEP FIRE OUT WHICH IS THE
DOMINANT CONDITION IN MOST OF
THE SIERRA NEVADAS AND MOST OF
THE MOUNTAINS.
AND THE FORCE GETS REALLY CHOCK
FULL OF TREES IT'S VERY DENSE.
IT'S VERY HOMOGENEOUS THERE
ISN'T A LOT OF VERY ABILITY IN
THE MICRO CLIMATE THE PLANT
COMMUNITY IT'S PRETTY MUCH ALL
CLOSE CANOPY AND THEIR OR WHAT
HAPPENS IS YOU GET A BIG WILD
CARD THAT COMES IN OR DROUGHT
EVENT.
AND ALMOST ALL THE TREES DIE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IT
FLIPS TO BEING A VERY
HOMOGENEOUS CONDITION BUT IN THE
OTHER SENSE OF LACKING TREES
MOSTLY DOMINATED BY SHRUBS.
AND IN EITHER CASE IS OUTSIDE
THE RANGE OF HOW THAT FOREST
DEVOLVED AND HOW IT RESPONDS. TO
THESE KIND OF CONDITIONS BOTH
DROUGHT AND FIRE WHICH IS
EXPERIENCED IN THE PAST THIS IS
OUTSIDE THE RANGE OF THOSE TYPE
THE CONDITIONS.
SO THINK ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
WHEN YOU KEEP FIRE OUT OF IT. TO
THE BIG THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IS YOU REALLY INCREASE
THE FUEL LOAD IN THE FOREST
WHICH IS WHAT ALL THE SMALL
TREES ARE DOING.
AND THE OTHER THING TO THINK
ABOUT IS THE TREES ARE BASICALLY
STRAWS.
AND YOU GET TOO MANY STRAWS IN
THE GROUND.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU GET
A DROUGHT OF IT LIKE WE HAD A IN
THE SIERRAS IN THE SOUTHERN PART
WHICH IS TO THE PRIOR PART.
YOU END UP WITH A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DEAD TREES IN
THERE BECAUSE THERE'S TOO MUCH
COMPETITION FOR THE WATER.
AND SO THAT FORCE DOESN'T HAVE
THE ABILITY MORE TO FLEX TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND TO THESE KIND OF
STRESSES.
AND WHAT WE HAVE FINALLY FIGURED
OUT IS HOW TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THOSE FOR US MORE RESPONSIVE
MORE FLEXIBLE TO THOSE TYPES OF
CONDITIONS.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THE
KIND OF GETS VERY SPECIFIC HERE
BUT I THINK IT'LL SHOW HOW WE
CAN ACTUALLY BRING THESE THINGS
SYNERGISTICALLY TO BENEFIT ALL
OF THE RESPONSES.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
FORESTRY HAS FOCUS ON FOR THE
LAST. FIFTY SIXTY YEARS IS BIG
TREES QUICKLY BOTH FOR BOARD
FEET FOR FIBER FOR ALL OF THOSE
KIND OF PRODUCTS.
AND ONE OF THE WAYS OF DOING
THAT IS WHEN THE TREES ARE GONE --
YOUR RE PLANTING AREA YOU PLANT
TREES IT VERY REGULAR SPACING SO
THE OPTIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF SPACE
THEY HAVE TO GROW IN AND THEY
CAN GROW REALLY FAST QUICKLY.
WORKS FOR CORN ALSO WORKS FOR
TREES NOT TO SAY THE TREES ARE
CORN BUT THEY DO HAVE THE SAME
KIND OF RESPONSE.
THAT'S THE WAY WE WOULD HAVE
RESPONDED A LOT OF CASES TO
THESE FORESTS BEING BURNT OVER
OR TO THE TREES DYING FROM
DROUGHT.
BUT WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
SPECIFICALLY WITH A LOT OF
RESEARCH OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
IS ACTUALLY THE SPATIAL
ARRANGEMENT OF THE TREES REALLY
MATTERS.
AND IN PARTICULAR THAT
ARRANGEMENT MAKES THE TREES MORE
RESILIENT TO BOTH WILDFIRE AND
TO DROUGHT.
SO AGAIN AN EXAMPLE HERE.
WE WOULD HAVE SPACE TO TREAT
EVENLY TO MAKE THEM GROW FAST IN
THE PAST WE NOW KNOW THAT WE'LL
WE'D LIKE TO DO IS HAVE THEM
GROW IN CLUMPS.
WITH OPENINGS IN BETWEEN THEM
AND SCATTERED INDIVIDUAL TREES.
WHAT'S THE BENEFIT OF THAT.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THOSE OPENINGS
IN THAT KIND OF ARRANGEMENT
MAKES THE FOREST VERY RESILIENT
TO WILDFIRE WHEN IT COMES
THROUGH.
IT ALSO MAKES THE FOREST VERY
RESILIENT TO DROUGHT STRESS.
AND THAT IS NOT A WAY THAT WE
WOULD HAVE MANAGE FOR US WHEN WE
WERE MANAGING THEM FOR
MAXIMIZING BOARD FEET OR TREE
GROWTH PATTERNS.
BUT THAT KIND OF OPEN GAP GROUP
TYPE THE STRUCTURE IT ENDS UP
BEING EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR
BREAKING THE FOREST RESILIENT TO
WHAT WE KNOW IS GOING TO BE
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE.
THESE MORE COMMON OCCURRENCE OF
EXTREME DROUGHT EVENTS AND
EXTREME FIRE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO BRING UP THAT
POINT BECAUSE IT'S A BENEFIT NOT
ONLY TO THE FOREST'S RESILIENCE
IS GOING ON THERE.
BUT THE OTHER THING THAT'S
ACTUALLY REALLY IMPROVING WITH
IT IS WATER.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY IS IF
YOU HAD AS LAURIE WAS ALLUDING
TO IF YOU HAVE REALLY DENSE
TREES ALL WITH THE CROWNS
TOUCHING EACH OTHER.
WHEN THE SNOW COMES DOWN IN THE
WINTER TIME IT STAYS IN THE TOPS
OF THE CROWNS?
SOME OF IT MELTS AND GETS DOWN
INTO THE GROUND BUT A LOT OF IT
SUBLIMATES WHICH MEANS IT JUST
GOES STRAIGHT FROM THE SNOW
STAGE.
BACK TO WATER VAPOR IN THE
ATMOSPHERE YOU LOSE ALL THAT
WATER.
AND AS BEST AS WE CAN TELL YOU
PROBABLY INCREASE WATER YIELDS
OUT OF THE SYSTEMS BY 10220%.
BY HAVING SOME OF THESE OPENINGS
SO THAT ALL THE SNOW ENDS UP
DOWN ON THE GROUND RATHER THAN
STUCK UP IN THE TOPS OF THE
TREES.
YOU CAN HAVE THE OPENINGS TO BIG
YOU CAN HAVE MASSIVE CLEAR CUTS.
BECAUSE THEN ALL THE SUN COMES
AND IT MELTS THE WATER AND
BASICALLY FLUSHES --
THE SYSTEM WITHOUT A STORAGE
ABILITY.
SO YOU NEED THIS KIND OF PATTERN
AND THIS IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THE PATTERN AND THE
ARE KIND OF UNDERSTANDING
RESILIENCE TO PRODUCE THESE KIND
OF CONDITIONS.
FUTURE NOT ONLY GONNA MAKE THE
FORCE MORE RE.
YOUR PRODUCE MORE WATER COMING
OUT OF THE END OF IT.
END YOUR INCREASE THE STORAGE
CAPACITY BECAUSE MORE THAT WATER
IS STAYING AS SNOW.
RATHER THAN JUST ENDING UP AS
BEING FLUSHED DOWN THE SYSTEM
WHEN IT MELTS OUT DUE TO THE
SUNLIGHT.
SO IT'S JUST IT'S A FAIRLY
SIMPLE EXAMPLE BUT IT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE REALLY WORKED
AT TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW TO MAKE THE SYSTEMS
SYNERGISTICALLY BENEFITING?
FIRE RESILIENCE DROUGHT
RESILIENCE AND WATER THROUGH PUT
AT THE SAME TIME.
AND I THINK WE KNOW HOW TO DO
THIS STUFF NOW BECAUSE WERE
REALLY FOCUS LAST ON TIMBER
PRODUCTION AND MORE ON MAKING
THE FOREST ABLE TO WITHSTAND
THESE TYPES OF CONDITIONS.
SO HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD IN
SOME OF THESE THINGS.
I THINK ONE OF THE BIG THINGS IS
IS THAT OUR RESPONSE SO FAR
PARTICULARLY TO WILDFIRE.
AND ALSO FRANKLY TO DROUGHT HAS
BEEN A VERY REACTIVE RESPONSE.
WE'RE SITTING THERE TRYING TO
PUT ALL THE WILDFIRES OUT WHEN
THEY COME ALONG.
AND BASICALLY WE'RE NEVER GOING
TO WIN THAT GAME.
WE KNOW THE FIRES GET WORSE THE
FUELS KEEP ON BUILDING.
WE HAVE TO START WORKING WITH
FIRE RATHER THAN ALWAYS
SUPPRESSING IT.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S KIND OF
FUNDAMENTALLY RIGHT AT THE CRUX
OF THIS.
IS ONCE WE REALIZED THAT WE'RE
NEVER GOING TO IT'S INEVITABLE.
WE HAVE TWO CHOICES WE CAN
EITHER CONTINUE THE ROUTE WE'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW WHICH FRANKLY
THE FIRES KIND OF KICKING OUR
*.
OR WE CAN GET OUT THERE IN FRONT
OF IT AND TRY TO BE THE ELEMENT
THE PUTS THE FIRE MORE ON THE
LANDSCAPE.
WHEN THE WEATHER PATTERNS IN THE
WIND IS GOING TO MOVE THE SMOKE
AWAY FROM PEOPLE WE HAVE BETTER
CONTROL OVER THE FIRE BURNING AT
THE RIGHT TIME TO THE TENT CITY?
SO THAT IMPROVES THE HEALTH OF
THE FOREST.
AND WERE THE ELEMENT OUT THERE
THAT ACTUALLY DETERMINING WHEN
AND WHERE THE FIRE WORKERS TO
MAKE ECOLOGICALLY BENEFICIAL.
RIGHT NOW ABOUT 90% OF OUR FIRES
ARE NOT ECOLOGICALLY BENEFICIAL
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
REALLY COULD CHANGE HAS TRIED TO
PROACTIVELY GET OUT THERE FRONT
OF IT.
FINALLY ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
PROBABLY HEARD A BUNCH OF ABOUT
BECAUSE THIS IS IS A FAVORITE.
DISCUSSION OF OF POLITICIANS IS
PEOPLE SAY WELL YOU KNOW YOU
REALLY CAN'T GET MORE FIRE OUT
ON THAT LANDSCAPE.
IN A STATE WITH FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING
TO TOLERATE THAT AMOUNT OF SMOKE
THAT'S GOING ON THERE YOU CAN
HAVE TO THINK YOUR WAY OUT OF
THIS PROBLEM.
AND I GET KIND OF TIRED OF THIS
DEBATE BECAUSE IT WAS REYES ONE
TIME TO ME AND I RAN ALL THE
NUMBERS AND I WROTE A PAPER ON
THIS.
AND THE SHORT ANSWER IS YOU
CANNOT SEND YOUR WAY OUT OF THIS
PROBLEM.
THINNING IS HELPFUL IS VERY
USEFUL DONE IN THE RIGHT PLACE
YOU CAN DO A LOT OF GOOD.
BUT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO START
WORKING WITH AND SO THOSE TWO
THINGS HAVE TO GO TOGETHER AND
RATHER THAN NATTERING EACH OTHER
ABOUT -- WE
CAN IN OUR WAY OUT --
WE CAN BURN OUR WAY OUT FRANKLY
NO WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING THAT
WE CAN ALL THE TOOLS WE CAN TO
REALLY BE ABLE TO RESTORE THE
FOREST.
SO FINALLY.
WHAT KIND OF THINGS MIGHT BE
ABLE TO HELP IN TERMS OF
LEGISLATIVE ACTION OR WHAT'S
GOING ON?
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE ELEMENTS
THAT WOULD CHANGE OUR ABILITY TO
WORK WITH AND USE FIRE.
WOULD BE TO RETHINK OUR AIR
QUALITY REGULATIONS AND HOW AT
PRESENT THEY ACTUALLY MAKE IT
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO BE THE
ELEMENTS.
OF PUTTING FIRE ON THE LANDSCAPE.
AND PART OF THE PROBLEM THERE IS.
THE NEXT TIME YOU'RE OUT IN THE
FOREST.
NOT WHEN IT'S ALL COVERED WITH
SNOW.
IN THE SUMMERTIME LOOK DOWN WHAT
YOU'RE WALKING AROUND ON IT'S A
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF LEAF LITTER
AND BRANCHES AND SO FORTH AND
YOU THINK.
WOW THAT'S FUEL BUT IT'S NOT
ALONE FUEL THINK THAT WHAT
YOU'RE REALLY WALKING AROUND ON
IS SMOKE.
ITS SMOKE THAT IS WAITING TO
HAPPEN.
AND ALTHOUGH THAT LEAF LITTER
AND BRANCHES KONDIK HEY.
IT'S COMING IN EVEN FASTER FROM
THE TREES AND IT IS DECAYING OUT
THE OTHER WAY SO YOU'RE ALWAYS
GOING TO HAVE AT LEAST THAT
LEVEL SMOKY YOU'RE WALKING
AROUND ON AND THE LONGER YOU
DELAY PUTTING FIRE INTO THE
SYSTEM.
THE MORE SMOKE YOU'RE EVENTUALLY
GOING TO PRODUCE.
YOU CAN HAVE THAT SMOKE HAPPEN
LIKE INTO RIMFIRE EVENT WE'RE
ALL GOES UP AND GETS DUMPED ON
RENO AND EXPOSES THINK WE
CALCULATED SEVEN MILLION PERSON
DAY'S WORTH OF EXPOSURE DURING
THAT KIND OF FIRE EVENT.
OR AGAIN WE CAN BE THE ELEMENTS
PUTTING THE FIRE OUT ON THEIR
WHEN THE CONDITIONS LOFT THAT
SMOKE WAY UP AWAY FROM PEOPLE OR
TAKE IT AWAY FROM URBAN AREAS.
AND THE CALCULATION WE ESTIMATED
IS YOU WOULD HAVE LESS THAN ONE
SEVEN THE IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S
HEALTH.
THE WOOD BY WALKING AWAY WHICH
IS WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING
AND LETTING THE RIMFIRE EVENT
TAKE ALL THAT LEAFLET HER.
AND PUT ALL THAT SMOKE INTO THE
AIR AT THAT TYPE OF TIME.
SAYS ONE EXAMPLE BUT I THINK
THAT IF WE GET MORE PROACTIVE
ABOUT THIS WHOLE SYSTEM.
AND WE START BEING SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS OF MAKING THE
RECONSTRUCTION OF FOREST'S
HAPPEN.
WE CAN BENEFIT WATER QUALITY AND
QUANTITY CARBON STORAGE.
FOREST'S RESILIENCE WILDFIRE.
AND BENEFIT AND RESTORE THE
FOREST'S WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT.
WE WANT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MYSTERIES HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
COM JUST ONE WHEN THE MAP WAS
PUT UP -- MS
WEBERN.
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND BOTTOM IT SHOWED THE GLASS
TWENTY ONE MILLION OF WHO TO GET
THAT WHO WHO.
THERE THE DRINKING WATER WHEN
YOU COMPARE THAT TO ORGAN OR NEW
YORK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THERE'S THE SPACE BETWEEN THE
TOP WHERE THE WATER'S COMING TO
WHERE THE END.
THE END IS IS MUCH SHORTER HERE
YOU YOU'VE GOT A WHOLE LOT MORE
THE SPACE IT'S THAT IT HAS TO GO
THROUGH.
OF YOU HAVE BEEN UNDER THERE WAS
A COMMENT THAT WAS MADE ABOUT.
THE DOWNSTREAM BENEFICIARIES.
THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE -- AND
TO JUST JUST A WE WERE HEARING
ABOUT WATER IN BEVERLY HILLS
VERSUS SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS --
SO FIGURING OUT DUTY YOU YOU
CAN'T EVEN BAY THAN SOME OF THIS
WATER SO THAT THE PROBLEM IS
MUCH BIGGER BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE TOPIC FOR TODAY'S WILD FIRES
AND AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO TO MAKE SURE THAT --
WE PROTECT THE WATERSHED THAT WE
PROTECT THE THE LAND AND OF THAT
THE ERROR THAT WE ALL BREATHE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS AND I THINK THAT THE
IT'S MUCH BIGGER THAN.
THAN WHAT WE SOMETIMES THINK AND
YOU WE DO HAVE TO THINK OUTSIDE
THE BOX AND LOOK AT THE BOX WE
USED TO HAVE YOU KNOW.
NATIVE AMERICAN BROTHERS AND
SISTERS HAD THEIR WAY OF DOING
THINGS AND MAYBE WE NEED TO GO
BACK TO SOME OF WHAT.
WAS DONE DURING THAT TIME WITH
CONTROLLED BURNS AND SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT WERE DONE.
COULD I JUST MENTION THAT I
THINK --
YOUR POINT IS SO WELL TAKEN WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT INNER CITY LOS
ANGELES.
THE MOST RELIABLE AND CHEAPEST
WATER.
IS WHAT'S COMING FROM THE NORTH
STATE.
THROUGH THE STATE AND WATER
SYSTEM SO THOSE CONNECTIONS ARE
FAR GREATER THAN WHAT WE OFTEN
KNOW OR FEEL OR SEE.
AND THE CHOICES THAT WE MAKE IN
THE WATERSHEDS. FOR EXAMPLE
AROUND REGULAR INFLOW.
INTO THOSE HOLDING SYSTEMS THAT
ARE THE RESERVOIRS ON THAT PIPES
AND CANALS THAT WE THINK OF AS
THE WATER SYSTEM.
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON THE
QUALITY OF LIFE.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
YES THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS --
MALCOLM YOU YOU SAID THAT WHY
YOU THOUGHT YOU WERE THE LAST
FOR CENTER BUTI THINK IT WAS
JUST A GOOD BOOK AND I WE WERE
CARRYING ABOUT THE WORK THAT IS
BEING DONE AND WE HAVE INCREASE
ARE PRESCRIBED FIRES.
WE ARE WORKING ON X. WITH
ANYTHING THINNING IN TRYING TO
USE AS MANY TOOLS AND THAT
COLLABORATION.
I THINK YOU BOOK AND THAT IT TO
REMIND US WHY WE'RE DOING IT AND
WHERE WE NEED TO KEEP DOING ANY%
TYPE TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE ON
THE WORK THAT WE'RE ALREADY
DOING.
OUT THERE AND SAY I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PANELS THAT CAME
OUT TO SEE --
PERCENT TODAY UNDER DISCUSSION
THAT'S THAT'S ON PORT AND NOT
JUST FOR THE NORTH SEA BUT FOR
THE WHOLE STATE AND THAT INTER
CONNECTED.
EIGHTY AS THE TWO LEFT THE
REFLECTIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HERE -- IT
IS A GOOD REMINDER TO US WHEN WE
GO BACK THERE I AND IT'S UP
THERE BECAUSE WE NEED IT DOWN
THERE ALSO --
INTO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
I AND EVERYONE AT TESTIFIED
TODAY.
LEDGER --
I'VE SORRY ACTUALLY YES PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
I WOULD.
ASK US ALL TO BE AS BRIEF AND
CONCISE AS POSSIBLE.
WE HAVE TO BE OUT HERE AND EIGHT
MINUTES.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AT THING THANKS FOR
THIS AWESOME DISCUSSION --
THE WHICH IS VERY INFORMATIVE TO
ALL THE PANELISTS AND FOLKS FROM
FROM THE STATE THAT WERE ABLE TO
PRESENT --
FEDERAL KNOW ME HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
WANTED TO TO MENTION YOU KNOW AS
THE ECOLOGICAL PERFORMANCE
MEASURES ARE BEING DEVELOPED.
YOU KNOW SEE IN PS IS BEEN
TAKING A DEEP DIVE INTO THE
WEEDS.
ON REGULATIONS AS IT RELATES TO
EIGHTY FORTY NINETY TWO
IMPLEMENTATION FOR TIMBERLANDS
IN IN CALIFORNIA --
WHAT ONE OF THE? ONE OF THE CORE --
PREMISES ANY TO BE ADDRESSED IS
ACCESS TO TO GOOD RELIABLE DATA.
ON WHAT'S OUT THERE CURRENTLY ON
THE FORCE LANCE EDGE ON
SPECIALLY FROM THINKING WITH THE
SUB THREE HAD ON ABOUT THE WAYS
IN WHICH RESOURCES CAN BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO DEVELOP THAT DATA.
IN OUR FORCE LINES --
AND THEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN SPRING STREAMS
PARTNERSHIP AND THE CALIFORNIA
WHAT SHOULD NETWORK.
WANTED TO REALLY HIGHLIGHT --
CAYLEY'S COMMENTS ABOUT THE THE
BENEFITS OF THE WATCH ACCORDING
TO PROGRAM --
SPECIALLY AT BEING ABLE TO TAKE
THE REGIONAL APPROACH --
AND AND WORK ON MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LOCAL LEVEL --
APPROACHES.
TO ENSURING THAT OUR WATERSHEDS
AND ECOSYSTEMS ARE A RESILIENT
ESPECIALLY IN IN LIGHT OF ALL
THE CHANGES THAT OUR STATE IS IS
AN ARE GOING --
SO LEAVE IT AT THAT FOR NOW BUT
THINK YOU'LL APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY COMING. ONE OF THE
MEAT ON A WITHOUT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA WE AYE WE WANNA ECHO --
THE SAME COMMENTS --
FROM THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER AND
AND SO THE INVESTING AND THE
NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF WHAT
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN SAID.
IN A RELATED TO CLEAN WATER BUT
ALSO -- THE
AMOUNT OF A CO BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH WILDLIFE.
IN --
BENEFITS THAT.
BE A HEALTHY --
WATERSHED TAB SO THANK YOU.
HI ANNELIES ROAD DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AYE WE'VE THREE BRIEF
SUGGESTIONS THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE --
WE RECOMMEND THAT STATE EXPAND
ITS FOCUS FOR RESTORATION
PLANNING AND FUNDING PRIORITIZE
THE SOUTHERN SIERRA. TO ENSURE
THAT THE SOUTHERN TIER
WATERSHEDS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE TO RETAIN SNOW PACK LATER
IN PROVIDE IMPORTANT WATER
RETENTION SOME STORAGE FOR
CALIFORNIA IN ADDITION TO THE
NORTHERN ONES AS WELL OF COURSE --
WE URGENT INCREASE SUPPORT FOR
THE AT LOCAL REGIONAL EFFORTS TO
EXPAND THE USE OF GETTING MORE
FIRE ON THE GROUND FOR FOREST
RESTORATION EFFORTS AS WE HEARD
TODAY WE NEED. TO GET FIRE BACK
INTO THE ECOSYSTEM --
ESPECIALLY SINCE FIRES WERE ONLY
RESTORATION AND SCAPES DUE TO
TOMOGRAPHIC ADMINISTRATIVE
CONSTRAINTS.
OF FINALLY THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PROVIDED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWO DR A
FUNDS TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD.
FOR ONE CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY PROJECTS THAT
CONSERVE NATURAL WORKING LANCE
RELEASED FIFTY YEARS. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF CRIME ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE WILDLIFE AND TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT.
NATURAL WORKING LANDS ADAPTATION
RESILIENCY PLANNING THE
PRIORITIZE THE CONSERVATION AND
MANAGEMENT OF NATURAL WORKING
LANDS PROVIDES ASSISTANCE FOR
NETWORKING AND MANAGERS AND
SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO IMPROVE.
RURAL URBAN COORDINATION ON
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROGRAM IN THE BUDGET THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN A WIKI
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR HAVING THIS
PANEL A TO THE COMMITTEES --
I DON'T THINK WE ALL AGREE WITH
ALL OF THE SPECIFICS AND DETAILS
WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY BUT I AM.
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THAT WE'RE
FINALLY TO SEE THIS DISCUSSION
WERE DIGGING INTO THIS ASPECT OF
THE ISSUE --
I THINK THE TALKING ABOUT THE
LARGE SCALE PLANNING.
AND WILDLIFE IMPACTS AS WELL AS
THE THE THE ECOLOGICAL CRITERIA
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN LEFT OUT
OF OUR DISCUSSION IN FACT
CONTINUES.IN MANY WAYS TO BE LEFT OUT
BECAUSE SO OFTEN ARE FUNDING AND
OUR ACTION ON THIS IS DRIVEN BY
THE CRISES WHEN COMMUNITIES
HOMES AND LIVES ARE THREATENED.
AND ON THAT I WANT TO I WANT TO
THE END AND THE SPEAKERS TODAY
IS LIKE I FELT LIKE IT WAS
IMPLICIT BUT THAT WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE THAT DISTINCTION
BETWEEN ALL OF THE WORK AND ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT THINKING THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE OUT IN THE
FOREST.
VERSES THE PROTECTIONS THAT HAVE
TO BE GIVEN FOR COMMUNITIES.
HOUSES AND LIVES THAT THOSE ARE
TWO SEPARATE THINGS THAT NEED TO
BE DEALT WITH SEPARATELY AND AND
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
BIOMASS UTILIZATION CAME UP A
FEW TIMES TODAY.
AND I JUST WANTED --
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE STATE
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZING NANI
MISSION BIOMASS UTILIZATION.
AND SHOULD ALWAYS PRIORITIZE --
ECOLOGICAL CONSIDERATIONS FIRST
THAT.
WE DON'T CREATE MORE OF A DEMAND.
FOR WHAT THEN A PARTICULAR AREA
CAN SUPPLY IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE AS WE'RE TRYING.
TO SEQUESTER CARBON ON AYE
LANDSCAPE.
PRESS TO REMOVE TRAYS AND THEN
BURN THEM AND PAUL HUGHES WITH
FORCED FOREVER --
WE FEEL GENERALLY VERY GOOD
ABOUT THE INCOMING NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION IN THE HOPE IT
HOLDS.
FOR GOOD POLICY ON WILD FIRE
RESILIENCE AND WATERSHED HEALTH.
ARE SPECIALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
CONTROLLED BURNING --
AND WANT TO SEE MORE OF THAT OUT
BUT WERE SKEPTICAL OF THE
EFFORTS TO REMOVE.
DEAD TREES EITHER IN THE FORM OF
PRE FIRE OR POST FIRE SALVAGE
LOGGING PROGRAMS.
THAT WE NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT A INCREASING AND VERY
LARGE GROWING UP BODY OF
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT SNACK
FORESTS ARE GENERALLY LESS
FLAMMABLE.
THAN GREEN TREES THE FINE FUELS
AND VOLATILE OILS DISAPPEAR
FAIRLY QUICKLY AFTER THE TREES
DIE.
AND THOSE FOREST'S SPEC FORESTER
UNDER REPRESENTED HISTORICALLY
AND IN TERMS OF BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY RIVAL OLD GROWTH TREES
ARE NOT THE ENEMY.
HARDENING HOMES IS WHERE THE
ACTION IS AT THERE ARE TWO
THINGS THAT WERE SUPPORTING THAT.
YOU'LL BE SEEING SOON WE HOPE
ARE ONE IS US SENATE BILL NINE
NO ONE CLEAN UP --
WE FEEL IT WAS ENACTED IN HASTE.
A AND NEEDS MORE ATTENTION TO
THE MAXIMUM DIAMETER TREES THAT
CAN BE REMOVED WITH A NOTICE OF
INTENT EMERGENCY HARVEST NOTICE
OF INTENT.
A AM TO CAL FIRE RUDIMENTARY
INSPECTIONS OF THOSE.
OF ENOUGH OPERATIONS NEED TO BE
PUT BACK IN PLACE.
AND THE SECOND BIGGER ONE IS
THAT THERE IS A CONFLICT WITHIN
THE AGENCY RIGHT NOW CAL FIRE.
IT'S 90% THE FIREFIGHTING AGENCY
ONE OF THE WORLD'S BIGGEST AND
BEST WE APPLAUD THAT WANT TO SEE
THAT ROLE EXPANDED.
BUT THERE'S LITTLE QUESTION NOW
THAT IT IS DOING A THE
SAFEGUARDING OUR PUBLIC TRUST
VALUES.
F WATERSHED HEALTH WATER
QUALITY WILDLIFE AND SO ON AT
ROUTE IS A CONFLICT BETWEEN ITS
FORESTRY THAT IS TIMBER HARVEST
REGULATION.
AND FIREFIGHTING FUNCTIONS
FORESTERS ARE TAKEN OFF LINE
FROM THEIR FORESTRY DUTIES WHEN
CALLED TO FIGHT FIRES WHICH IS
ALMOST CONSTANT NOW.
AND THERE IS AN INCREASING
INTEREST IN SEPARATING THOSE TWO
FUNCTIONS.%
AB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO CALLS FOR
MORE EFFECTIVENESS AND
EFFICIENCY.
IN REGULATING LOGGING WE FEEL
THAT SEPARATION WOULD DO THAT.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT SAID THAT
MORE COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
BETWEEN AGENCIES.
ESPECIALLY IN NATURAL RESOURCES
IS NEEDED.
OUGHT TO SAFEGUARD PUBLIC TRUST
VALUES IN CALIFORNIA CANNOT DO
IT ALONE.
SO WE NEED TO CONSOLIDATE CAL
FIRES OF ACTIVITIES AROUND ITS
CORE MISSION OF FIRE FIGHTING --
LET FIREFIGHTERS DO WHAT THEY DO
BETTER WITH LESS INTERFERENCE
FROM.
OF FORESTERS WHO ARE LESS
TRAINED AND EXPERIENCED A LOT
FORESTERS DO THEIR PARAMOUNT WE
IMPORTANT JOB OF REGULATING THE
END GREENHOUSE SEA QUEST
[inaudible]
STAY TUNED.
CURRENTLY ON BACK AUTHORED A
LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THERE'S NO MORE
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT THANK
EVERYONE WHO ATTENDED TODAY WE
WILL BE ADJOURNING